foreign
the house will come to order members
take your seats
so
members take your seats
[Music]
so
the house will come to order members
take your seats
the chair recognizes the member from
auburn representative osborne who's the
house adjourned from the session about
16 2022
are you ready for the question all those
in favor say aye
those opposed nay the eyes have it in
the house is adjourned
the house will attend to a prayer by
house chaplain reverend bob stewart
pastor of saint paul's united methodist
church in manchester
good morning my friends
let me start by offering you a irish
blessing for
saint patty's day
may love and laughter light your days
and warm your heart and home
may good and faithful friends be yours
wherever you may roam
may peace and plenty bless your world
with joy that long endures
may all life's passing seasons bring the
best to you and yours
a loving god
in you we can be a transformation for
others
when the discouraged cry for hope
help us to be an encourager
when the hungry cry for bread
help us lead them to finding food
when the thirsty cry for water
help us lead them to a drink
of water
when the suffering cry for help
let us be their helping hand
when the sick cry for healing
let us pray to you
for your healing touch
when the outcasts cry for love
let us be your love o compassionate god
look down with mercy on
the ukrainian people
protect and save them from the unjust
aggressors
who seek to subdue
them grant them steadfast trust in your
mercy and protection
and we also seek prayers for the russian
people
who do not want any part of this
aggression
oh god please help everyone learn
that you are a god of peace and love
oh god i once again ask for prayers for
all my brothers and sisters
through you that are gathered here today
i pray for their health and safety
as they lead this great state of new
hampshire
be with them as they work hard to make
the best decisions based on that which
is presented before the house today
give them the wisdom and guidance
they need
and be with all the leadership of the
house of representatives
and i ask that your hand be upon each
leader
to give them the strength and courage
to lead
oh god we pray all this to glorify only
you
for you are our shalom
amen
the chair recognizes the member from
loudoun representative howard pearl who
will lead us in the pledge of allegiance
[Music]
the chair recognizes don taylor our door
keeper from loudon who will now perform
the national anthem
[Music]
[Applause]
the house will attend to request release
of absence
mr speaker the day illness
representatives birch cleaver connors
ellis gorg mary griffin heath hopper
kennedy lawton lundgren milor newton
salloway sofikidas spang stevens tudor
vale
the day important business
representatives buras bradley cody
crawford cross diesel vestro frost
harvey hunt mills the day illness in the
family representatives davis and elliot
these leaves of absence shall be grant
unless otherwise ordered by the house
house will attend the introduction of
guests
mr speaker please welcome james tebow
student from winnisquam regional high
school our page for the day
[Applause]
mr speaker please also welcome muriel
and john stickney grandparents of
representative belanger faye linda
tafalt guest of representative pearl
mayor q carino cousin of representative
yokela
marguerite moffat and beth boardman
mother and wife of representative moffat
they're with us in the gallery today
welcome to the new hampshire house
[Applause]
chair recognizes representative notter
thank you mr speaker
last night i gave an a parliamentary
inquiry
that crossed a line in delivery
i knew immediately that i upset some
people
including you mr speaker
when i sat back down i saw the look on
your face and i thought oh no
i own it that my words were harsh and
they lacked prudence
it pains me to know that i disappointed
you mr speaker
and you mr clerk and the others i
apologize to those i offended and i ask
for your forgiveness thank you
[Applause]
the house will now attend a continuation
of the regular calendar beginning with
house bill 1053 from the committee on
labor and open data services
the majority of the committee on labor
and industrial and relativity of
services to which was referred house
bill 1053
an act relative to the hourly rate paid
to an employee for hours worked but not
previously scheduled considered the same
report the same with the following
resolution resolved that is inexpedient
to legislate senator mark warden for the
majority of the committee
minority of the committee having
considered the same inevitable to agree
with the majority report the
recommendation that the bill ought to
pass presenter joshua adjunct for the
minority of the committee
the motion before us is the committee
report of inexpedient to legislate are
you ready for the question all those in
favor say aye
those opposed nay
the eyes have it and committer report is
adopted
majority of the committee on labor and
industrial and relevant rehabilitative
services to which was referred
house bill 1076 an act relative to
illegal productivity quotas have been
considered the same
report the same with the following
amendment the recommendation that the
bill ought to pass with amendment
representative josh adjunct for the
majority of the committee
minority of the committee having
considered the same being unable to
agree with the majority report with the
following resolution resolved that is
inexpedient to legislate senator glenn
turcotte from the minority of the
committee what reason does the member
rise
for a motion mr speaker stage in motion
i make a motion that we table hb 1076
it is a proper motion the motion before
us is to table house bill 1076.
a division has been requested members
take your seats
so
this is a division
vote
yes
a roll call has been requested is that
sufficiently seconded
it is sufficiently seconded this will be
a roll call vote members take your seats
so
the motion before us is the table house
bill 1076
chair recognizes representative turcotte
for parliamentary inquiry
thank you mr speaker good morning
colleagues mr speaker if i know that
considerable time will be saved by
avoiding a debate to overturn the motion
of otp then a motion of itl
would i now press a the green button to
table hb 1076
j recognizes representing adjutant for a
parliamentary inquiry
thank you mr speaker
mr speaker if i know that in the labor
committee during the executive session
on this bill
the totality of the debate
was me thanking the chair of the labor
committee for the weeks of bipartisan
work that we did to craft a committee
amendment that came out otp to you all
the midnight ols amendments all the work
that we did to make that happen and how
grateful i am of him to that
if i know that the chair himself would
like to have the debate on this bill
and lastly mr speaker
if i know that if i spent this entire
last weekend calling my friends on the
republican side of the aisle
and like with every vote i told them i
will not ask you to vote unless you hear
a debate
and if i know
that they can't have they can't listen
to a debate
that doesn't happen would i now vote
read
to not have this tabling motion and
support the committee of the bipartisan
otp recommendation
the motion before us is tabling motion
on house bill 1076.
it's a roll call vote if you're in favor
you'll press the green button if you
oppose you'll press the red button
voting stations are open for 30 seconds
so
representative rollins
representative rollins thank you
so
this one
if all members president had an
opportunity to vote
house will attend to the state of the
vote 169 voting yeah 152 voting nay
the tabling motion on house bill 1076 is
adopted
mr speaker mr speaker
just a minute
for what reason does a member rise i
have a question for the chair
state your question thank you mr speaker
i've looked at the black book
and i've looked at mason's and nowhere
do i find a legitimate reason
for a deliberative body to choose not to
vote
because not to debate because it might
take time
can you tell me where
you can find a mention of a legitimate
reason
not to debate because of time
representative
smith
i don't believe that is a fair question
to me
i the body has a right to make any
motion they wish which both sides do
consistently
i thank you very much and mr speaker i
think you know that the last thing i
would ever do would be to challenge you
i have full respect for you and your
position as i do for the legislature
which is a deliberative body i'm i
really i'm sorry if you saw that as
anything personal to you it was not
for what reason does a member rise
thank you mr speaker good morning i rise
to make a motion to print the debate on
house bill 1673 into the permanent
journal
okay 16 1673
relative to women's health privacy and
repealing the fetal health protection
act the motion is to print the remarks
in the permanent journal correct
are you ready for the question
all those in favor say aye
those oppose nay
the eyes have it remarks will be printed
majority of the committee on labor
industrial and rehabilitative services
to which was referred house bill 1088
act relative to employee protections
from covert 19 in the workplace
considered the same report the same with
the following resolution resolved that
is inexpedient to legislate so greg huff
for the majority of the committee
minority of the committee having
considered the same be an edible degree
with the majority report the
recommendation that the bill ought to
pass representative brian sullivan from
the minority of the committee
the chair recognizes
representative horrigan
to speak against the committee report
thank you very much mr speaker
um
1088 an act relative to employee
protections from covet 19 in the
workplace its title is pretty
self-explanatory
it's the flip side to the many anti-vax
spills which have been introduced and
it says basically you just have the
right to be vaccinated against covet 19
and the right to use personal protective
equipment such as face masks and face
shields while employed in the workplace
and no employer shall discriminate in
any way against an employee based on the
employee exercising his or her rights
in this section and
so it is narrowly limited to covet 19
but it
and the two of these some well three one
of the assumptions behind her is that
the vaccines the mass are worthwhile
they may not be 100 safe but they're
extremely safe certainly much safer than
the disease
and the
same goes for the mass and ppe so
employees should be able to wear them in
the workplace to protect themselves
and
all workers have the right to protect
themselves it's killed nearly a million
americans 966 000 last time i checked
which is a couple of days ago and i
don't sp and um so
there have been a lot of famous cases
about it but there have been some in
here in new hampshire and certainly um
there were a number of employers who
made the business decision to shut down
who specifically cited the first the
uh
ppe he's
the mass mandates during the state of
emergency as a reason why they shut down
even though that's a business this
season they had many factors in it so
[Music]
so please uh
please protect the right of our workers
they have the right to protect
themselves and they certainly
no one has the right to spread a
communicable disease especially one as
terrible as covet 19 because even if you
survive there's the long-term
consequences are in some cases
quite quite horrific and life-altering
so please and also i believe your
employer does not have the right to tell
you
not to protect yourself against a
respiratory disease so please
please overturn the committee report and
vote for series
so an alternative motion
can be introduced thanks
do you recognize representative time to
speak for the committee report
thank you mr speaker
the labor committee only had one
individual speak in favor of this bill
and no one
against we have no evidence that there
is any discrimination or has been any
discrimination that has gone on for
someone unwilling or because someone
wants to wear a mask or a shield
get vaccinated or not vaccinated
you've all seen me wearing my mask
around here it's because i have an 84
year old mom i like to go see and it
makes her happy
that i have a mask when i'm in public
settings
that's my choice
no one's criticized me
and i have not heard anyone
from any walk of life any email any
anything
that shows that individuals have
discriminated because of this
i would ask you to follow the committee
and
don't
say this correctly don't try to have a
solution for a problem that doesn't
exist thank you mr speaker
the motion before us is a majority
motion of inexpedient to legislate on
house bill 1088 are you ready for the
question
all those in favor say aye
those opposed nay
eyes the eyes have it and the committee
report is adopted
before i get on to the next bill
we have
78 i think bill's left on the regular
calendar
we don't have any real
contentious debates as we had yesterday
quite a few have one-on-one and quite a
few don't have the base at all
so i uh we should be able to get through
this calendar
without too much trouble today so i just
wanted to let everybody know
that today's calendar isn't anything
like yesterday's
majority of the committee on labor and
industrial and rehabilitative services
which was referred house bill
1089 act relative to the
unenforceability of non-complete
agreements with termination of an
employee for non-compliance and with a
vaccination mandate considered the same
report the same with the following
amendment recommendation that the bill
ought to pass with amendment senator
brian seaworth for the majority of the
committee
minority of the committee having
considered the same being unable to
agree with the majority report with the
following resolution resolved that is
inexpedient to legislate representative
andrew manville for the minority of the
committee
the amendment is zero three seven six h
printed in house record 10 a page 13.
are you ready for the question on the
amendment all those in favor say
aye as opposed nay
you guys have it and the amendment is
adopted motion before us now is the
committee report about the past with
amendment are you ready for the question
all those in favor say aye
those opposed nay
eyes have it and the committee report is
adopted
majority of the committee on labor
industrial and rehabilitative services
to which was referred house bill 1094
act relative to employee work schedules
and rest periods if considered the same
report the same with the following
resolution result that is in expedient
to legislate senator linda turcotte from
the majority of the committee
minority of the committee having
considered the same being unable to
agree with the majority report with the
recommendation that the bill ought to
pass representative joshua accident for
the minority of the committee
the motion before us is the committee
reporter of inexpedient to legislate are
you ready for the question all those in
favor say aye
those opposed nay
the eyes have it committee report is
adopted
majority of the committee on labor and
industrial and
rehabilitative services to which was
referred house bill 1165 an act
repealing the granite state paid family
leave plan considered the same report
the same with the recommendation that
the bill ought to pass senator leonard
turcotte from the majority of the
committee
minority of the
minority of the committee having
considered the same being unable to
agree with the majority report with the
recommendation that the bill be referred
for interim study senator joshua
adjutant for the minority of the
committee for what reason does the
member rise to make a motion
state your motion
i moved to table bill
1165.
that is a proper motion the motion
before us is the table house bill 1
division
our representative proud has requested a
roll call is that sufficiently seconded
it is sufficiently seconded this will be
a roll call vote
he's in favor of the table
the motion before us is the table house
bill 1165.
chair recognizes representative sullivan
for a parliamentary inquiry
thank you mr speaker
mr speaker
if i know
the governor's granite state family
medical leave plan is not yet been fully
put in place and tested
and if i know that any family medical
leave is better than no family medical
leave
would i now press the green button to
table this premature repeal
thank you
i recognize representative turcotte for
parliamentary inquiry
thank you mr speaker
if i know there are private insurance
companies that are wanting to offer this
type of fmli insurance to private
businesses on the open and free market
here in new hampshire without the need
for any bureaucratic involvement
and if i also realize we have a short
window of opportunity
to remove the granite state fmli plant
from our rsas while still in its infancy
and prior to it being fully implemented
later this year or early next year
and finally mr speaker if i know by
failing to remove from our books
legislation that was wrongly slipped
into hb2
we will forever
after be stuck with yet another
taxpayer-funded social entitlement
scheme
then would i press the red button
to allow
full consideration of the otp motion on
hb1165 thank you mr speaker the motion
before us is to table house bill 1165.
this is a roll call vote if you're
unfavorable press the green button if
you oppose you'll press the red button
voting stations are open for 30 seconds
[Music]
representative downville
while members president had an
opportunity to vote also attend the
state of the vote
160 voting a 172 vote in a the motion to
table fails
chair recognizes representative adjunct
to speak against the committee report
thank you mr speaker i am in the
unenviable position
of coming before the house today to ask
you not to repeal a program that i could
not possibly be convinced to vote for
i am not going to stand here and pretend
like that i think the fmli plan that was
passed as part of hb2 in 2021 was a good
plan
in fact i think it was extremely
regressive
were i to draft a paid family medical
leave plan it wouldn't look like this
for starters it's not universal a
private sector employee can only receive
the plan's benefits
if their employer happens to sign up for
the program
there's no path for an individual to get
the coverage as part of a larger state
pool without the employer signing up
and those benefits
sixty percent of your regular income
forbes magazine reported in 2021 that
six in ten americans live paycheck to
paycheck and now it's closer to seven
and ten
so if you're an administrative assistant
making fifty five thousand dollars a
year sure you can probably forgo forty
percent of your income and still be okay
however if you're a state liquor store
employee who for reasons that escape me
only makes twelve dollars an hour
that person is expected under the fmli
plan at hb2 to live on seven dollars an
hour
if they take advantage of a plan that
both people in this hypothetical pay
taxes into
this is an upward redistribution of
wealth from the working class to the
permanent managerial class and doesn't
benefit those who need the program the
most
however
these are not the reasons why a repeal
is being discussed i wish it was
in committee reasons for repeal of this
plan were it costs money it may balloon
as more people sign up for it
well yes there is no free paid family
leave
if you want a program you outline it if
it has the kind of popular support that
a real and robust paid family leave
program has shown to have in polls in
new hampshire you pass it and pay for it
this to me feels like the affordable
care act discussion in 2017.
i felt that the plan passed in 2009 was
alienating confusing technocratic
insurance company giveaways without even
a public option let alone universal
coverage
but the answer then wasn't repeal and
it's not the answer now
it was improved the minority wants this
bill to go to interim study so paid
family leave can be improved and made
better
we should fix this instead of throwing
away a bad plan and starting again at
square one thank you mr speaker
the chair recognizes representative
tarakot to speak for the committee
report
thank you mr speaker
as previously stated at 1165 would
repeal the granite state
paid family medical leave insurance plan
that was
part of hb2 last year
that's been tout as a way for the
private businesses to get paid family
leave insurance for their employees but
in fact in the end this is only going to
morph into a taxpayer-funded
entitlement
so let's talk a little bit of the
specifics
under the current
plan the nearly eleven thousand state
employees
would have their premiums for this
insurance plan
paid by the taxpayers a hundred percent
how much is that nobody knows the
answers because we passed this in hb2
without knowing how much it was going to
cost
doing my own calculations and
you you can
you can bet this is going to be in the
millions and millions of dollars every
year just for the 11 000 state employees
again on the backs of the taxpayers
this past january 1.9 million dollars
was authorized 1.9 million dollars just
to pay the consultants to look into
getting quotes and getting the plan up
and running
our last executive session the insurance
commissioner asked to address our
committee
now this was just a week and a half ago
they've had
two bills
to repeal this
fmli plan in two different committees
nobody from the commissioner's office
attended
so i asked we asked him at the executive
session the other day why are you coming
here now
why didn't anybody show up to these
original hearings if this was so
important
and he had no answer
asked him about a few other things
in the current plan fifty percent of the
premiums that a business would pay
they would get a tax break on it
so i asked him
what's the net effect on the revenues
on this
he said he didn't know
the commission also made the statement
during that hearing
that private businesses were very
interested in participating in this plan
when i asked him how many and what
businesses had indicated interest
he said he didn't have a number but he
thought he recalled some someone talking
to him in the lob hallway about it
now there are several other points in
the
in the uh purpose and policy statement
contained in the original language
that's in hb2 i'm going to mention one
of them because it's kind of interesting
excuse me it says
one of the primary reasons for this is
attracting and retaining workers
this is pure nonsense
all we had to do is look at some of the
states that already have fmli
new york new jersey california illinois
connecticut
note anything in common with those
states
these are the most heavily taxed states
in our country
where the residents are fleeing they
have the highest net negative migration
of all estates in our country
no one is flocking to these states
to get fmli
now the reason why private and private
employers are not going to buy this
anyway is extremely expensive
during our last term or the last term i
was here senator felt has tried putting
through a plan
and during that testimony i won't go
through the whole thing
but there was an individual on our
committee who was a fireman
and he bought his own similar
type of insurance short-term disability
if you will
that had less coverage than this fmli
insurance plan had
and he had sixty dollars a week uh sixty
dollars a paycheck every other week
taken out of his plan so that's a
hundred twenty dollars per employee
do the math
so
without getting in boring you with a
bunch of numbers
private businesses are not going to be
signing up for this scheme
we're going to be back to the
taxpayer-funded
state employees getting the benefit on
the backs of the taxpayers
i mentioned before
insurance companies now one has already
filed and more will follow
to start providing similar fmli
insurance to private businesses in new
hampshire
outside of the granite state
plan that's in our books
i have a copy of the document from the
insurance department that states that
the most important part and i mentioned
it briefly in my reason against tabling
is we have an opportunity now a short
window before the this thing gets fully
implemented
to remove this off our books and allow
the free market
to
allow the free market to
do its thing
so
i'm going to ask that you join me in
supporting the committee's
recommendation
of ought to pass and i do ask for a roll
call vote mr speaker
senator turkin asked for a roll call was
that sufficiently seconded it is
officially seconded this will be a roll
call vote members take your seats
so
okay
the motion before us is the majority
committed report of octopass and house
bill 1165.
this is a roll call vote
the chair recognizes representative
sullivan for parliamentary inquiry
thank you mr speaker
mr speaker
if i know
that the granite state family medical
leave program
ought to be tested
and has not yet been implemented
and if i further know
still know that any family medical leave
is better than no family medical leave
would i now press the red button to
defeat this premature repeal
thank you
chair recognize representative turcotte
for parliamentary inquiry
thank you mr speaker if i know that
private insurance companies are
wanting to offer this type of fmli
insurance on the private market but i
also know we have the opportunity here
to remove the
fmli program from the rsas prior to it
being implemented and finally mr speaker
if i know failing to remove this from
our books the legislation
this nation legislation will be forever
stuck
in our rsas and become a taxpayer-funded
entitlement scheme then what i press the
green button to sustain the majority
vote of ought to pass thank you mr
speaker the motion before us the
majority committee report about to pass
house bill 1165
this is a roll call vote if you're in
favor
you'll press the green button of the
pros who press the red button voting
stations are open for 30 seconds
[Music]
represent mckay
representative egan
president had an opportunity to vote
house will tend to stay to the vote
172 voting yeah 164 voting a committee
report is adopted
majority of the committee on labor
industrial and
relabilitative services to which was
referred house bill 1210
an act relative to exemptions from
vaccine mandates considered the same
report the same with the following
amendment the recommendation that the
bill ought to pass with amendment senate
letter turquod for the majority of the
committee
minority of the committee
having considered the same being
unbelievable to agree with the majority
report with the following resolution
resolved that is inexpedient to
legislators in a brian sullivan for the
minority of the committee
the amendment is 0724
h
printed in house record 10 a page 26.
are you ready for the question on the
amendment
all those in favor say aye
mr paul's nay
[Applause]
you guys have it the amendment is
adopted chair recognizes representative
sullivan
to speak against the committee
report thank you mr speaker
mr speaker
hb 1210 is a dangerous bill
it is dangerous medically and it is
dangerous economically
what it does is expand the exemptions
for vaccine mandates
for institutions in schools that accept
state and federal funding
let's be clear
this is not a coveted bill
this is a vaccine bill
it exempts all vaccines
it welcomes back
diseases that have been long
been eradicated
welcome back to polio
welcome back measles
this is a very dangerous medical
bill
currently
under our current rules
medical and religious exemptions are
allowed
under hb
there's a new exemption
exemptions for rights of conscience
currently
institutions can create policies
to to evaluate whether or not an
exemption
should or should not be accepted
under hp
1210 employees simply sign a declaration
saying that they want an exemption
there's no
review
it simply must be accepted
it is clear that the more exemptions
there are
the more disease we will have
this bill is medically dangerous
since this bill also applies to colleges
and universities
schools will be less able to protect
students
from
infectious disease
one disease that they are very
active about protecting is encephalitis
students who don't want to get into
encephalitis vaccination won't
that puts all students at risk
colleges and universities
operate in close quarters
students live in dormitories
they go to class together
in groups
infectious disease can spread
quickly on college campuses
for that reason colleges often have
vaccine mandates
again not just against covid against
many infectious diseases
this bill is also economically dangerous
i got a call this morning from the
hospital association
they ran the numbers
over the last few days
and have concluded
that just for the hospitals
the amount of medicaid and medicare
funding that we are at risk of losing
is in the vicinity of 2
billion
with a b
two billion dollars
that's big money
our hospitals operate at a very
slim margin
hospitals have already closed because of
economic situations
we will lose hospitals if we lose our
medicaid and medicare funding
it is at risk because
the
the center for
medicare and medicaid services
allow for exemptions
for medical and religious reasons
they do not allow for exemptions
on the
rights of conscience
if we add that exemption
and people
act on that exemption
we put all of that medicare and medicaid
funding at risk
are we willing to do that
this bill also does not allow for
those institutions to evaluate
exemptions
that is part of the
expectation from the cms
if we don't follow cms regulations
we put all that funding at risk
we might hear arguments that other
states have done exactly the same thing
as this bill intends to do
we'll hear that those states have not
lost funding for medicare and medicaid
yet there's a process
when that process takes place it'll be
evaluated whether or not our
institutions
are following the the guidelines
if they are found to be in violation of
the guidelines
they will be warned
and then they will lose the funding
this is way too risky for us to
undertake
i also need to point out that our county
nursing homes
county nursing homes that all of us
are responsible for taking care of
we are all delegates
to our county delegations
those county nursing homes cannot
operate without medicare and medicaid
funding
if this bill passes they lose that
what will fill that gap
i think it's going to be county taxes
so essentially if we lose the funding
for medicare and medicaid
we're voting for a gigantic
increase in county taxes
get ready
hb 1210
is a dangerous bill we should not
entertain this bill
please vote red
on the ought to pass
motion thank you
we're down to our last speaker
senate blazik has requested a roll call
as that's officially seconded
it is sufficiently seconded this will be
a roll call vote members take your seats
chair recognizes representative
infantine
thank you mr speaker
you heard a lot of
really
tough and dangerous talk just now
while i respect my colleague
on the labor committee i vehemently
disagree i think we're looking at two
vastly different bills
the labor committee had about i'd say 10
or 11 bills that came for us that had to
do with
covert related
issues
and one of the things the labor
committee tries to do at all costs is
not to get in between business
and the legislature we try to tell them
what to do except for things of safety
so we have a situation where people have
the ability
to have
a waiver if they had a medical reason or
religious
reason what happens if you didn't have a
medical reason and you're not overly
religious
what happens if you were
put on the spot explain to me exactly
why
medically
you are unable to do this explain to me
exactly why
you have a problem uh you cannot take
this because of a religious reason
so the concept came up
of personal
right of conscience so what is right of
conscious what does that mean
it means something within you says i do
not want to do this for my personal
reasons
that has never been offered
the goal of all the pieces of
legislation that we had we brought them
down to one
had a study committee and came up with
what you see now
trying to provide individuals the
ability to have that
right of conscience
the bill was
very
well crafted
and has nothing to do with what mike you
heard just previously do you really
think
that after 14 years here as a chairman
of the committee i am going to put my
name on a piece of legislation that
takes two billion dollars away from new
hampshire and closes every single
nursing home i wouldn't do that i'm not
that crazy
there are contracts
between the federal government
and providers of medicare and medicaid
we do not want to get involved in
between that contract
those contracts do say
vaccinations are required for certain
things or you're not going to get the
money no doubt
we don't want to get in between that
what this allows
is someone to be able to say hey i have
a right of conscience here i'm going to
sign a piece of paper and say i've
written a conscience
it has to be accepted by the employer
at that point the employer
can say well i'm sorry thank you very
much
but that is what is required under our
contract
and
i'm sorry you can no longer have your
job here
at which
they could go to unemployment and other
mechanisms or this opens up the ability
for any medical institution or whatever
to say okay we accept that
maybe we want to keep you we can put you
somewhere else and do something else
which is not going to be in violation of
that contract
so we've given the employee
a new mechanism
right of conscience
and we also haven't gotten in between
that contract
now what will happen after that if
they're consistent
the the employer is consistent
with
how they rule on each one of these
things sorry can't do it it's in
violation of our contract we will lose
all the funding we get from the federal
government
maybe we can do something else with you
somewhere else it won't be in violation
or you can go to unemployment
up until about a month ago unemployment
and securities told us they had 200
people
file for unemployment claims
through medical institutions because
unwillingness to take the vaccine
a certain percentage of those were
provided benefits as long as there was
consistency with what the employer did
so
we kind of very narrowly put this
together it's not as much as some people
would like trust me we have some people
say you didn't go far enough
we wanted you to make sure that that
person for the conscious has a job no
matter what
we can't do that ladies and gentlemen
because we would be putting this money
in in jeopardy
so
in recap we gave them
individuals so you now have medical
religious right of conscience
but
we have not interfered with the contract
between the employer
and the federal government
and we've given everyone as best options
we can we didn't go overboard
trying to to
deal with some of the
negative things that came out of kovitt
which we all know
i call it the great overreaction
but we did the best we could
and i stand here today
this committee the majority of the
committee
did not and does not feel
that they have put two billion dollars
in jeopardy
is going to put medical institutions
hospitals and nursing homes out of
business it is a very narrowly written
bill and if it's not read correctly
it will look like we did do that
um
i would ask you to support the
committee's recommendation about to pass
thank you mr speaker
the motion before us a majority report
about to pass as amended on house bill
1210 this is a roll call vote members
take your seats
so
the motion before us is the majority
report of autopasses amended on house
bill
1210 this is a roll call vote
chair recognizes representative soucy
for a parliamentary inquiry
thank you mr speaker
mr speaker if i believe that hb 1210 as
amended were to become law
that new hampshire would place our
health care providers in direct conflict
with the vaccine requirements of
descendants for medicare and medicaid
services potentially causing them to
forfeit billions of dollars of federal
funding
and mr speaker if i know that house bill
1210 attempts to create a right of
conscience in the state that
a state law that is in direct conflict
with the federal vaccine requirements
and if i also know that the language in
hb 1210
requires that any exemption
request made either for religious
medical or right of conscience must be
granted which is in clear violation of
the federal vaccine requirements placing
an undue burden on our businesses and
healthcare providers once again putting
at risk billions of dollars in medicare
and medicaid funding
and finally mr speaker if i know that hb
1210 seeks to usurp the decision of
business and health care leaders in our
state from making the decisions they
believe are in the best interest of
their businesses health care
organizations employees
customers and patients but i now press
the red button to oppose the ought to
pass amendment motion so that another
motion can be made thank you mr speaker
[Music]
chair recognized representative lang for
parliamentary inquiry
thank you mr speaker mr speaker
if i happily agree with the rep from
walpole when while speaking yesterday on
house bill 1080 she said all persons
deserve the right of conscience and mrs
further mr speaker if i am happy knowing
that is exactly what this bill does
extending the right of conscience to all
new hampshire citizens in alignment with
our new hampshire constitution part one
article four
and end the rep of the rep from
walpole's beliefs
mr speaker if i know that new hampshire
constitution part 1 article 4 reads and
the right of conscience unalienable
among these natural rights are some by
their very nature
unalienable
because no equivalent can be given or
received for them
of this kind are the rights of
conscience mr speaker if i know the word
unalienable means that which will not be
given or taken away
lastly mr speaker if i know this bill in
addition to aligning our law with the
new hampshire constitution has the
additional benefit of streamlining
business processes
reducing the potential lawsuits based on
the ada and civil rights acts
and would i now press the green button
support both our new hampshire
constitution our new hampshire citizens
and our new hampshire businesses please
vote green
the motion before us is the majority
report of what to pass as amended on
house bill 1-2-1-0
this is a rope
for what reason memorized
personal privilege
we're in we're in the voting mode right
now representative
webber
the motion before us is the majority
report of our passes amended in house
bill one two one oh
this is a roll call vote if you're in
favor you'll press the green button if
you're opposed you'll press the red
button voting stations are open for 30
seconds
do
of all members
president had an opportunity to vote
house will attend the state of the vote
181 voting a 155 voting a
committee report is adopted
now representative weber
thank you mr speaker and my apologies
for being a little too precipitate
i rise as a point of personal privilege
to state
that my words were taken entirely out of
context by the previous speaker and i
thoroughly resented it
house house will be in order
the majority of committee on labor
industrial and rehabilitative services
to which was referred house bill one two
five one
an act prohibiting payment of sub
minimum wages having considered the same
report the same with the following
resolution resolved that is inexpedient
to legislate president lyndon turcotte
from the majority of the committee
minority of the committee having
considered the same and being unable to
agree with the majority report with the
recommendation that the bill ought to
pass from mrs brian sullivan to the
minority of the committee
for what reason does the member rise
rise to make a motion mr speaker motion
motion to table hb1251
the motion the table is
correct
the motion before us now is the table
house bill
one two five one
a division has been requested
members take your seats
so
the motion before us is the table house
bill
five one this is a division vote the
chair recognizes representative turcotte
for parliamentary inquiry
thank you mr speaker if i know the
average tipped employee in new hampshire
makes north of twenty dollars an hour
and much higher and higher under higher
end establishments
and if i further know that restauranters
restauranteurs and tip staff know best
how to operate their businesses better
than we politicians do
and finally mr speaker if i know that
here in new hampshire in our neighbor to
the northeast the state of maine there
are real world examples
of how ill-conceived legislation like
this has proven disastrous and i won't
get to tell you those stories
would i now press the green button to
tell table hb one two five one thank you
mr speaker
chair recognized remember
schultz for a parliamentary inquiry
thank you mr speaker
if i know
that the average american now believes
that hard work is not being rewarded
if i know we as granite staters need a
robust
capitalism that has the real
conversation about wages
if i know
alex ray of the common man family of
restaurants the largest new hampshire
employer
of restaurant workers almost ten
thousand granite staters
supports this bill
[Music]
and if i know new hampshire ought to be
the land of opportunity
not the land of the lowest wages in our
region
i would then push the red button
and start that robust conversation
thank you
the motion before us is the tabling
motion on house bill one two five one
this is a division vote
if you're in favor you'll press the
green button if you oppose you'll press
the red button voting stations are open
for 30 seconds
representative spillsbury
all members president had an opportunity
to vote also attend this state of the
vote
187 voting a 149 voting a
the tabling motion on house bill 1251 is
adopted
majority of the committee on labor
industrial relative services to which
was referred house bill 1337
and act relative to the duration of
unemployment benefits having considered
the same report the same
the following amendment and the
recommendation that the bill ought to
pass with the amendment senate have
landed turcotte for the majority of the
committee
minority of the committee have been
considered the same being unable to
agree with the majority report with the
following resolution result that is
inexpedient to legislate
president of andrew manville for the
minority of the committee
house will be in order
the amendment is zero seven three two h
printed in house record 10a pages 51-52
the question is on the amendment are you
ready for the question all those in
favor say aye
those opposed nay
[Music]
the amendment is adopted the chair
recognizes
senator manville to speak against the
committee report
thank you mr speaker
i rise in opposition to house bill 1337
today
this bill if enacted
would index
the
time for unemployment benefits
to be paid
to claimants under that system
indexing it to the state
average unemployment rate
that is
the if this bill is enacted
the maximum number of weeks of coverage
for
unemployment benefits
would be 16 weeks
if the unemployment rate
is three percent
with that time
increasing to 26 weeks
in
half point increments per week
up to 26
at an eight percent rate of unemployment
this bill has a good objective
to get people back to work but
it is a bad methodology for doing that
our new hampshire unemployment benefit
system already has built-in incentives
for people to get back to work
it only pays a portion of
the earnings claimants make prior to
going on unemployment
it has a 26-week limit
and
claimants
must be actively looking for work and
there are
rules in place to help ensure that this
happens
but the proof is in the pudding
the vast majority
of
people who apply for and get
unemployment benefits
do not use all 26 weeks
so who are
the relatively few
people who do
well this bill would appear to assume
that they are freeloaders
happy to take advantage of
a golden goose
and
the bill then assumes
that the time they should have for
finding a job should be linked to the
state unemployment rate
this is illogical
the unemployment rate does not take into
account
particular
trades
or occupations
certain geographical variances
or the demand for or availability of
particular
skills experience or training
but most importantly
it doesn't take into account the
individual circumstances of the people
who are in
this
minority of people who need time to find
work
those individual circumstances
include such things as age
health issues
we just heard that they might include
rights of conscience
they include local
employment challenges
transportation issues
lack of experience
or training in a particular
sought-after
area of work
they ignore the possibility that someone
would choose to stay in a particular
field of endeavor rather than take
whatever is available on the market
and generally they
do not relate it all to
anomalies at any point in time in the
job market relevant to a particular
person as addressed by the state
unemployment rate
mr speaker very few people
want to stay unemployed
those
who
those relative few who stay
unemployed longer
than others
often face challenges that most of us
aren't facing
their circumstances are peculiar to them
not to
a
[Music]
determined state average unemployment
rate
for this minority of job seekers
reducing the benefit period
because of a low unemployment rate
would have a cruel
and punitive effect
on them
and
in respect to their circumstances and
also on their families
this bill if enacted
could create further welfare benef
burdens on our municipalities
ex exact other demands on our safety
nets
and even potentially exacerbate
homelessness
our current system works
i urge you to vote against
this bill so that a motion for itl can
be made
thank you
we're down to our last speaker a roll
call has been requested by
representative is that sufficiently
seconded
it is officially seconded this will be a
roll call vote members take your seats
chair recognizes representative turcotte
thank you mr speaker
hb 1337 is a common sense and rational
approach to unemployment that has proven
successful in the other states that
has implemented such a plan
businesses see their unemployment
compensation insurance rates decline
and it also allows the state's trust
fund to be strengthened remember
businesses are the ones who pay for all
the unemployment compensation in this
state
florida i'll give you one example is the
shining star of where this has happened
at one point during the 2008 finite
financial crisis
its trust fund had swung to a negative
1.7 billion dollar
loss
after a few years of implementing this
type of a plan
it swung positive 3.9 for a net gain of
5.6 billion
and florida now enjoys the lowest
unemployment
insurance rates in the country
as the previous speaker mentioned this
does tie the length of time one can
receive the employment
compensation to the employ unemployment
rate
the maximum of 26 weeks does not change
and it does reduce
uh down to when whenever the
unemployment rate is less than three
percent
the member will suspend for a minute the
member has a right to be heard take your
seats quietly
thank you mr speaker
one other issue that came up in uh
and was a few of the reasons why we had
changes in the the amendment
were the concerns over what would happen
in case of uh like the financial crisis
in 2008 or even the recent coveted
crisis where we had individuals on
unemployment for extended lengths of
time the the deputy commissioner
actually actually made the point that he
wasn't concerned about it only because
the federal government had stepped in to
extend those benefits
even with that i decided to put an
additional provision into the language
that would
give the governor an extreme
circumstances
similar to the covet 19 the the ability
to
adjust those
rates
the good news about this there is
absolutely no financial downside risk
the only probability for a positive
upside for both the state's trust fund
and more importantly the businesses who
will see their unemployment taxes go
down
new hampshire does have a pretty good
system now this bill would only make it
better i ask that you support the otp
motion by pressing the green button
thank you mr speaker
the motion before us is the majority
report of what to pass as amended on
house bill 1337
this is a roll call vote
members take your seats
so
motion before us is the majority
committee report of what
ought to pass as amended on house bill
chair recognizes
representative sullivan for
parliamentary inquiry
thank you mr speaker
mr speaker if i know
that our unemployment benefit program is
working effectively as it is
and if i further know that the
relatively low level of unemployment
benefits
and the requirement to seek employment
provide a strong incentive for folks to
seek
to return to work
and finally if i know that a small group
of individuals find it very difficult to
find a new job
due to age
physical frailty
or family circumstances and therefore
need 26 weeks of benefits available
regardless of the unemployment rate
would i then
press the red button
so that another motion might be made
thank you
gee i recognize representative turcotte
for parliamentary inquiry
thank you mr speaker
if i know indexing the time the
unemployed may collect unemployment
compensation to the unemployment rate is
both rational and grounded in common
sense
and if i also know the net effect of
this legislation would be to improve new
hampshire's unemployment trust fund
while also lowering the cost of
insurance premiums our new hampshire
businesses currently pay
then when i press the green button to
send this fiscally sound bill to the
those on the other side of the wall
behind me thank you mr speaker
the motion before us a majority
committee report of what a pass has
amended on house bill one three three
seven it's a roll call vote if you're in
favor you'll press the green button if
you're opposed you'll press the red
button voting stations are open for 30
seconds
so
while members president had an
opportunity to vote
house will attend the state of the vote
179 voting day 153 voting a committee
report is adopted
the majority of the committee on labor
industrial and rehabilitative services
to which was referred to house bill 1472
an act prohibiting anti-union activities
by employers having considered the same
report the same with the following
resolution resolve that it is an
expedient to legislate representative
gregor for the majority of the committee
the minority of the committee having
considered the same and being unable to
agree with the majority report with the
recommendation that the bill ought to
pass representative dan tsumy for the
minority of the
committee member from nashua
representative chumi is recognized to
speak against the committee report
working people
sometimes question whether it's in their
best interest to bargain with their
employer as
an individual
or
[Music]
bargain as a group
and so
if a majority of them
decides
it's in their best interest to bargain
as a group
they can go through a legal process
and an election and be certified as a
sole bargaining agent as part of a union
yet
more
and and they should be able to do this
without interference from their employer
yet more than 75 percent of private
sector employees
respond
to organizing drives with aggressive
anti-union campaigns
these typically involve a series of
mandatory captive meetings
at the workplace where the employer
makes this case
against unionizations
these meetings are by their nature
coercive
because workers must attend
an employee and employers make dire
claims about the consequences of
unionization
and those who question the company line
can face discipline
or termination
and that happens
high-ranking company officials often
attend
and present
and union activists are pointed out for
derision
these meetings are offered
followed by supervisor one on ones
as the primary means through which
employers deliver threats
and engage in interrogation
employers use these
supervisors
one-on-one
to threaten workers with union activity
at least 54 percent of the time
and
interrogate workers about their union
activity and that of co-workers in at
least 63 percent of the time
employees use survey surveillance in
about 14 of the time
there are laws against
firing employees for organizing union
but in more than 40 percent of the union
election campaign
employers are charged with violating
laws however
the penalties for breaking the law are
minimal
and there applied many months after
an employee is fired for the purpose of
intimidating other employees
employers own their business but they
don't own their employees
employees are free citizens
whose work
makes all of our lives better
and as such they are deserving of
dignity
and respect they should be free
from coercion or intimidation
employers often
claim that these meetings are an
exercise in free speech
but mandating a person or a group to
listen to your point of view is not free
speech
it's not free
i don't know what it is but it's not
free speech
vote against the committee's
recommendation
of itl and press the red button thank
you
the member from manchester
representative infanzine is recognized
to speak in support of the committee
report
thank you mr speaker
when a group of individuals decides that
they're going to
[Music]
make an attempt to form a union to be
organized
that's okay that's all fair and that's
the way our system works
but we all know and i'll use a
legal term here
that more often than not
in the trenches no one has clean hands
all right
management may say something that is
against
forming the union and say well you're
going to spend money on this and this
and you may not get that union on the
other hand we'll say yeah but we'll get
you this this and this
so then each one uses the media to see
what we can do that they can do to try
to
dissuade
an opinion national labor relations
board is in place does their job gets
involved when need be
the bill was one-sided
said that management can't say anything
negative about a union well what about
the other side
why do we have a one-sided bill that was
that was a uh something that
the majority couldn't get past
if you're going to do something it needs
to be fair for all
that's what the national labor relations
board does
they try to get involved when things get
out of control and bring things back to
where they should be so we had a bill
that was not equal to both
we have an organization that is already
in place to do things
and unfortunately as i said
things
don't always
aren't always pretty
when we're making legislation and
they're not always pretty
when uh
a group is trying to organize
it is not the best system but it's the
best one we have
and so far it seems to be working so i
would request that the members of the
committee or excuse me the members of
the house support the labor committee
position of inexpedient to legislate and
mr speaker i would like a division vote
the question before the house is the
majority committee report of
inexpedience legislate are you ready for
the question a roll call has been
requested is that sufficiently seconded
who requested it
is that sufficiently seconded
it is not sufficiently seconded this
will be a division vote
thank you
clearer
house will be in order
representative bluchart is recognized
for parliamentary inquiry
thank you mr speaker
mr speaker
if i know that employees should have the
right
to come together and decide
and then bargain as a group without
employer interference
and
mr speaker if i know that this decision
to come together to decide and then
bargain as a group must be free
from coercion and intimidation
then mr speaker
would i press the red button
so that someone can make
another motion
thank you mr speaker
representative infantine is recognized
for parliamentary inquiry thank you mr
speaker if i know that the bill was well
intended but is one-sided
if i also know that we there are
mechanisms in place for the national
labor relations board to deal with
issues that go on when a group of
employees wants to organize than what i
support
the committee recommendation of
inexpedient to legislate thank you
the question is on the majority
committee report of inexpediency
legislate this is a division vote if
you're in favor you'll be pressing the
green button if you're opposed you'll
press the red button voting stations are
open for 30 seconds
my
representatives
have all members president an
opportunity to vote
the house will attend to the state of
the vote
181 having voted in the affirmative 149
on the negative the committee report has
adopted
mr speaker for reason doesn't remember
us i rise to request that hb the remarks
on hb
1472 be placed in the permanent journal
which bill
the motion is to print remarks
without objection
there is an objection
are you ready for the question
what
the motion is whether to print the
remarks of the previous debate in the
permanent journal all those in favor say
aye
well done
we had a division all right this will be
a division vote members take your seats
the question is whether to print the
remarks of the previous debate and the
permanent journal this is a division
vote you're in favor you'll press the
green button if you're opposed you'll
press the red button voting stations are
open for 30 seconds
representative wilhelm
representative alicia lekkis
representative sue newman
all memphis president had an opportunity
to vote
i also attended the state of the vote
195 having voted in the affirmative 141
and the negative the remarks will be
printed
journals are going to weigh 50 pounds
the majority of the committee on labor
industrial and rehabilitative services
which referred house bill 1508 fn
an act prohibiting discharge of
volunteer firefighters or volunteer
emergency medical technicians from other
employment having considered the same
report the same with the following
resolution resolve that it is
inexpedient to legislate representative
leno avalany for the majority of the
committee
the minority of the committee having
considered the same and being unable to
agree with the majority report with the
recommendation that the bill ought to
pass representative andrew manaval for
the minority of the committee
questions on the majority committee
report
of inexpediency legislate are you ready
for the question all those in favor say
aye
all those opposed nay
the eyes haven't the committee reports
adopted
the majority of the committee on labor
industrial and rehabilitative services
to which was referred to house bill 1514
fn and act relative to an employee's
unused earned time having considered the
same report the same with the following
resolution resolved that is inexpedient
to legislate representative leno avelani
for the majority of the committee
the minority of the committee having
considered the same and being unable to
agree with the majority report with the
following amendment and the
recommendation that the bill ought to
pass with amendment representative
michael cahill for the minority of the
committee
the member from newmarket representative
cahill is recognized to speak against
the committee report
uh
sorry what for what reason does a member
rise i make a motion
state your motion a motion to table this
bill
representative harrington moves to table
house bill 1514
are you ready for the question
division has been requested this will be
a division vote members take your
oh seats
clearer
okay
the question is whether to lay house
bill 1514 on the table
okay representative cahill is recognized
for parliamentary inquiry
thank you mr speaker
mr speaker if i know that there are
people of good will who are interested
in fairness
fairness of how we treat our workforce
who
may have been here for previous
reversions of this bill which the house
has voted to pass twice before once with
the overturning of a committee report so
it could happen again
uh if if maybe if i'd like to
talk about the bill and hear the
other side talk about their perspective
i think it's worth talking about
worth considering would i then vote red
on the tabling motion and i ask your
support
the question is whether to lay house
bill 1514 on the table this is division
vote if you're in favor you'll be
pressing the green button if you're
opposed you'll be pressing the red
button voting stations are open for 30
seconds
[Music]
here
of all members president an opportunity
to vote
the house will attend to the state of
the vote
168 having voted in the affirmative 172
on the negative the motion fails
we're back to the majority committee
report the rep member from newmarket
representative cahill is recognized to
speak against the committee report
and let's give him a chance to be heard
thank you mr speaker
and thank you
colleagues
three hundred dollars
three hundred and six dollars and sixty
cents
four hundred and ninety three dollars
and sixty six cents
hundred and seventy dollars
five hundred and ninety one dollars and
eighteen cents
mr speaker colleagues this is not the
proposed pay increase for the members of
the house
this is these numbers are the number or
the amounts that people lost
when they were working a job
and the and the owner sold the company
but did not
provide that their vacation hours would
be transferred to the next employer he
did not pay them out so they lost a
combined total of two thousand two
hundred and sixty one dollars and forty
four cents
many of us think that's not that
shouldn't happen that's the wrong way to
handle your employees that what should
happen is that you would transfer
everything to the new employer or pay
them
18 days
144 hours at sixteen dollars and thirty
two cents per hour
twenty three hundred dollars fifty cents
twenty three fifty in eight cents
that is what another employee lost when
she was told today is your last day
you you may have vacation hours and this
cut this employer had the policy
of if you did not use all your vacation
hours during the year they would not it
would not say use or lose it but they
would pay you a very progressive company
they would pay you what you hadn't used
but it when terminated
they did not pay because this employee
unable to request the vacation time two
weeks in advance per the policy because
she had no notice of the of being laid
off she lost 2 300
now
while the other people were fortunate to
have a job to go to this this person had
to go and collect unemployment
which i think probably hurt the
unemployment trust fund
a small amount but it still impacted the
trust fund
so
i've been working on this for a few
years now with my good friend from
hudson
the man with the wonderful thai
collection
we began this quest because he was
interested in using or losing
the practice where an employer says you
know you get this much time in a
calendar year or your anniversary date
if you don't use it you lose it this
bill does nothing has nothing to do with
that that's practice remains does not
affect it
this bill only comes into effect
when the company is sold
or there's a layoff and a permanent
layoff at that because we heard from the
people who paved the roads at the
seasonal employer if you lay them off
you know you're probably going to come
them back so this is a permanent the
amendment that we'll talk about later it
deals with that so it's only two special
circumstances that we think
when an employer writes their policy
that says i don't pay a termination
that termination could have many many
causes without you know where the
employee is blameless has not caused
trouble at work has done their job has
obviously been paying 16.32 cents an
hour had done a good job for the seven
years she worked there
and
it's just not it's just not right for
the employee to suffer
when they have no role in this it was
beyond their control and all of a sudden
what was on their pay stub whether it
was paper digital it's gone
so i asked you to overturn
the committee report so that we might
look at the amendment and pass that so i
can stop bothering you and i want to do
this again next year
thank you so much
does this member yield for a question
yes
you may inquire
thank you mr speaker and thank you for
taking my question uh according to the
bill it says that this only takes effect
if the company is sold or transferred or
if it's a layoff if you have a worker
who has accrued a thousand or two
thousand dollars an unpaid time vacation
time sick time something like that
and they walk off the job they quit it
doesn't apply to that
it does not all right thank you very
much
last speaker the member from manchester
representative infantine is recognized
to speak in favor of the committee
report
thank you mr speaker
employers choose many different ways
to offer enticements or benefits to
their employees to be good employers to
have good employees you must offer these
things some are health benefits
disability vacation time sick time
but the way each company does this is
very different depending on what kind of
a business they are if they're seasonal
uh they have uh bit busier times slower
times
uh whether they offer bonuses on a
quarterly basis for
exceptional production or any of these
things some say well you're going to get
two weeks vacation five sick days
and five personal days other companies
have said we're going to take that
entire amount we're going to give you
equivalent to three weeks to use what
however you choose whether it's vacation
time personal time or sick time
it varies
in the labor committee we try not to
tell businesses what to do and how to do
it
for example my company chooses to
provide people with vacation time
and they want them to use the vacation
time i want them to be fresh i want them
to take that time with their families
and do what they need to do
to enjoy their lives
at the end of the year i don't want them
to carry it over to other times i want
them to use it
right but i will if they don't use their
sick time roll it over because something
terrible happens where you're sick for a
month you want them to have those
benefits those are decisions i make as
an owner
other other owners make other decisions
on how they're going to do it and we try
not to interfere
what the bill is trying to say is that
vacation time and sick time is earned
money
it's not a benefit but it's cash in hand
now we hear every once in a while
especially with some organized uh
municipalities or something where
someone will retire
and they haven't taken sick time in five
years or vacation in five years and they
walk away with a large check that's fine
because that's negotiation with the
union and that's what was developed
again
labor committee not getting involved
with a private business or a private
municipality and their employees
we don't want to do the same thing here
we do not want to tell employers
that sick time unused sick time and
vacation time
is cash in hand to take with them if
that is not if that is the intent of the
owner
then it's in the employer's manual
if it is not the intent of the employer
we shouldn't be telling that they should
have to do that and that is the only
difference i don't disagree with the
previous speaker if a business wants to
do that
but again
it's up to the individual business the
individual owner and how they treat
their employees and what's their
employee
manuals and we don't like to interfere
with that
so i would ask you to support
the committee
recommendation of it expedient to
legislate and i would like a division
vote mr speaker
roll call has been requested by who
represent request roll call and it is
sufficiently seconded this will be a
roll call vote
so
all right
the house will come to order
the question is on the majority
committee report of an expediency
legislate
this is a roll call vote the member from
newmarket representative cahill is
recognized for parliamentary inquiry
thank you mr speaker
mr speaker if i know
that
i agree
with the previous speaker my good friend
from manchester
that
hour isn't these policies are set by the
employer that's that's a good situation
to have and i know that in many cases
most cases the employer will use
something else beside the law they'll
use their conscience something will tell
them what they should and shouldn't do
what's the right thing to do
but it doesn't always go that way and if
i know that this law
would only cover two very narrow
circumstances which i think most of us
will agree
were egregious they were not handled
well they would they would not fare to
the employer to the employee would i
then vote green sorry
red to defeat the itl so that another
emotion may be made thank you
representative infantine is recognized
for parliamentary inquiry
thank you mr speaker if i know there are
always circumstances that we can't
account for but not everything has to be
in law
and by a further note that we do not
tell businesses for the most part except
for safety type things
uh what to do then i would request that
you support the majority report of itl
thank you mr speaker
this is a roll call vote if you are in
favor of the committee report you'll
press the green button if you're opposed
you'll press the red button voting
stations are open for 30 seconds
uh
[Music]
representative rich
have all members present at an
opportunity to vote
the house will attend to the state of
the vote
172 having voted in the affirmative 164
in the negative the committee report is
adopted
the majority of the committee on
legislative administration which was
referred cacr23
enact
the new hampshire constitution that's
awkward wording providing that all
references to persons in the new
hampshire constitution be neutral having
considered the same report the same with
the following resolution resolved that
it is inexpedient to legislate
representative bob greene for the
majority of the committee
the minority of the committee having
considered the same being unable to
agree with the majority report with the
recommendation that the bill ought to
pass representative manny a special for
the minority of the committee
for what reason does a member rise
make a motion state in motion i'd like
to table cacr23
representative hill moves that cacr23 be
laid on the table are you ready for the
question
a division has been requested this will
be a division vote members take your
seats
so
up
all right the question is whether to lay
crc
rcacr23 on the table this is a division
vote
representative lebranch is recognized
for parliamentary inquiry oh sorry i did
that wrong
represent i know i'm sorry
representative hill is recognized for
parliamentary inquiry thank you mr
speaker mr speaker if i know there is
little chance that
the necessary percentage will be
received
and if i know the testimony was that
since each and every
change that would need be needed to be
included on and shown to the voter
that the ballot for this question would
be 12 pages long
leading to much confusion and wasted
resources would i now request and follow
the committee suggestion to
table this bill thank you
representative lebranch is recognized
for parliamentary inquiry
thank you mr speaker mr speaker
if i know that this is a very important
cacr
and if i know that this cacr has passed
this house before with a bipartisan
majority and it has also passed
the other body with a bipartisan
majority
and if i know
that back in 1998 56 percent of voters
have voted in favor of the cacr and i
believe we've come a long way since 1998
and if i believe that today we would
have had the
requisite support from the population to
pass the caacr would i now press the red
button so that we can pass this very
important cacr thank you
the question is whether to lay cr
cacr23 on the table
if you're in favor you'll press the
green button if you're opposed you'll
press the red button voting stations are
open for 30 seconds
so
[Music]
also
of all members president an opportunity
to vote
somebody say no
get him
all right the house will attend to the
state of the vote
190 having voted in the affirmative 140
in the negative cacr 23 is laid on the
table
the committee on legislative
administration which was referred to
house bill 1007 an act relative to
qualifications for office having
considered the same report the same with
the following resolution resolved that
it is inexpedient to legislate
representative matthew simon for the
committee
for what reason does a member rise
to make a motion state your motion i'd
like to table house bill
representative hill moves that house
bill 1007 be laid on the table are you
ready for the question
roll calls been requested
uh by representative marsh roll call
okay
you're awesome
all righty so who requested the roll
call
representative tim smith requests a roll
call is that sufficiently seconded
and it is this will be a roll call vote
members take their seats
this
all right the house will come to order
the question is whether to lay house
bill 1007 on the table
we're going
i also come to order please
representative ruillard is recognized
for parliamentary inquiry
thank you mr speaker
if i know that removal of a member of
this house
for insurrection and rebellion would be
a very
difficult task
and if i know that this bill is vague
the language is poor and there's no
procedure outlined for removal in the
bill
and if i know that this bill
could be used
as a political weapon
by one party
against the other
would i vote with the majority of
legislative administration
and vote the color of my jacket
green thank you mr speaker
representative marshall is recognized
for parliamentary inquiry
thank you mr speaker
mr speaker if i know that the
disqualification clause of the 14th
amendment already prohibits those who
engage in insurrection
and rebellion from holding any public
office and at this time even without the
passage of this bill
a member can be removed or not seated
for that reason
and if i know that the new hampshire
constitution gives the new hampshire
house under part 2 article 14
and the new hampshire senate under part
2 article 29 the sole authority to rule
on the qualifications of their members
and they can do so at any time
but if i know that there is no authority
under current statute to call a special
election if either body disqualified a
member for violating the 14th amendment
and therefore an entire district
of this house or if the other body could
remain unrepresented for an entire
biennium
then would i push the red button so that
we can ensure that all of our citizens
are represented in this body thank you
the question is whether lay house bill
1007 on the table this is a roll call
vote if you're in favor you'll press the
green button if you're opposed you'll
press the red button voting stations are
open for 30 seconds
representative sylvia
of all members president had an
opportunity to vote
the house will attend to the state of
the vote
186 having voted in the affirmative 150
and the negative house bill 1007 is laid
on the table
the committee on legislative for what
reason doesn't member rise
the committee on legislative
administration which was referred to
house bill 1033 fn local
an act prohibiting recipients of state
or local grants or appropriations from
using such funds for lobbying having
considered the same report the same with
the following amendments and the
recommendation that the bill ought to
pass with amendment representative
gregory hill for the committee
the committee amendment is zero eight
one five h printed in house record 10a
on pages six and seven
the quest question is on the committee
amendment for what reason does the
member rise again you're so kind mr
speaker i move that we table hb 1033. i
couldn't understand that
i couldn't
hear with the motion
mr speaker i move that we table hb 1033.
okey-dokey
the motion is whether chile house bill
1033 on the table
a division has been requested this will
be a division vote
representative belanger requests a roll
call and it is sufficiently seconded
are you doing
yes
the question is whether to lay house
bill 1033 on the table this is a roll
call vote if you're in favor you'll
press the green button if you're opposed
you'll press the red button
voting stations are open for 30 seconds
representative bucco
mr speaker of all members president an
opportunity to vote
the house will attend to the state of
the vote
174 having voted in the affirmative 161
on the negative house bill 1033 is laid
on the table
the committee on legislative
administration which was referred house
bill 1041 fn
an act extending the public employees
labor relations act to employees of the
general court and relative to the duties
of the joint committee on legislative
facilities having considered the same
report the same with the following
resolution resolve that it is
inexpedient to legislate representative
scott wallace for the committee the
question is on the committee report of
inexpedient to legislate
representative hill requests a division
vote this will be a division vote
going on uh for what reason does a
member rise for a motion sure why not
may i table house bill 1041 please
representative hill moves at house bill
1041 be laid on the table
are you ready for the question
i'm sorry what
uh
okay there it is the division vote's
been requested this will be a division
vote members take your seats
thank you
clearance
all right the question is whether to lay
house bill 1041 on the table
representative turcotte is recognized
for parliamentary inquiry
thank you mr speaker if i know this
legislative body has heard the same bill
at least four times in recent years and
the employees of the general court
and the employees of the general court
have not once been asked for their input
regarding such a bill and its
proposition
if i further know that just like
previous bills
like previous similar bills the language
and provisions of the bill are nothing
but
clear and in fact very confusing and ill
thought out and lastly and most
importantly mr speaker if i know the
staff of the general court has always
been and should continue to be exemplars
of nonpartisanship
in the fulfillment of their duties then
would i now press the green button to
support the tabling motion thank you mr
speaker
representative schultz is recognized for
parliamentary inquiry
thank you mr speaker
if i know
that the reason the bill keeps coming
back is because
being able to organize a union is a
human right
and if i know
that
our leader
who recently passed
worked hard on this bill because he
understood the human right to organize
and that state all government employees
in the state should be able to unionize
i'm sorry
and if i know
that it's the right thing to do
press the red button so another
motion
may come forward thank you
the question is whether to lay house
bill 1041 on the table this is a
division vote if you're in favor you'll
press the green button if you're opposed
you'll press the red button voting
stations are open for 30 seconds
so
if all members president had an
opportunity to vote
the house will attend to the state of
the vote
187 having voted in the affirmative 146
and the negative house bill 1041 is laid
on the table
the committee on legislative
administration which was referred house
bill for what reason does a member rise
i rise to ask
for
the remarks on
oh sorry
i asked to uh i rise to ask that the
remarks for house bill 1007 be added to
the permanent record
the motion is whether to
print the remarks for house bill 1007
yes
just parliamentary interest
okay without objection
the marks will be printed
the committee on legislative
administration which was referred house
bill 1084 and act relative to the
disclosure of the sources of legislative
bill proposals
oh my having considered the same report
the same with the following resolution
resolved that it is in expedient to
legislate representative bob green for
the committee the question is on the
committee report of an expedient to
legislate are you ready for the question
all those in favor say aye
all those opposed nay
yes have it the committee reports
adopted
the committee on legislative
administration which was referred to
house bill 1102 an act relative to
certain committees and commissions of
the department of state
having considered the same report the
same with the following amendment and
the recommendation that the bill ought
to pass with amendment representative
bob greene for the committee the
amendment zero one eight eight h is
printed on house record 10-a on pages
13-14 the question is on the committee
amendment are you ready for the question
all those in favor say aye
all those bosnia
the eyes have it and the amendment is
adopted the question is now on the
majority committee report of ought to
pass with amendment are you ready for
the question all those in favor say aye
all those opposed nay
the eyes have it and the committee
reports adopted
the committee on legislative
administration which was referred to
house bill 1129 and acts relative to the
fiscal committee of the general court
having considered the same report the
same with the following resolution
resolve that it is inexpedient to
legislate representative claire roulade
for the committee the question is on the
committee report have been expedient to
legislate and a division has been
requested this will be a division vote
members please take your seats
clear
the questions on the committee report
have been expedient to legislate this is
a division vote representative timothy
smith is recognized for parliamentary
inquiry
mr speaker if i know that in the long
history of the new hampshire general
court
the membership
of the joint fiscal committee
has not historically been
a partisan issue
that the composition of that committee
has historically followed the same
proportional representation as other
committees in both chambers
however if i also know
that unfortunately in recent years
the membership count and the party
balance on that committee has become a
partisan issue
and the process
is no longer working and that the
parties are no longer balanced on that
committee
and if i know mr speaker that the
purpose of this bill is not about any
current
issues but that it is looking towards
the future
to make sure that moving forward
future legislatures our successors in
these seats
4 6 20 years from now
won't have to worry about the membership
of this joint fiscal committee becoming
a partisan football regardless of which
party is happening to be in control of
the chamber at that time
did you want to press the red button
there you go
representative ruler is recognized for
parliamentary inquiry
thank you mr speaker
if i know the joint fiscal committee
made up of members from the house and
the senate
has been appointed
for 35
years
by the same mechanism since
1987 we have not had that problem
and if i know that changing who appoints
the members
will not affect the great work that's
currently done and has been done by the
fiscal committee
and if i also know
that the change is unnecessary because
they continue to work well together and
will continue to work well together
regardless of who appoints them
would i now vote with the majority
of the legislative administration and
still press the button the color of this
jacket green
the questions on the majority committee
report have been expedient to legislate
if you're in favor you'll press the
green button if you're opposed you'll
press the red button voting stations are
open for 30 seconds
[Music]
so
representative oregon you need to be in
your seat
have all members president an
opportunity to vote
the house will attend to the state of
the vote
188 having voted in the affirmative 142
and the negative the committee report is
adopted
the committee on legislative
administration which was referred house
bill 1170 an act limiting the authority
of new hampshire delegates to
policy-making conventions having
considered the same
report the same with the following
amendment and the recommendation that
the bill ought to pass with amendment
representative scott wallace for the
committee mr speaker the committee
amendment is 0-2-7-0-h
printed on house record 10-a on page 16.
for what reason does the member rise
it's a little too late because we're
already into the amendment so wait a
minute sorry
we're already into the amendment so i'll
wait a minute
mr speaker i would move that house bill
1170 be placed upon the table but it
sounded like you had started to call the
question on the
amendment so moved
representative tim smith moves that
house bill 1170 be laid on the table
are you ready for the question
a division has been requested this will
be a division vote members back in your
seats
what was that
represent requests for roll calls that
sufficiently seconded
it is sufficiently seconded this will be
a roll call vote
okay this is a roll call vote whether to
lay house bill 1170 on the table
representative tim smith is recognized
for parliamentary inquiry
thank you mr speaker
mr speaker if i have been
working on the article 5 issue for well
over a decade
and if i have been approached over the
years
by members of both parties and used as a
resource
in regards to the nuance of article 5 of
the u.s federal constitution
and mr speaker if i am in firm agreement
with the intent and principles behind
this legislation
however mr speaker
if i have also found that the language
in this bill is unenforceable under
federal law
and if i have found mr speaker that the
language in this bill is unfortunately
overly broad
and could interfere with the state's
ability
to engage in other interstate
conventions and pacts unrelated to
article 5 of the u.s constitution
for example mr speaker if this could
negatively impact the ability of new
hampshire to participate in periodic
renegotiations of things like the
interstate driver's license compact
which we kind of need would i now press
the green button
representative wallace is recognized for
a shorter parliamentary inquiry
yes thank you mr speaker mr speaker if i
know that this party passed an identical
bill in 2015 by a bipartisan three to
one majority
and mr speaker if i further know that
the body on the other side of the wall
behind me passed the bill on on a voice
vote
and mr speaker if i further know that
the governor's veto was due to the need
for this legislation was in the future
and the future is now
and finally mr speaker if i know that we
are only a couple of states away from a
convention call with two states filing
resolutions just in the time period
since this bill was introduced would and
i'll press the red button to stop this
tabling motion so another motion can be
made
the question is whether to lay house
bill 1170 on the table this is a roll
call vote
if you're in favor you'll be pressing
the green button if you're opposed
you'll be pressing the red button voting
stations are open for 30 seconds
[Music]
representative yokela
of all members president had an
opportunity to vote
the house will attend to the state of
the vote
157 having voted in the affirmative 186
and the negative the motion
fails the question now is on the
committee amendment zero two seven zero
h are you ready for the question all
those in favor say aye
all those opposed nay
the eyes have it and the amendment is
adopted
the question now was on the majority
committee report about to pass with
amendment the member from seabrook
representative abramson is recognized to
speak against the committee report
thank you
mr speaker
mr speaker the last time that the house
passed this bill
both sides admitted in hearings and on
the floor that unless any convention of
the states occurred in new hampshire
the event would probably be outside
the state's jurisdiction and the
jurisdiction of our laws and have no
impact
but out of nearly 200 conventions of the
states in our country's history and over
200 state constitutional conventions
not one single delegate
has been recorded to have ever exceeded
their legislative commission
at no time
has either type of convention resulted
in a loss nor erosion of anything in any
state nor federal bill of rights
whenever conventions meandered outside
the scope of a delegate's commission
they have always returned to their
respective state legislatures to seek
guidance and were allowed to do so
the problem with this bill
is that it provides a false sense of
security to legislatures to legislators
sorry
since 269 members of congress if we're
talking about an article 5 convention
269 members of congress can bypass our
state legislature voters to elect
delegates to a state ratifying
convention who are committed to a no
vote
this house rejected that bill when i
introduced it a few years ago
worse state law has
that the governor not the general court
makes the appointments to conventions of
the states such as with the uniform law
commission
state legislatures make those
appointments themselves still worse is
that if this bill
if it were successful in binding any
delegate would automatically take our
delegate
out of the debate on any proposed
constitutional amendment if someone
discovered structural or constitutional
issues since they wouldn't be allowed to
vote on an amendment to the amendment or
any change to the amendment late
proposals at that convention of states
that congress
could not raise the debt ceiling without
a the ascent of three quarters of state
legislatures or limiting the scope of
spending cuts in a balanced budget
amendment which we're two states away
from now
might prevent our delegate from voting
on the matter
this bill is the worst idea since the
cia spent 20 million dollars on studies
to find out whether human beings had
psychic powers if we'd had psychic
powers we'd have known to itl this bill
red button please
the member from durham representative
horrigan is recognized to speak against
the committee report
um how is it okay
actually
thank you very much mr speaker i guess i
originally thought i was signed up to do
a
pi but plans have changed but
um
so
the main problem with this bill is that
it's uh totally unnecessary um our an
article five convention is it's not
imminent it's not on the horizon um i
if one happens
we'll have plenty of uh plenty of lead
time to
craft a bill similar
well crafty bill covering the same
subject matter as this
it's not you know we're not going to
have one next week we're not you know
we're not going to have one
for quite some time if we have one at
all um
but then the second problem is
we don't know what the rules for this
convention is even if it's a so-called
assembly of the states whatever body
uh convenes that amendment will set its
own rules they're probably
going to have nothing whatsoever
to do with the detail in this bill
and
also the whole basic concept that we're
supposed to remove these delegates if
they approve an under a so-called what
what the term is un
unapproved amendment
they'll have the same rights that we
have as members of the new hampshire
house the same rights as members
congress has those are guaranteed not
just by the us and state constitutions
but by common laws so
when we're on the floor of the
convention the people of the our
district can't can't remove us just
because they don't like our vote at
least and the same goat will same go for
those delegates regardless of whether
it's an article 5 convention could mean
by congress
or some other some other body
then finally let's say
let's say they do let's say the body
does vote for some unapproved uh
unapproved amendments um those still
have to be ratified by
a super majority of the states that's
very difficult it's happened i think
only
now i forget the exact number but i
think it's 26 times in
250 years
so anything that this convention passes
is going to be harmless unless it's
incredibly popular there's a very broad
consensus
that we should change the constitution
or even
i suppose theoretically they could even
uh enact a new conversation constitution
people talk about the articles of
convention the runaway convention
that was supposed to just amend the
articles of confederation that was a
convention that caused the us
constitution which has uh
served us well since 1789.
and um
the member from
and the the member from manchester
already mentioned this but this bill
this particular version of it is so
broadly written it covers the members of
i believe there's 41 interstate compacts
dealing with things as big as driver's
licenses
or things as small scale as our
interstate school districts in the
rivendell school district and the
hanover
the dresden school district in the
hanover area of the rivendell school
district up in the upper valley the
connecticut river so this uh
bill is you know this bill is
unnecessary it's premature
and it would have some very bad
unintended consequences
so we should uh
we should
we should overturn the octopass's
amendment and itel today and we can
always
revisit this once we know
if there's a convention we'll plenty of
time to revisit it once we know what the
framework for the convention will
actually be
thanks
so uh
vote red when we get the chance thanks
all right we are at the final speaker
and a division was requested on this so
start migrating back
the member from danville representative
wallace is recognized to speak in
support of the committee report
okay
representative wallace waves off the pi
so this will be a division vote members
take receipts
peninsula
represent wallace
all right members take your seats
also come to order
the question is on the majority
committee report of house bill 1170.
this is a division vote
representative horrigan is recognized
for parliamentary inquiry
thank you very much mr speaker
so if i know that
hb 1170 is totally unnecessary no
article 5 convention is going to happen
you know in the very near future may
happen someday but it's
it'll happen
and if i do know it's premature we will
know
when such a convention is called we're
going to know
well in advance we'll have plenty of
time to
write another bill
if i know also this bill pr a lot of the
details in the bill are highly
questionable in fact it's probably
unconstitutional
the
members would have the same rights and
responsibilities as those of any other
legislative body such as the us congress
or this house you know so
a lot of the things in the bill are
things that's just sort of the state
cannot
cannot do and
finally this also interferes with our
participation over 40 interstate
compacts
it's supposed to be a problem if i know
all these things
i apologize for leaving out the if i
know so if i know this feels unnecessary
if i know it's premature if i know it
adversely affects our participation over
40 interstate compacts
press the red button representative
are you getting to the point where
you're going to ask the question
that's a parliamentary inquiry yes if i
know all these things would i then press
the red button
representative wallace is recognized for
parliamentary inquiry thank you mr
speaker if i know that the previous two
speakers were not present for the
hearing on this bill
thank you thank you mr speaker if i know
that the two previous speakers on this
matter were not present for the hearing
on this bill and i know that the
the committee had a bipartisan amendment
to this bill and it passed
by a narrow margin when i now press the
green button
so we can be prepared for this in the
future and keep new hampshire delegates
faithful
the question is on the majority
committee report of octopass with
amendment on house bill 1170. if you're
in favor you'll press the green button
if you're opposed you'll press the red
button voting stations are open for 30
seconds
representation vote please
do
have all members president had an
opportunity to vote
the house will attend to the state of
the vote
173 having voted in the affirmative 162
on the negative the committee reporters
adopted
committee on legislative administration
to which was referred house bill 1309
knack establishing a committee to study
visiting house rules to assure that all
sections of the budget trailer bill
receive an adequate public hearing
having considered the same report the
same with the following resolution
resolve that is inexpedient to legislate
senator matthew simon for the committee
the motion before us is the inexpedient
to legislate
on house bill 1309 are you ready for the
question all those in favor say aye
those opposed nay
[Applause]
division has been has been called
members
will stay in their seats nobody can come
in
this is to verify the vote we're not
doing pis or anything
members in your seats
the motion before us is
the unexpected legislator in house bill
if you're in favor you'll press the
green button if you're imposed you'll
press the red button voting stations are
open for 30 seconds
of all members president had an
opportunity to vote house attend the
state of the vote
180 voting yeah 154 of 1480 committee
reports adopted
all rights
all right the next bill
which will be the last bill before lunch
and we have a couple of announcements
before be so don't leave before the
announcement
um
this is a
division this will be a division vote
with just parliamentary inquiries
majority of the committee on legislative
administration to which referred house
bill 1370 an act establishing a
committee due to study child care
options for new hampshire state
legislators we can consider the same
report the same with the following
resolution resolve that is inexpensive
to legislate said matthew simon for the
majority of the committee
minority of the committee having
considered the same being unable to
agree with the majority report with the
recommendation that the bill ought to
pass sent allison dunning wong for the
minority of the committee
this is going to be a division vote
members take your seats
so
the motion before us
is the majority committed report of
inexpedient to legislator on house bill
13-7-0
this is going to be a division vote
the chair recognizes representative
wilhelm for our parliamentary inquiry
thank you mr speaker
mr speaker if i know that when it comes
to serving in new hampshire's citizen
legislature which as i hope the members
assembled know
meets during the work day and pays just
a hundred dollars per year
there are significant and unique
challenges faced by parents who wish to
serve in this hallowed chamber and mr
speaker if i know that there is a great
deal of wisdom and a life experience in
this chamber which at the start of the
2021-2022
session had a median age of 61 with
nearly four in five
members over the age of 50 leaving
granite staters in their 20s 30s and 40s
many of whom have young families
significantly underrepresented
and mr speaker if i know that we have
great work to do to live up to dr king's
belief that anyone can be great because
anyone can serve
at least so far as it's concerned in our
citizen legislature and would i now push
the red button so that another motion
can be made and we can consider taking
some simple steps to make it possible
for more working parents to serve thank
you mr speaker
i recognize representative shaheen for a
shahan for a parliamentary inquiry
thank you mr speaker
mr speaker if i know that it is not the
responsibility of the general court to
provide child care options for
legislators lobbyists or visitors
and if i know in addition to the extra
cost and liability to the state
the decision to serve falls exclusively
to the legislator in his or her family
would i press the green button and
support the committee recommendation of
itl
and save us all from yet another study
committee thank you mr speaker
the motion before us is the majority
committed report of indexing to
legislative house bill 1370
this is a division vote
if you're in favor you'll press the
green button if you oppose you press the
red button voting stations are open for
30 seconds
mr speaker
if all members president had an
opportunity to vote
house will attend the state of the vote
under an 87 voting a 153 voting a
committee report is adopted
we've got i'm going to read a
proclamation
so everybody stay in your seats
and then i'm going to tell you about
lunch and then we have an announcement
from representative walner
whereas on this day march 17th irish
americans celebrate the feast of saint
patrick the patron saint of ireland
whereas on this day all who wear green
partake in the spirit of saint patrick
bridget
and this is a good word columbil
whose 1500th anniversary was observed
within the last year and whereas
we honor and acknowledge the cultural
influence and contributions of irish
immigrants
who came here and laid down a strong
foundation and called america home
whereas we celebrate the establishment
of the american irish state legislators
caucus with its mission of growing and
strengthening the long-standing
relationship that the united states of
america and ireland have enjoyed
whereas we recognize the rich cultural
history of ireland
celebrated through songs and literature
that mark the endurance of its people
the love and joy and the tragic losses
of the emerald isle and declare that
this house commemorates the celebration
of the feast of saint patrick
patron saint of ireland
and declared by virtue of my signature
subscribe below the new hampshire house
of representatives does extend its
highest accolades and plot us to the
american irish state legislators caucus
and their resolve to have this day saint
patrick's day remembered as a day of
honor the irish americans their
ancestors and traditions
and probably like a good number of
people in this body i am part irish too
so
the kiwanis club of concord is helping
us by cooking hot dogs and hamburgers
outside on the plaza
i want you to join me in thanking them
for them for their service and doing
this for us
[Applause]
the general court will be making a
donation to their organization as a
recognition of our thanks in addition to
burgers and hot dogs they'll have
various sides chips and drinks
please make your way outside to the
plaza and form a line
we don't have diamond dining tables
outside but you are free to eat inside
in the cafeteria dining area or anywhere
you'd like in or outside
just not in representatives hall
please try to return by
quarter past one at the latest
and thank thank you again
yeah
thank you again to conquer qantas wait a
minute we got one announcement please
everybody take your seats for a minute
representative walner is acknowledged
for an announcement
thank you mr speaker
and
thank you for
recognizing the irish i'm a little bit
myself
oh my mask i'm sorry
um i would just like to ask that the
democrats maybe wait a few minutes and
um during the lunch hour we'll wait to
get started
until
we get started our lunch until after
we've had a few minutes together
so thank you
house is in recess until 1 15.
so
members will take your seats the house
will come to order
the chair recognizes representative
mcguire
thank you madam speaker
the house will come to order
members will take your seats
thank you madam speaker i move that the
gentleman be allowed to remove their
jackets
except at the well
so moved
oh without objection so moved
the majority of the committee on
municipal and county government to which
was referred house bill 1046
an act relative to the election of the
sullivan county commissioners
having considered the same report the
same with the following resolution
resolved that it is inexpedient to
legislate representative richard tripp
for the majority of the committee
the minority of the committee having
considered the same and being unable to
agree with the majority report with the
recommendation that the bill ought to
pass
representative rosemary run for the
minority of the committee
the chair recognizes representative
tripp to speak in favor of the committee
nope
oh i'm sorry
representative rung to speak against the
committee report
thank you very much madam speaker
hb 1046 is a simple and straightforward
bill brought to the municipal and county
government committee by sullivan county
delegates
it would allow voters in each of the
three districts of sullivan county to be
the only ones
to elect their county commissioner
presently each voter in sullivan county
has a say in who gets elected to every
other county district
even if the voter does not reside in
that district
opponents of this bill
none of whom live in sullivan county
say that it is not clear
difficult to understand
and needs more study
well eight of the ten counties in new
hampshire already do this
it doesn't make much sense does it
it's an anomaly in new hampshire
elections
only carroll county elects their county
commissioners this way besides sullivan
county but belknap chesser
cheshire coast grafton hillsborough
merrimack rockingham and stratford
elect commissioners by district
and only by the voters that reside in
those districts
imagine being elected by voters who
don't even live in your district
and worse
imagining voting for someone who doesn't
even live in your district
this is the reality for the folks
residing in the three districts of
sullivan county
colleagues don't have people elect other
people's representatives
let people elect their own
representative
if eight of the ten counties in new
hampshire can do it so can sullivan
county
please vote no
to expedia to legislate so a motion to
pass this bill can be made thank you
the chair recognizes
the
member from dairy representative tripp
to speak in for the committee report
thank you mr speaker
i rise in support of the committee's
recommendation of inexpedient
to legislate
house bill 1046 seeks to change the
process by which sullivan county
commissioners are elected
for more than 30 years
the county commissioners have been
elected by all the voters in the county
rather than just a district they
represent
it is one of three counties
carol stafford and sullivan which used
this method
to elect the county commissioners
this bill seeks to limit voters to only
those in the district the commissioner
seeks to represent
during the bill's hearing it was argued
that the commissioners should be elected
only by those they will be representing
it was also mentioned the campaigning
for commissioner
is expensive since they have to do
throughout the county rather than just
within the district
i wonder what the actual reason for
changing from at large the district is
is it representation or the cost of
campaigning
as previously stated carroll county has
been using the at large election
method for more than 30 years
it seems that the at-large method for
electing commissioners is preferred by
the voters in this county
if this is the voter's wish then why
should the method of voting be changed
have election be changed
thank you very much and i ask you press
the green button and support the
committee's recommendation of
inexpension and expedient to legislate
okay the motion on the floor is the
majority recommendation of an expedient
to legislate are you ready for the
question
division has been requested members will
take their seats
this will be a division vote if you are
in favor you will press the green button
if you are opposed you will press
oh wait a minute
first i'm going to recognize
representative band for a parliamentary
inquiry
ban right b-a-n-n
whoops
i'm sorry
thank you madam speaker and thank you
members of the house if i know that
people ought to be able to vote for
their own representatives and not for
those
that do not representative represent
them
and if i know that most of the counties
in new hampshire
use this method
would i now
press
the red
button
so that another motion can be brought
thank you
the chair recognizes representative
mcdonald for pipe pi
thank you madam speaker
madam speaker if i know that hp 1046
would change a long established process
30 plus years of all sullivan county
voters electing their county
commissioners
and madam speaker if i know that the
responsibility of each county
commissioner should be to represent the
best interest of all county residents
and madam speaker if i know that there
are two other counties in new hampshire
in which voters elect the county
commissioners the same way as sullivan
county
and madame speaker if i know that the
cost of running a county-wide campaign
should not be reached for changing a
long-established law
madam speaker request that everyone
press the green button in order to
support the committee's recommendation
of itl thank you
the question is on the majority
committee report of itl on hb1046
if you are in favor you will press the
green button if you are opposed you will
press the red button voting stations
will be open for 30 seconds
have all members present had the
opportunity to vote the house will
attend to the state of the vote
158 in the affirmative 169 in the
negative the motion fails
representative wrong moves the minority
report of itl
yes thank you otp
yeah
i'm sorry
thank you madam speaker i move ought to
pass on hb 1046
and i ask for a division vote
this is a division vote members will
take their seats
this is a division vote the motion on
the floor is the minority report of
ought to pass
if you are in favor you will press the
green button if you are opposed you will
press the red button voting stations
will be open for 30 seconds
[Music]
have all members present had the
opportunity to vote the house will
attend to the state of the vote
192 in the affirmative 141 in the
negative the minority report is adopted
the majority of the committee on
municipal and county government to which
was referred hb 1070 and act relative to
the default budget
in official ballot jurisdictions having
considered the same report the same with
the recommendation that the bill ought
to pass representative richard tripp for
the majority of the committee
the minority of the committee having
considered the same and being unable to
agree with the majority report with the
following resolution resolved that is
inexpedient to legislate representative
julie gilman for the minority of the
committee the chair recognizes
representative gilman
to speak against the committee report
thank you madam speaker
this bill is yet another manipulation of
the definition of default budgets in
official ballot town meetings
and i know when you hear official town
ballot town meetings your eyes are going
to roll
and the and when you hear default budget
that's also going to make your eyes roll
but here we are again
the new language includes
less any reduction to an appropriation
the governing body made in the proposed
operating budget
so this will now use three different
budgets to calculate the default budget
for the third fiscal year
fiscal year 22 operating budget and
default budgets are based on fiscal year
21.
do we need more or less of something
have we overspent or underspent
something
the fiscal year 2022 default default
budget is based on the difference
between 21 and 22
budgets
21 and 22 budgets with the additions and
subtractions as specified in the current
rsa
the proposed fiscal year 23 budget and
subsequent default are based on the
operating budget of fiscal year 22.
this bill includes contracts in its
definition of the default budget
calculation
but in fact
the existing rsa there is a definition
of contracts saying that contracts
previously approved in the amount so
approved
are included in the default budget
for example in fiscal year 21 the voters
approved a three-year contract at 20 000
per year
during fiscal 20 year 22 a conservative
fiduciary decision offered the
municipality the ability to pay off that
last year of the contract that had been
approved at 20k
for 21 22 and 23.
with this bill the proposed fiscal year
23 and its default budget
do not include that contract
appropriation because it hasn't been
because it's been paid off and is no
longer needed in the budget
but the 20k as previously approved
contract included in fiscal year 2023
default budget because the voters
contracted an amount approved in 2021
20k for four-year contract paid off
no longer necessary but is necessary
because that's the definition of
contracts
so the default budget is going to be
twenty thousand dollars more than the
proposed budget
the new language in this bill conflicts
because it requires that change
and and doesn't include the money that
we would not have had to appropriate
there's an approved contract in the
amount so approved but the voters
previously had not
previously had approved it
the circular calculation and confusion
is one of the problems that the minority
had with the
and do not agree with the ought to pass
recommendation and i asked for a
division vote
the chair recognizes the member from
litchfield representative boehm to speak
in favor of the committee report
thank you madam chair
the reason for the municipal budget law
was that towns did not have a facility
big enough to hold regular town or
school district meetings
one town i know it had the tv set up
between
multiple places
so this was passed back i believe 95 and
was initially called sb2 so still
reference to that sb2 towns and it will
only affect those towns that have passed
this and school district
this bill is common sense if the
governing body reduces something in
their proposed operating budget they
must make the same reduction in the
default
the argument about contracts contracts
will be in both
the proposed operating budget and the
default budget so that's not an issue
but
but after a while when the first time it
was passed for the first number of years
the default was always lower
than a proposed operating budget but
after a while certain associations
and lawyers figure out a way by using
the wording of the law to manipulate the
default budget to make it higher than
the operating budget to ensure that the
budget will pass but that was not the
intent of the law
and if you read the section 4013
roman 11 there c
is pretty much says it
this is what's got to be on the
shall the local governing body political
suffer raise an appropriate operating
budget so much and then it says
should this article be defeated
then the default budget will be this
okay
or
the governing body
may hold one special meeting in
accordance with this law to take the
issue of a revised operating budget only
so
if your governing body your selectment
or your school board
have a higher default budget
and it the
warrant passes are they going to have a
special meeting because they got more
money than they asked for i don't think
so
so that's why they're manipulating the
default to be higher
than the operating budget
what school district is going to follow
the law if for example not needing three
teachers they are removed from the
proposed operating budget but left in
the default
of course the default is going to be
higher
if the teacher's contract says they will
fund clubs and sports stipends for say
for twenty thousand but never spent more
than fifteen thousand you guess that the
proposed operating budget will be
fifteen thousand but the default will be
twenty
on the town side if every other year the
town buys two police cruisers but then
then one the next year
guess what the year one will have two in
the default
et cetera et cetera you know this is not
common sense and
for example in this year in my school
district the proposed operating budget
is twenty three million seven hundred
thousand
the default is 24 million
of course how you people and the people
did vote for the
operating budget because the default was
higher and sometimes they say no and not
realizing that they're spending more
money
so
and like i said before contracts
teachers contract will be an addition
not a reduction
in both contra and both the proposed so
it's not going to be higher because of
that the default is higher because of
manipulation
thank you
a division must be requested the members
will take their seats
a roll call has been requested is that
sufficiently seconded yes that is
sufficiently seconded members will take
their seats
the question is on the majority report
of ought to pass for hb-1070
this is a roll call vote
if you are in favor you will press the
green button if you are opposed you will
press the red button voting stations
will be open
oh
and now i'm going to do pis
the chair recognizes representative
stavis
thank you madam speaker
madam speaker if i know that hb 1070
conflicts with existing laws in numerous
ways
and if i know that default budgets do
not include previously approved
contracts such as bond agreements
and if i further know that this
oversight concerning contracts and bonds
will result in a tangle of confusion for
towns across the state
would i now press the red button to
defeat the majorities ought to pass
recommendation so that another motion
can be made
the chair recognizes representative
lasalles to speak in favor of the
committee report
for parliamentary inquiry
thank you madam speaker
madam speaker if i know
that when you have an
issue where budgets continually
over and over and over again
year after year
the default budget comes out greater
than the operating budget
how would you feel
if you're on a budget committee
and spend all those time
times
working on the operating budget
and when it comes to this is this is a
pi
my apology
if i know
that we need to stop the kabuki dance
and press the green button thank you
house will be in order
the question is on the majority
committee report of ought to pass for
hb-1070
this is a roll call vote if you are in
favor you will press the green button if
you are opposed you will rest you will
press the
green button the red button
voting stations are open for 30 seconds
have all members president had an
opportunity to vote the house
well
okay the house will attend to the state
no
this gentleman
have all members present had the
opportunity to vote
the house will attend to the state of
the boat
with 172 in the affirmative and 162 in
the negative the majority report is
adopted
the majority of the committee on
municipal and county government to which
was referred hb 1081 and act relative to
the dissolution of a village district
having considered the same report the
same with the recommendation that the
bill ought to pass represent
representative richard tripped for the
majority of the committee
the minority of the committee having
considered the same being unable to
agree with the majority report that the
following resolution resolution resolved
that is inexpedient to legislate
representative jim maggiore for the
minority of the committee
the chair recognizes representative rung
to speak against the committee report
thank you madam speaker
hb 1081
is one of those bills that tricks you
into thinking that an equivalency exists
that an action on one side must be met
with the same action on the other side
in this case that since only a simple
majority is needed to form a village
district that the right thing to do is
to change the law so that only a simple
majority is needed to dissolve it
with village districts nothing could be
further from the truth
to illustrate my point i will use the
merrimack village district as an example
it's my hometown municipal water
district
it was founded by a simple majority to
supply municipal water to the residents
in merrimack
at the time the vote was taken residents
did not have municipal water
nor did mvd have any assets or capital
nor did it have any employees
it was nothing but a dream to the voters
of merrimack
in fact if that vote had failed
merrimack residents would have been no
worse off than when they were there
before the vote was taken
a simple majority was exactly that
simple
fast forward to today
mvd manages over 7500
service locations
which is more than 87 percent of the
town
these locations include residents
municipal commercial and industrial
properties
nvd services and maintains
approximately
176 miles of water mains
fire hydrants
6 wells
three storage tanks
an iron and manganese treatment plant
three booster stations and a pfast
treatment plant with two more coming
online later this year
as you can see
this village district like many others
throughout new hampshire is not simple
mvd's total assets are over 34 million
dollars
if we require two-thirds vote majority
vote
to acquire bonded debt
shouldn't we maintain the same threshold
when we are divesting far greater
holdings
but beyond our fiduciary responsibility
we have a responsibility to the lives of
granite staters
village districts
provide essential
life-dependent resources to our citizens
water
fire and emergency response wastewater
treatment
and a host of other targeted services
making the decision to dissolve those
services from our communities is not
something to be taken lightly
certainly not lighter than a decision to
secure a bond
let's keep the two-thirds vote
requirement to dissolve a village
district let's not change the law when
so much is at stake
please vote no on ought to pass thank
you
the chair recognizes representative
jonathan smith defeats me speak in favor
of the committee report
thank you madam speaker
hb 1081 really is a simple bill the
purpose is to change the legal
requirement to dissolve a village
district from a two-thirds majority of
legal voters to a simple majority of
legal voters
the simple majority standard is what is
used to create the village district
a village district should be no harder
to dissolve than it was to create the
change is about fairness to the voter
i have had concerns from people asking
if the bill allows non-residents to vote
the answer is no the standard of voting
is like every other election in the
state you must be a legally registered
voter and only those present and voting
are counted that was a court case sugar
hill association versus lisbon 1962.
during testimony i had questions
comparing the bill to a bond
which has a two-third majority
requirement but was lowered to a
three-fifths majority requirement in
2020 by this legislature
the only way to answer answer the
question regarding bonding and village
district is that bonding and dissolving
a village district are entirely two
different subjects
finally the minority blurb indicated
that the municipality would absorb the
cost of the dissolved district which is
not correct rsa 5221 states clearly the
selectmen of the town or towns in which
the district was situated shall assess
the taxes and betterment assessments in
the same manner
as if the district had not been
dissolved
to close this bill is about fairness to
the voter and i ask you to push green
for otp thank you
the question on the floor
is the adoption of the
majority committee report for ought to
pass on hb1081
are you ready for the question
a division has been requested
a roll call has been requested
is that sufficiently seconded
yes that is sufficiently seconded
the house will
come to order
the house will come to order
the chair recognizes representative
maggiore for parliamentary inquiry
thank you madam speaker madam speaker if
i know that dissolving a village
district is more than just erasing a
line
and if i know that within the boundaries
or lines of that village district the
residents of that district may have
created their own public safety
departments
may have hired first responders and
employees
may have built wastewater treatment
facilities
may have installed infrastructure such
as sidewalks street lights parks
recreation fields fire hydrants all as
permitted by law
and if i know that this illusion of such
a district would mean that the
surrounding community would then need to
absorb all the costs
for that infrastructure employees
maintenance
and long-term payments
then finally madam speaker if i know
that the disillusioned assist of the
district and said investment should
require a two-thirds majority of voters
rather than a simple majority
then would you please vote red so that
another motion can be made thank you
the chair recognizes representative
jonathan smith for a parliamentary
inquiry
thank you madam speaker if i know that
it takes a simple majority to create a
village district and i also know that it
should not be any harder to dissolve a
village district than it is to create
would i now press the green button thank
you
the question is on the majority
committee report about to pass on hb one
zero eight one
this is a roll call vote if you are in
favor you will press
the green button if you are opposed you
will press the red button voting
stations are open for 30 seconds
have all members present had the
opportunity to vote
the house will attend to the state of
the vote
with 174 members in the affirmative
and 162 in the negative the motion
passes
what happened
oh did i forget oh
i've never done it up here before so
i'm feeling a little nervous and very
humble right now
for what purpose does the member rise
uh madam speaker i first wish to say i
think i speak on behalf of the house and
say that we think you're doing a great
job and we appreciate you thank you
but i'd like to be recognized for a
motion
state your motion
i move hb 1076 be pulled off the table
and i'd like a division vote
labor
the motion is to pull house bill 1076
off the table
[Music]
roll call
has been requested is that sufficiently
seconded that is sufficiently seconded
the members will take your seat
i'm waiting
the house will come to order
the chair recognizes representative
adjacent for a parliamentary inquiry
thank you madam speaker
if i know
that the underlying bill
with the otpa motion
seeks to rein in some of the biggest
excesses from big tech
by ensuring that large companies that
use productivity quotas cannot deny
their employees the bathroom breaks that
they are legally entitled to but are
being denied due to a small technicality
that we seek to fix
if i know that this bill thanks to
much much bipartisan cooperation on the
labor committee and weeks and weeks of
negotiations in good faith with the
chair and my friend from manchester
passed and the labor committee deemed it
ought to pass on the floor of the house
and if i know those things
and
if i spent this weekend calling my
friends asking them to listen to the
debate
and i want to be sure that there is a
debate for them to listen to would i now
vote green
and allow the bill to come off the table
thank you
the chair recognizes representative
osborne for a parliamentary inquiry
well thank you madam speaker if i know
that i just had the pleasure of
listening to an entire speech on this
bill would i leave this on the table
right now
the house will come to order
the question is on polling hb stations
are open for 30 seconds
representatives
[Music]
have all members present had the
opportunity to vote
the house will attend to the state of
the vote
165 in the affirmative 171 in the
negative
the motion fails
the majority of the committee on
municipal and county government to which
was referred house bill 1087
an act relative to zoning for
single-family housing lots having
considered the same report the same with
the following resolution resolved that
it is inexpedient to legislate
representative joseph go three for the
majority of the committee
the minority of the committee having
considered the same and being unable to
agree with the majority report that the
report with the recommendation that the
bill ought to pass representative
laurels davis for the minority of the
committee
the chair recognizes
representative van to speak in
opposition to the committee report
thank you madam speaker
and thank you members of the house
i rise to oppose
the inexpedient to a legislate
on this bill because
there's really
no reason
to require
half an acre
or more
for a single family house
served by water and sewer
there's no reason why you couldn't have
one it's the requiring that's the
problem
land costs are a big part
of the cost of a single family house
usually you say it's about 20 percent
so as
people are building houses if i have to
spend
a hundred thousand dollars on a lot
i'm gonna have to build build
a bigger
fancier
more expensive house
on that lot
if we want to encourage
the creation
of smaller houses
at a lower cost
one thing that we can do
is stop
artificially requiring
big
lots
that's what this bill does it says you
can't
require
a large lot
if it is served by water and sewer which
of course is a big important piece of
that
because we all know that you need
x amount of square footage to safely
have a well and septic
so this only applies to places that have
municipal
water
and sewer
it doesn't preclude people from
buying larger pieces of land
whether they're individuals or
developers
it just says
don't require
a really big piece of land
the other thing i'd remind you is that
if you look
at
historic surveys of new hampshire towns
the sanford insurance maps are the most
famous ones
and what you'll see is that
in most town centers
the lots are considerably smaller than a
half an acre when i did the survey for
the town i live in
it looks like
our average lot size
in the what you would think of as the
village compact
is about
8 000 square feet
so
this is not an unusual thing to have
a smaller lot
it's a pretty usual thing
and we need to stop requiring bigger
ones in places where they're not
required
please vote red
on the unexpedient legislate
so that another motion can be brought
thank you
the chair recognizes representative
dolan
for a motion thank you madam speaker i'd
like to make a motion to table
the motion on the floor is to table
house bill 1087
all those in favor say aye
those oppose nay
the eyes have it emotion is adopted
i did say it i'm sorry
the majority of the committee on
municipal and county government to which
was referred house bill 112 fn and act
relative to competitive bidding in
countries having considered the same
report the same with the following
resolved that is inexpedient to
legislate representative richard tripp
for the majority of the committee
the minority of the committee having
considered the same and being unable to
agree with the majority report that with
the recommendation that the bill ought
to pass representative julie gilman for
the majority of the committee
the question is on the majority
committee report of
itl
you ready for the question
although a division has been requested
members will take their seats
the house will come to order
the chair recognizes representative
maggiore for a parliamentary inquiry
thank you madam chair
if i know that
a very valuable tenant is to treat like
things alike
and that competitive bidding for
community or for counties
would allow us to do that and
competitive and if i know excuse me if i
know
that competitive bidding
is a better guarantee for getting better
pricing and we all want to have the
lowest price available for things that
are very important to our counties then
would i please vote which way do i want
to go
then would i please vote against the
motion so that another motion can be
made plus
red
red thank you thank you
madam
the chair recognizes representative
dolan for a parliamentary inquiry
thank you madam speaker i'd like to make
a motion
to table so
you're doing a pi
for dissimilar end entities
and i know that local control is our
means of operation
in this state of new hampshire
would i now
press the green button
support the itl
the question is on
the majority committee report of itl on
hb112fn
this will be a division vote if you are
in favor you will press the green button
if you are opposed you will press the
red button voting stations are open for
30 seconds
have all members present had an
opportunity to vote
the house will attend to the state of
the vote
with the 175 in the affirmative and 160.
i
did did it go
see i'm hitting it he closed the vote
he closed the vote okay
so
state state the vote he closed it he
closed it on our end so it's not we
can't show it so this wasn't my fault
okay
with 175 in the affirmative and 163 in
the negative the motion fails
oh it passed i'm sorry it passed
the majority of the committee on
municipal and county government to which
was referred hb 1119
act relative to the regulation of
single-use bags having considered the
same report the same with the following
resolution resolved that it is
inexpedient to legislate representative
charles melvin
for the majority of the committee the
minority of the committee having
considered the same and being unable to
agree with the majority report with the
following amendment and the
recommendation that the bill ought to
pass with amendment representative
rosemary rung for the minority of the
committee for what purpose does the
member rise
to make a motion madam speaker state
your motion i'd like to make a motion to
table
hb1119
okay the motion on the floor is to table
house bill one one
one nine
are you ready for the question
representative bird has requested a roll
call is that sufficiently seconded
it is sufficiently seconded this will be
a roll call vote members will take their
seats
the house will come to order
this is a roll call vote the question is
on house bill one one one nine the
majority report of and i
owe the motion to table
if you are in favor you will press the
green button if you are opposed you will
press the red button voting stations are
open for 30 seconds
i hit hit open button
okay just keep voting
the house will come to order
the house will be in order
with 300 in the affirmative and 35 in
the negative hb 119 is laid upon the
table
madam
for what purpose does the member rise
to make a motion madam chair please
state your motion
having voted on the prevailing side of
house bill 1087
and
not sure that the vote was
correctly called although not not on
purpose i would
is it table can i can i move to
reconsider
can i move to take it off the table
okay
so the motion is to reconsider
no
to remove house bill 1087 from the table
are you ready for the question
all those division vote has been
requested
the chair recognizes representative
vervo for parliamentary inquiry thank
you madam speaker
if i know that i voted on the prevailing
side
but i also
believe that the gavel came down quickly
and perhaps
the true will of the body was not
determined
and if i believe that the rightful and
fair thing to do would be to allow the
division vote on the tabling motion
but also madam speaker if i believe
if i know
that i do not support removing this bill
from the table
would i now not press
the shiny
red button
to leave this bill
on the table thank you madam speaker
the house will be in order
the chair recognizes representatives
davis for a parliamentary inquiry the
house will be in order
thank you madam speaker i think i hope
i'm doing the right thing here
madam speaker if i know that we are in
the midst of an unprecedented housing
shortage
and if i know that we need housing of
all kinds to alleviate this crisis
if i further know that hp 1087 would
make it easier to build single-family
homes in areas served by public water
and sewer and if i know that doing so
would have zero impact on the beautiful
rural parts of our state
would i now press the red button to
defeat the majority's inexpedient
the green button
to remove it from the table thank you
madam speaker
the question before the house
is removing
hb1087 from the table
if you are in favor you will press the
green button if you are opposed you will
press the red button voting stations are
open for 30 seconds
representatives representative macbeth
have all members present had the
opportunity to vote the house will
attend to the state of the vote
166 in the affirmative 169 in the
negative the motion fails
the majority of the committee on
municipal and county government to which
was referred hb 1172 fn
an act requiring composting and waste
recycling to be made available to
residents of public housing having
considered the same report the same with
the recommendation that the bill be
referred for interim study
representative ivy van for the majority
of the committee
the minority of the committee
having considered the same and being
unable to agree with the majority report
that the following resolution resolved
that is inexpedient to legislate
representative tony piamonte for the
minority of the committee
are you ready for the question
all those in favor say aye
those oppose nay
the eyes have it and the committee
report is adopted
the majority of the committee on
municipal and county government to which
was referred hb 1177
and act relative to permissible
residential units in a residential zone
having considered the same report the
same with the recommendation that the
bill off to pass representative ivey van
for the majority of the committee
the minority of the committee i mean
having considered the same
and being unable to agree with the
majority report with the following
resolution resolve that it is
inexpedient to legislate representative
richard tripp for the minority of the
committee
the chair recognizes representative
abrams from some to speak against the
committee report
i almost got to sit down
thank you madam speaker madam speaker i
rise in opposition to the ought to pass
motion on house bill 1177 requiring
apartment buildings
be added in suburban areas
almost the same bill
came through municipal and county when i
was there and comes through almost every
year this bill
tries to override local control by
forcing our towns and cities to accept
apartment buildings where the voters
have only improved the construction of a
single family house
according the bill quote
these may be configured as a single four
unit building two duplex units two
single units one duplex unit with two
accessory buildings
four town houses or a single family
house with three accessory dwelling
units
really
but you can't have a duplex a townhouse
and an accessory for each
how about a mini courtyard plus
for three plus a whole mcmansion added
on or two two houses in a hotel on
marvin gardens
will this require that towns accept a
four-story high mini skyscraper like
those in downtown manchester near where
i used to live
should even the inner suburbs of
manchester be required by the state
to allow buildings that would only fit
in the busier parts of elm street
and would buildings on elm street be
torn down and replaced with pairs of
duplexes contrary to the intent of the
planners at city hall who put years and
years and years into developing their
city's plan a kind of nightmare on elm
street
towns like
towns like seabrook okay
it wasn't meant to be a joke but i guess
it is
towns like seabrook are already
overloaded with apartment buildings and
most people there are now dead set
against them i used to serve on my
town's planning board and every single
member of my planning board was opposed
to adding apartment buildings to my town
should the state override the will of
the voters also
should towns like hampton falls and
hampton be commanded by another top-down
one-size-fits-all solution to replace
the suburbs with medium density
apartment buildings over 40 feet high
blocking everyone's view of the water
would you want to see your neighborhood
overbuilt
would you want to explain to angry an
angry planning board and other land use
boards while you've thrown out years of
town planning built around limited
municipal services and staff to turn
everything
into something that looks somewhat like
downtown lawrence
what will we tell our constituents when
we see when they see their property tax
rates nearly double because of the
sudden need to add two police
stations to fire stations another high
school
to serve a state induced surge in
migration and where will already
overworked water departments find more
water and bigger pipes in towns that are
already at their limit
or six million dollars for a new
wastewater treatment facility how will
our emergency rooms and fire departments
deal with a large influx of people
moving up from lynn and lawrence and
north shore mass because thousands of
cheaply built low income stack and pack
or section 8 apartment buildings are
only 10 feet apart sometimes not far
enough apart
for our fire trucks in some of these
small towns
this bill is the worst idea since
congress forced us to pay for giant pink
flatulence balloons that cows have to
have strapped on to combat global
warming please press the red button
for what purpose does the member rise to
make a motion
please state your motion yes i'd like to
make a motion to table this bill
the motion on the floor is to table
house bill
a division vote has been requested
members will take their seats
i'm going to do the pi
i just wanted to move for a roll call
a roll call has been requested is that
sufficiently seconded
it's hard to tell that is sufficiently
seconded members will take their seeds
are you doing the piano
a week ago
just the day before the last session
the house will come to order
the chair recognizes representative bob
disarro for a parliamentary inquiry
thank you madam speaker madam speaker if
i know that this bill allows residential
zones single-family homes be re-zoned in
purposes for up to four residential
units and madam speaker if i know new
hampshire believes in local control and
if i know statewide zoning mandates
creates a one size fits all
and madam speaker if i know many in this
house have invested their hard earned
money and property only to have it
changed by a vote here in the house when
i press the green button and table is
bill
the house will come to order
the chair recognizes representative van
for a parliamentary inquiry thank you
madam speaker members of the house if i
know that new hampshire is short
somewhere between 20 and 30 000 housing
units
and if i know
that our restrictive zoning is part of
the reason that we cannot build more
units and if i know
that this bill allows four
four
four units
and if i know that the federal home
administration believes that four units
is a house
would i now vote red
against the tabling motion
so that we can debate this bill
thank you very much
the question is on the tabling motion
for hb1177
this is a roll call vote if you are in
favor you will press the green button if
you are opposed you will press the red
button voting stations are open for 30
seconds
representative cohen
have all members present had the
opportunity to vote the house will
attend to the state of the vote
167 in the affirmative 157 in the
negative the motion passes
so
for what reason does a member rise
um i like the remarks i move that the
remarks of the previous debate be added
to the permanent journal
i move that the remarks of the previous
debate be
entered into the permanent journal
holy feedback
okay so i already heard an objection the
motion is
to print the remarks of the previous
debate in the permanent journal
and a division has been requested
members should probably still be in
their seats but this is a division vote
there's some out there
he has a question
in the voting mode
graham
all right it's time for members to go to
their seats
the question is whether to print the
remarks of the previous debate in the
permanent journal this is a division
vote hey where you headed
okay
so like i said this is to print the
remarks of the previous debate in the
permanent journal if you're in favor
you'll press the green button if you're
opposed you'll press the red button
voting stations are open for 30 seconds
so
representative sandler representative
laid
representative fargo
have all members president had an
opportunity to vote
the house will attend to the state of
the vote
199 having voted in the affirmative 136
and the negative the remarks will be
printed
the majority of the committee on
municipal and county governments which
is referred to house bill 1184 an act
authorizing the establishment of
revolving funds having considered the
same report the same with the following
resolution resolve that it is an
expedient to legislate representative
john mcdonald from the majority of the
committee
the minority committee having considered
the same and being unable to agree with
the majority report with the
recommendation that the bill ought to
pass representative rosemary rung for
the minority of the committee
the question is on the majority
committee report of an expediency
legislate are you ready for the question
all those in favor say aye
all those opposed nay
the eyes
and the committee reporters adopt
to make a motion
okay state your motion
mr speaker i move to have house bill
1194 placed on the table
oh yeah we don't have that bill up mr
speaker can you wait a little while for
me to get my head together
i didn't mean that
sorry
totally wrong my fault
all right
the majority of the committee on
municipal and county governments which
was referred to house bill 1194 and act
relative to the procedure for overriding
a local tax cap having considered the
same report the same with the
recommendation that the bill ought to
pass representative diane power for the
majority of the committee
the minority of the committee having
considered the same and being unable to
agree with the majority report with the
following resolution resolved that it is
inexpedient to legislate representative
julie gilman for the minority of the
committee
now what reason does the member rise
to hopefully improve on my last request
mr speaker mr speaker i make a motion to
place
1194 on the table should you agree
motion is to lay house bill 1194 on the
table
our division has been requested this
will be a division vote members take
your seats
who requested a roll call
all right
representative requests a roll call and
it is sufficiently seconded
they are
somebody over there isn't doing the pi
thank you mr speaker
hang on a sec
and uh members should be in their seats
okay there's a division vote
the motion is delayed house bill 1194
oh it's a roll call my bad
to lay house bill 1194 on the table
representative manager foodie is
recognized for a parliamentary inquiry
thank you mr speaker
if i know
that this bill will only impact
seven communities out of 280
communities in new hampshire it only
impacts
seven
and we do not need it i would
urge you to press green color of my
jacket
irish luck
thank you
representative dolan is recognized for
parliamentary inquiry
thank you mr speaker
i think we've wasted enough time on this
so i'm just going to say that
vote against representative dolan
yes you're recognized for parliamentary
inquiry
if i know
that this bill
should not go not come off the table
i'm sorry
if i know
that this bill should not come off the
table
not go on the table i'm sorry
but i press the red button and get it
over with
[Applause]
the house will be in order
and that's why we do increase so we can
get the answers
okay so this is a roll call vote
chile house bill 1194 on the table if
you're in favor you'll press the green
button if you're opposed you'll press
the red button voting stations are open
for 30 seconds
so
[Music]
representatives
representative kittridge
have all members president had an
opportunity to vote
the house will attend to the state of
the vote
148 in the affirmative 181 and negative
the motion fails
back to the majority committee report
ought to pass
the member from exeter representative
gilman is recognized to speak against
the committee report
where is he at
thank you mr chair hang on a sec
the house will be in order so that we
can hear the member at the well please
sorry go ahead thank you mr speaker
house bill 1194
proposes a change to the voting process
of a tax cap override in a town or
district that has adopted rsa 32 colon
b-5
the proposed legislation requires a
three-fifth super-majority vote for tax
cap override which is already specified
in rsa 32 colon
c
used for budget approval
the bill was proposed as a clarification
but is now confusing section b with
section c
further it has an additional change to
include only the first year payment of a
multi-year bond in the cap calculation
disregarding any debt service
and it's not clear what happens after
the initial payment or what may accrue
the following years
capital bonds are voted separately from
operating budgets
in the in the first year and then if
approved are appropriated in the
subsequent operating budgets
a further concern is that the bond
ratings may be affected by the lack of
guaranteed payments that were not
considered with this bill
it is also it also has no provision for
the possibility of rising inflation
this bill is not as clarifying as it
says it wanted to be
it leads to more questions than answers
for these reasons the minority found
this bill in expedient to legislate and
mr speaker i ask for division vote
the member from brookline representative
power is recognized to speak in support
of the committee report
thank you mr speaker
mr speaker i rise in support
of the committee recommendation of ought
to pass on house bill 1194.
year after year new hampshire citizens
are faced with increased local spending
and escalating tax bills
making it extremely difficult for some
to make ends meet in the granite state
house bill 1194 helps to address the
problem of escalating taxes resulting
from unsustainable spending at the local
level
currently a tax cap may be adopted with
a three-fifth super-majority vote by the
legislative body and
with just a simple majority vote the
legislative body can override a tax cap
this bill addresses this problem
since the purpose of a tax cap is to
ensure fiscal responsibility and
prudence in spending is therefore
reasonable that any proposed spending
which exceeds the tax cap should
have a higher standard to pass
than just a simple majority
and furthermore since a super majority
is required to adopt a tax cap
then it makes sense that a super
majority should be required to override
a tax cap
requiring a three-fifth super-majority
override will ensure
that any spending that exceeds a tax cap
is both warranted and is supported by
the legislative body
additionally
it is important to note that in this
bill in no way limits the legislative
body's authority
to either increase or decrease the
amount of any single appropriation or
the total amount of all appropriations
in conclusion
this bill
puts teeth
into a toothless tax cap
and it provides an essential tool
for new hampshire taxpayers to more
effectively
manage unsustainable spending and keep
local taxes under control
for these reasons i urge my fellow
colleagues to support
the committee recommendation of ought to
pass
by voting yes on house bill 1194
by pushing the green button
thank you mr speaker
the questions on the majority committee
report of ought to pass are you ready
for the question
a division has been requested members
take receipts or a roll call who's who
requested a roll call
representative trojan requests a roll
call is that sufficiently seconded it is
this will be a roll call vote
faster we get to our seats faster we can
go home
members take your seats please
all right
close enough
the questions on the majority committee
report of
ought to pass representative maggiore is
recognized for parliamentary inquiry
thank you mr speaker mr speaker if i
know that this bill is not merely a bill
to create the voting percentage to
create a local tax cap
and if mr speaker if i know that the
additional language in this bill
requires that only the first year
payment on a bond
long-term contract municipal project
capital improvement project are the
numbers that should be used in the
analysis for the tax cap and not the
subsequent years
and if mr speaker if i know that this
bill only applies to seven
out of the 234 municipalities and school
units in new hampshire and that none of
those communities testified about a
problem within their communities and
finally mr speaker if i know that we
should preserve the local authority
that legislative bodies and school
districts need to negotiate their own
prudent funding without any additional
interference from the state then would i
press the red red button to overturn the
otp so that a different motion can be
made thank you mr speaker
representative silver is recognized for
parliamentary inquiry
thank you mr speaker mr speaker if i
know that across the granite state
taxpayers are met year after year
with increasing local budgets in taxes
in towns cities and schools
resulting in constantly escalating tax
bills year after year making it
difficult for our constituents and their
families to make their ends meet
and mr speaker if i know that local tax
caps have been enacted in many parts of
the state
in an attempt to moderate the increasing
tax burdens on our families
and mr speaker if i know that current
law
enables the voters of a town or district
to adopt a local tax cap
by a three-fifth super majority
but allows the legislative body to
override the tax cap
by but a simple majority vote
and mr speaker if i know that hb 1194
would change the vote to override
a local tax cap
from a simple majority
to the same three-fifths super majority
now required to put the tax cap in plate
in the first place
and if i know that hb 1194 would provide
new hampshire taxpayers
with an important tool
that can enable them to more effectively
manage
unsustainable spending at the local
level in an effort to keep tax increases
at more reasonable
levels then would i press the bright
green button
to approve the otp motion to adopt hp
1194. thank you mr speaker
all right we're in the voting mode
representatives should have been all
along in their seats
the questions on the majority committee
report about to pass
this is a roll call vote if you're in
favor you'll press the green button if
you're opposed you'll press the red
button voting stations are open for 30
seconds
wearing nothing green
okay
representative bose
representative hamm
representative ammon
of all members president an opportunity
to vote
the house will attend to the state of
the vote
183 in the affirmative 146 and the
negative the committee reports adopted
majority of the committee on municipal
and county government to which was
referred house bill 1219 and act
relative to parking requirements for
religious institutional affiliated
housing
development projects having considered
the same report the same with the
following resolution resolve that it's
inexpedient to legislate
senator paul heir for the majority of
the committee
minority of the committee having
considered the same being unable to
agree with the majority report the
recommendation that the bill be referred
for interim study
representative eric gallagher from the
minority of the committee
g.i recognizes representative gallagher
senator gallagher waves off
chair recognizing representative
mcdonald
he's waving off too
question before the house is the
majority report have been expedient to
legislate on house bill 1219 are you
ready for the question
all those in favor say aye
those opposed nay
eyes have it and the majority committee
reporters accepted
majority of the committee on municipal
county government to which was referred
house bill one two two three enact
relative to meeting attendance
requirements for elected members of
budget committee and school board
considered the same report the same in
the recommendation the bill be referred
for interim study
senator richard lasallus for the
majority of the committee
minority of the committee having
considered the same being unable to
agree with the majority report with the
following resolution result that is
inexpedient to legislate senator
rosemary rung for the minority of the
committee
question before the house is the
majority report of refer for interim
study on house bill one two two three
are ready for the question all those in
favor say aye
those opposed nay
the eyes have it and the committee
report is adopted
majority committee i mean this the house
will be in order
of the committee on municipal and county
government to which was referred house
bill 1268
not limiting the authority for city
council bylaws and ordinances having
considered the same report the same with
the following amendment and
recommendation that bill ought to pass
with amendment senator richard loseles
for the majority of the committee
minority of the committee having
considered the same being unable to
agree with the majority report with the
following resolution resolved that is
inexpedient to legislate senator laurel
stabbis for the minority of the
committee
chair
stavis
do i recognize representatives davis
thank you mr speaker
colleagues we've seen a version of hb
1268 in a previous session
and we rejected it
i hope you'll agree that we should do so
again
this bill seeks to limit the authority
of city councils
to make certain bylaws and ordinances a
responsibility
representative
could you suspend please
my mistake i forgot to do the amendment
first so let me do the amendment and
then
you can start over again
the amendment is 0-6-8-0-h printed in
house record 10-a pages 35-36
question is on the amendment are you
ready for the question all those in
favor say aye
those opposed nay
the ice the eyes having an amendment is
adopted
now you're all set representative sorry
thank you mr speaker
ah so okay we've seen a version of this
bill before and we've rejected it i hope
we'll agree that we should do so again
it seeks to limit the authority of city
councils to make certain bylaws and
ordinances
a responsibility that the citizens who
elected them expect them to carry out
city councils have brought authority
under rsa 47 17. to regulate activities
taking place within their jurisdictions
hb 1268 proposes to delete a key phrase
from section 15 of that law
that allows municipalities to make any
regulations that and i quote
may seem needful for the well-being of
the city
substituting it with and i quote again
to regulate nuisances that interfere
with the use and enjoyment of one's
property
this is classic government overreach
not only does hb 1268
assume that we in the legislature no
more than the local officials our
citizens elect
it ports forth the notion
that enjoyment property is all that
matters
public health measures
regulations to design protect citizens
and help them thrive
those are trivial and in fact they
should be prohibited
this bill as amended
undermines the essence of rsa 4717.
which empowers local elected officials
to protect the people they serve
and not just their property
and it subverts existing law further
by preventing city councils from
carrying out the duties they are sworn
to perform
i have no doubt
that all of us in this chamber are very
wise
but are we better equipped to know at
the local level
what citizens in the 13 cities across
our state want
i really don't think so
and that is why they chose some of us
to serve at the state level
while expecting the counselors they
elected locally to understand their
needs and ensure their safety
i urge you to vote itl yet again on this
newest version of state house overreach
thank you mr speaker
we're down to our last speaker senator
blazik has requested a roll call is that
sufficiently seconded
it is sufficiently seconded
this is going to be a roll call vote
members take your seats
chair recognizes harvey bolio speak for
the committee report
thank you mr speaker
this bill is simple it fixes vague
language about what kinds of health
bylaws
city councils may pass
it inserts a definition about public
health nuisances into the statute to
clear up vagaries
it only pertains to one sentence in the
miscellaneous section about city council
bylaws not the whole chapter
the definition
was developed by the new hampshire
public health nuisance task force to
address this sometimes confusing subject
matter
it leaves intact the broad authority
that city councils have enjoyed to make
local issue bylaws
it covers everything from septic codes
to mosquito control
everything
that is a local issue
but it ensures that broader public
health issues
will it be addressed by the state
please support the committee
recommendation and vote green
thank you mr speaker
the motion before us the majority report
of water passes amended on house bill
one two six eight this is a roll call
vote
members will take their seats
chair recognizes representative magliore
for a parliamentary inquiry
wait a minute mr representative
all set
sorry go ahead
thank you mr speaker
mr speaker if i know that this bill
creates government overreach by limiting
the local control so crucial to each and
every city council and if mr speaker i
know that the current statutory language
which is
make any bylaws or ordinance which may
seem for the well-being of the city
has served our cities well
and that the
limiting
language to be amended would
limit the statute to the enjoyment of
property
and mr speaker if i know that the
current statute ensures that local
elected officials in our cities are
empowered to protect
all the people that they serve and not
just their property then mr speaker
would i vote red
on the current motion so that a
different motion can be made thank you
mr speaker
jerick and i as representative dolan for
parliamentary inquiry
thank you mr speaker
if i know that this bill as amended
clarifies and better defines how city
councils make laws
and if i know that dhhs is best staffed
with expertise
to lead state efforts regarding
communicable diseases
and as i know
a city by city approach
would create a confusing patchwork of
differing laws
than would i not press the green button
to support the opta recommendation
the motion before us is the majority
report of auto passes amended on house
bill one two six eight
this is a roll call vote
if you're in favor you'll press the
green button of your post you press the
red button voting stations are open for
30 seconds
so
[Music]
of all members president had an
opportunity to vote
house will tend to stay to the vote
176 voting yay 156 voting a committee
report is adopted
jury the committee on municipal and
county government to which was referred
house bill 1289 and act relative to
applications for abatements and
authority to abate prior year taxes for
certain homeowners considered the same
report the same the recommendation that
the bill be referred for interim study
senator rosemary rung for the majority
of the committee
minority of the committee having
considered the same being unable to
agree with the majority report with the
following resolution resolved that is
inexpedient to legislate senator joseph
guthrie from the minority of the
committee
the motion before us majority committee
reporter refer for interim study are
ready for the question
all those in favor say aye
those opposed nay
the eyes have it committee report is
adopted
majority of committee on the municipal
and county government to which was
referred house bill 1307 an act
modifying the authority and duties of
the housing appeals board considered the
same report the same the recommendation
that bill ought to pass it's in a
richard trip for the majority of the
committee
minority of the committee having
considered the same being unable to
agree with the majority report with the
following resolution result that is
inexpedient to legislate
representative ivy van from the minority
of the committee chair recognizes
representative
van
come on
thank you mr speaker thank you members
of the house
uh this bill seeks to change the rules
under which the housing appeals board
does its work
and i am
asking you not to support the committee
report
because the housing appeals board has
only been in operation for about two
years
and so far
it looks like it's working okay
what this bill does is say that
some
local
land some local boards
and elected officials shall not be
considered when you're when the housing
appeals board is looking at whether to
approve or not approve an appeal
and while it seems sensible that maybe
only
the planning board and the zba should be
part of that
since select boards have to do with
whether roads are open and closed and
what
classification roads have and road
classification does in fact affect
how
land use can be done
so i would respectfully ask you for that
reason to vote against the ought to pass
so that all of the boards and elected
officials
that and appointed officials that have
to do with decisions
concerning land use may continue
to be part of the housing appeals board
process thank you
chair recognizer barbara griffin
thank you mr speaker
as you've heard this bill relates to the
housing appeals board h.a.b the hab
board it was formed sort of like the
board of tax and land appeals it's a
three-person board appointed supposed to
be people of expertise in the area and
it's to provide an avenue for appeal
from local decisions
this board is a lesson in legislative
experience much like committees getting
a bill and having it be in their
jurisdiction the hab board was actually
created in 2019
in what some people referred to as the
christmas tree bill
hb2
it was a bill that has tried to meander
its way through the legislative process
one body to the other body to a
signature
but didn't quite make it
and sort of like the christmas tree that
has unexpected presence under it it
reappeared in the how in the hb2 was a
bill that ultimately was passed without
following what some argue is the typical
legislative process
as stated this board is relatively new
but i would suggest to you that waiting
for something we create to go bad to fix
it is not a reason to not address it
today
since the housing appeals board was
formed there have actually been 15 at
least at the time the committee
considered it 15 bills that were
considered by this which are appeals
from your local boards and
as also suggested it has included an
appeal from the board of selectmen even
though an appeal from the board of
selectmen was not ever listed
in the jurisdiction of this board when
the bill was adopted
what was listed in the jurisdiction of
bills
of for the board when this was adopted
was a
non-exclusive list
of things that do not include
development of land
so what it is it was authorized by
statute to do was to hear appeals of
fines ordinances and things that were
never
expressed as the purpose of the housing
appeals board
what this bill does
is put the housing appeals board in a
position where its authority is clearly
delineated to those decisions in your
localities that deal with the approval
of development of land that's what it
was intended to do and i ask that you
approve the bill so it is what it can
continue to do thank you
motion before is the majority puerto
vallarta pass
house bill 1307 you're ready for the
question all those in favor say aye
those opposed nay
you guys have it committee report is
adopted
majority committee on municipal and
county government to which was referred
house bill 1342 act relative to
municipal charter provisions for tax
caps having considered the same report
the same the recommendation that the
bill ought to pass senator
patricia keel for the majority of the
committee
majority of the committee having
considered the same being unable to
agree with the majority report with the
following resolution that it is
inexpensive to legislate president
richard tripp from the minority of the
committee
chair recognizes representative
power
speak against the committee report
here we go
okay the chair recognizes representative
wilder
thank you mr chairman
thank you mr speaker excuse me
i rise to oppose the passage of house
bill 1342.
sometimes the people we elect to our
governing boards get impressed
with all the demands of government when
most of the voices they hear
they are listening to are all saying
spend spend spend
so we allowed the taxpayers to vote in
spending caps
a landmark decision on manchester
spending led to the passage of a 2011
law to put in law guidance on spending
caps that had been passed locally
the law stated and i quote
all towner city charters which have been
adopted revised or amended to include a
tax or spending cap of any kind and all
charter commissions which have been
properly established and elected all
elections properly held in all actions
properly taken related to the tax of
spending cap in set charters are hereby
endorsed ratified validated and
legalized and a fully enforceable
without regard to whether such entities
or actions were authorized by law at the
time they were established or taken when
enacted some of the spending caps
included an override clause but not all
of them did
so those are left without that control
thus we see
house bill 1342
it was filed to benefit nashua
because when their spending cap was
passed there was no section to provide
for a supermajority override
in order to
override the nashua budget now it would
take a charter commission
to place the override language therein
a charter commissioned by the legal
procedure
takes about two years
nashua wants their representatives to
pass this law so they can do it in less
time
although many of the municipal and
county government
committee seem to sympathize with that
intent this bill before us has
unintended consequences as it was
written
i see that it eliminates provisions in
an earlier law that would have protected
previous actions it eliminates some of
the language in the paragraph i just
read in quotation marks
it would remove the necessity for an
annual
municipal budget super majority vote in
order to exclude interest and principle
on municipal bonded debt or capital
expenditure to outside the limit of the
capped budget it would remove the
necessity of an annual municipal budget
super majority vote in order for an
ordinance or accounting practice to
redistribute budget items from within
the limits of the cap budget most
importantly
this bill would eliminate the crucial
provisions signed into law just last
year
that grandfather tax and spending caps
enacted before july 5th 2011
that would be eliminated thus
jeopardizing municipal charter tax and
spending caps across the state
unintended consequences
could affect your municipal budget while
narrowly focusing on nashua's problem to
fix one problem we should not jeopardize
the situation of perhaps many other
places this bill has flaws rather than
having to come back next time to fix
them let's just reverse this octopass
and make the bill inexpedient to
legislate
press the red button thank you
chair representatives representative
o'brien speak for the committee report
thank you mr speaker happy st patrick's
day to you and to all my colleagues
what's before us this afternoon is house
bill 13
and it is kind of in an indirect way a
rebuttal to senate bill 52
if the representative if i listen to his
debate
and he says well how things came in well
senate bill 52 instead of taking the
freight elevator it definitely took the
express elevator
okay the right way to have done this
was to have something brought up as on a
referendum within the city budget as
a city ballot but that wasn't done
instead it came in via a back door
with a senator
and thus here we are so whenever
anything comes in the back door
does it really
solve a hundred percent of the problem
the answer is usually not
okay so in this particular case
nashua yes is seek and resolve now i
understand that i don't want you some of
my good friends and colleagues to be
rolling your eyes sort of like an old
episode of the brady bunch where jan
goes up and says masha marsha maja
and here's obi down at the well going
nashua nashua in nashua
but this is a truly legitimate problem
for the citizens of nashua
what's at hand here if there is some
dire emergency
nashville may need a mechanism
to override
the cap on the particular issue
so i arise today to urge you
and i would also like to say in our
existing charter
there is all it is already codified
that we do have a super majority it's in
the chatter
so i rise today to urge you to support
1342 with a positive recommendation of
what to pass
this bill would allow the citizens of
nashua the same fiscal rights
enjoyed by many of your same communities
if you have in your community a spending
cap you probably do have some overripe
vision in it all nashville wants to do
in this particular bill is to be treated
fairly
you remember
i previously came last year and came
before you on senate bill 52 which was
discussed by this body at that time i
spoke 52 was flawed and created problems
again as i reiterated earlier
having this without an override is one
of the problems this does not harm
senate bill 52
as a matter of fact it enhances it
by enhancing it
it will basically allow the override
position now how did we get here from
nashua
this was tried and true the supreme
court ruled down the spending cap till
we can have the override position put
into it
why is this override provision needed
well many of you will there wear two
hats like i do i'm uh alderman in the
city now sure and maybe some of you
besides being the same rep are in the
same boat
you know that sometimes murphy is
speaking the same patty say murphy's law
what can go wrong will
maybe a wall might fall on your fire
truck or something might happen and at
times you may need a remedy to go above
the cap
so by allowing nashua to have this
will allow them to address those
particular issues
in essence senate house bill 1342 does
not in any form like they say try to
harm senate bill 52.
so therefore
there is further president on this and i
want to bring up that rsa49c
semicolon 33
the letter i parentheses d
and i don't want to bore you
but i'll limit all the annual spending
increases that increases the amount
raised by taxes under the city budget
adopted pursuant to rsa 49 dash 49-c 23
such a cap shall provide for an override
threshold on a vote to exceed the normal
annual increase which shall be a
supermajority as determined by the
charter a tax cap in the provision of a
city charter may provide for
specific conclusions do i don't think
you want me to go on with the whole
thing
but i think you can believe me on
exactly what i say it's right in the
near the rsa
so i'm asking you
to be a little bit friendly nashua has a
little bit of an issue i know it's the
only
we're the only city or town that has
this particular issue
so i'm asking for your grace
that you will come up and support the
citizens of nashua and
by
passing house bill 1342
and to allow the right that evidently
was wrong to allow the city of nashville
which was a stand-alone municipality
with no override provision
and to become part of it just like
manchester which is similar in size to
us
and they have the override as well
so i'm asking for fair treatment thank
you mr speaker
the motion before us majority committed
a report about to pass on house bill
are you ready for the question
a division has been requested members
will take their seats this will be a
division vote
roll call has been requested is that
sufficiently seconded
it is sufficiently seconded this will be
a roll call vote
so
members will be in their seats
the motion before us
is the majority report of ought to pass
on house bill 1342
this is a roll call vote
chair recognizes representative power
for parliamentary inquiry
thank you mr speaker
mr speaker if i know today is saint
patrick's day and shamrocks are green
would i then oppose the committee
recommendation
of ought to pass by pressing the red
button
so that another motion can be made
thank you mr speaker
chair recognizes representative van for
a parliamentary agree
house will be in order
thank you mr speaker thank you members
of the house
if i know that this bill corrects
an oversight and puts
our second largest city on the same
footing as other places
would i now press the green button and
support
the committee recommendation of ought to
pass
the motion before us is majority
committee report of ought to pass on
house bill 1342 this is a roll call vote
if you're in favor you'll press the
green button if you oppose you press the
red button voting stations are open for
30 seconds
um
[Music]
while members president had an
opportunity to vote
also attend the state of the vote
157 voting
yay 181 voting a
majority committee report fails
representative weiler moves
in expedient to legislate
are you ready for the question
all those in favor say aye
those opposed nay
the eyes have it and the committee
minority report is adopted
majority of the committee on municipal
and county government to which was
referred house bill 1393 and act
relative to the adoption of school
district budget caps considered the same
report the same in the recommendation
that the bill ought to pass so diane
power for the majority of the
committee minority of the committee
haven't considered the same being unable
to agree with the majority
report with the following resolution
result that is inexpedient to legislate
representative jim magliori for the
minority of the
committee the motion before us is the
majority report of ought to pass are you
ready for the question
all those in favor
what reason does it memorize
to make a motion
state your motion i moved to table house
bill 1393
that is a
proper motion
the motion before us is to table
house
bill 1393.
a division has been requested members
will take their seats this will be a
division vote
roll call has been requested is that
sufficiently seconded it is sufficiently
seconded this will be a roll call vote
[Music]
the house will come to order
the motion before us is to table
on house bill
1393.
chair recognizes
mag maggie worry
for a parliamentary inquiry
thank you mr speaker mr speaker if i
know that this bill as it's drafted will
create a mandate
throughout the state that it's going to
be confusing for every municipality then
would i now press the green button to
place this bill on the table thank you
mr speaker
chair recognizes representative osborne
for parliamentary inquiry
thank you mr speaker if i am uh very
concerned tonight about out of control
spending and ever escalating property
taxes and i know that this bill will
help us do something about that would i
press the red button now
the motion before us is the tabling
motion on house bill 1393
this is a roll call vote if you're in
favor you'll press the green button if
you're opposed you'll press the red
button voting stations are open for 30
seconds
so
what's up mr speaker
while members president had an
opportunity to vote
house will attend the state of the vote
164 voting a 178 voting a the tabling
motion fails
we're back to the question of ought to
pass
the majority committee report of house
bill 1393
are you ready for the question
all those in favor say aye
those opposed nay
you guys have it the committee report is
adopted
recognizes the clerk thank you mr
speaker several members uh we're just
asking at the bottom of page 80 of the
calendar um it appears house bill 1387
as i sent an email to all members last
week uh that was innova inadvertently
printed in the calendar was acted on
last week so please pardon our our
mistake thank you
i also come in order
the majority of the committee on
municipal and county governments which
was referred house bill 1667 an act
relative to the standard and optional
veterans tax credits
and the
all veterans tax credit having
considered the same report the same with
the recommendation that the bill ought
to pass representative diane power for
the majority of the committee
the minority of the committee having
considered the same and being unable to
agree with the majority report with the
following resolution resolved that it is
inexpedient to legislate representative
patricia cleave for the minority of the
committee the member from nashua
representative clee is recognized to
speak against the committee report
thank you mr speaker
colleagues i have to admit as a person
who's worked with the military veterans
since i was 18 years old who's worked
with department of defense department of
veterans affairs
for me to speak against anything that
would limit any person from a military
background veteran or active duty
getting any extra benefit puts a dagger
into my heart
but the truth is we have to look at the
big picture
and we have to be honest that in the end
this is a tax shifting bill
it shifts the tax burden from one group
of individuals to another group of
individuals
the broadened definition will only add
more to the pool who qualify for the
veterans credits and exemptions
i agree we should do everything that we
can
to take to thank those
that have and are serving our country in
keeping us safe but doing so at the
expense of others doesn't make us the
good guys
while serving on state federal relations
and veterans affairs there were a number
of bills brought to create equity
between title 38 veterans benefits u.s
code 101 definitions
often referred to as usc 101
meaning the definitions
of veterans and what is a veteran as
well as what is active duty as per usc
101 a veteran by definition is a person
who served
in the active military naval or air
service and who was discharged or
released there from
under conditions other than dishonorable
the key word here is served not serving
as i already stated but bears repeating
if we were to change the definition
for the purpose of credits and
exemptions we are adding to the pool of
those who qualify for these credits and
exemptions
in 2020 based on the department of
revenue
the dra
reports the the state of new hampshire
through the municipalities granted 31
million
seven hundred and seventy five thousand
six hundred and thirty seven
dollars in tax relief
to fifty four thousand 654
veterans and or families
in a nutshell
those who do not qualify for these
exemptions and credits share in what is
often referred to as lost taxes
meaning their taxes go up to cover these
lost taxes
it should be noted that the veterans tax
credit exemption program is enabling
and will remain that way even if this
passes but
and this is a big but
when each municipality designed their
program they based it on what they felt
their residents could or would bear
summoners chose not to grant any
veterans credits exemptions and others
have given
high amounts and others not quite so
much
i stated that in 2020 in the state of
new hampshire municipalities granted
almost 32 million in tax relief just to
veterans and their families
these are small communities i'm sorry
there are small communities who don't
grant any
and some that grant as little as an
overall amount of only fifty dollars and
then there are those larger communities
cited in the minority report they
granted credits exemptions in excess of
1.5 million dollars
communities such as those in the area of
peace and those communities that border
the
state to our south will have the largest
impact
based on 2020 figures of active duty and
reservists here in new hampshire there's
potential increase of the pool by an
additional 10 percent who will qualify
again shifting the burden to other
property owners who do not qualify
in the end
isn't a new tax shift of any form an
increase in taxes
and isn't the state of new hampshire all
about little to no taxes
i'm not going to throw around the cliche
that is often spoken in this chamber
relative to taxes but i know that i
can't ask those already struggling in my
city to pick up an additional burden can
you
the only way to eliminate that burden
would be to either one
lessen the amount granted for a credit
or two completely the eliminate the
credit exemption in that community
personally i don't see the latter
happening but i do believe it's
conceivable for larger communities to
reduce what they currently grant
if that happens once again we are
increasing the tax burden of those
veterans
who are getting the credit slash
exemptions
this is a very hard catch 22 in that
passing this legislation will hurt one
group or another or multiple groups
this is not a political fight
rather it's a fight to not burden those
already held down by taxes just to say
look how
we helped one very important population
i have to ask
can we do so on the backs of the
remaining property owners
again i'm going to repeat something to
help make it clear so that we all
understand the situation you'll hear
from others that veterans tax credit is
enabling and yes it is
however
if you implement it or have done so you
must do so in its entirety
you can't say this group or that group
you have to do it all exactly as the
legislation says
you can set the amount that you give as
long as you stay within the minimum and
maximum set by this very body
this means that some municipalities have
veterans tax credits exemptions while
others have a credit as low as the
minimum of fifty dollars and others as
high as the maximum of seven hundred and
fifty dollars
some may say this doesn't cost the state
or the municipality a single dime
they're one hundred percent right it
doesn't take a toll on either budget
however
it does hit the wallets of those
who this does not apply to
as my mom taught me
stealing from peter to pay paul and
patting ourselves on the back because we
helped veterans doesn't make us better
people
let's continue to use the definition
provided by title 38 usc 101 relative to
veterans as those who have served and
not broadened the definition here
those that argue in favor of this bill
may say this is just a housekeeping bill
to bring one state statute into the
other in line with another
while there may be another new hampshire
statute that defines a veteran to
include active duty etc perhaps we need
to examine why
and if necessary bring that statute into
alignment
and the veterans benefit title 38 usc
101's definition of a veteran as a
person who served
and not serving remember unintended
consequences a broader definition for a
veteran that puts us in conflict with
the federal definition of a veteran only
puts a burden on those pools of property
owners who don't qualify
this body does everything that we can to
keep taxes low and we do that do what we
can to maintain equity throughout our
state
this is a simple tax shift to those who
don't qualify
i hope that you will join me in over
overturning the odd pass of this tax
shifting bill so that another motion can
be made and thank you so much for
listening to my very first for
speech the member from brookline
representative power is recognized to
speak in favor of the committee report
thank you mr speaker
mr speaker i rise in support of the
committee recommendation of ought to
pass on house bill 1667.
in 1871 after the civil civil war the
first veterans tax credit was signed
into law in new hampshire
over the past 150 years a number of
statutory changes have been made to
include the latest armed conflicts
the definition of a veteran
and to include certain certain national
guardsmen and reservists
new hampshire law clearly defines a
veteran as any person who has served in
the armed forces for more than four
years and
continues to serve or
who has been honorably discharged or has
received an uncharacterized discharge
based on a service-connected injury
illness or disability
due to the discrepancy between this
definition of a veteran and the veterans
tax credit statutes
some military veterans are wrongly
excluded from receiving any of the
veterans tax credits
and ironically the all veterans tax
credit does not include all veterans
recognized under new hampshire law
house bill 1667
addresses these inconsistencies
first this bill amends the language in
the veterans tax credit
statutes to include those veterans still
serving consistent with the statutory
definition of a veteran
and second
this bill removes the title 10 prefix
from the veterans tax credits language
so that title 10
title 32 and title 14 active service
all qualify for the 90-day requirement
lastly
it is important to note
that less than half a percent
of americans currently serve in our
armed forces
therefore
the claim that these changes will create
an undue tax burden is over exaggerated
and furthermore
the dollar amount that my colleague
quoted
prior previously
pertains
a large percentage to disabled veterans
in conclusion
this bill clarifies that all veterans of
the united states armed forces who
served in any active duty status
regardless of the title
or the branch of military that they
served in as well as those who continue
to serve
qualify for the veterans tax credits
for these reasons i urge my fellow
colleagues to support the committee
recommendation of ought to pass by
voting yay on house bill 1667
by pushing the green button
thank you mr speaker
the house will be in order
representative baldur requests a roll
call is that sufficiently seconded
it is sufficiently seconded this will be
a roll call vote members please take
your seats
hmm
which one another one
i also come to order members please take
your seats
and while i have you all here quick
reminder
when someone's speaking at the well
please use any other aisle
if you need that aisle to get to your
seat
they should be done in a minute or two
maybe wait but if you have to come down
here for anything for example someone's
at that well use one of the other aisles
please
representative stavis is recognized for
parliamentary inquiry
thank you mr speaker
mr speaker if i know that the expanded
definition of a veteran proposed in this
bill
conflicts with the definition of
veterans under federal law
and if i know that new hampshire towns
and cities already provide generous
support to veterans their spouses and
children
granting more than 32 million dollars in
2020 alone
and if i know
that this bill will shift tax burdens
from one group to another
something we really don't want to do
resulting in significant property tax
increases for those who do not qualify
would i now press the red button to
defeat the majorities ought to pass
recommendation so that another motion
can be made thank you mr speaker
representative edwards is recognized for
parliamentary inquiry
uh thank you mr speaker um
if if i know from my 33 years of serving
in all components of the army
that
my 10 years of active duty
was spent on hardship tours
in monterey california san antonio texas
the university of southern california
and seoul korea
but
that my two tours
of being called recalled to active duty
as a guardsman or a res or a reservist i
was in both components
i deployed to afghanistan
and got shot at four times i never got
shot at on active duty
and so as we look dispassionately
if i know
that as we look dispassionately at these
definitions
the way the current
tax code is written
discriminates against the guardsmen and
the reservists
who
after 20 years of a land war
in the middle east
have probably seen as much combat duty
as most active duty people
so if i knew
that this wasn't about money because if
it's about money we can reduce the money
later
if this is if i knew that this was about
equity
wouldn't i
treat our guardsmen and our reservists
who have
sacrificed by deploying away from their
families
only to be subjected to the same death
and injury that an active duty soldier
would
and if i knew all of that wouldn't i
vote green on this thank you
the house will be in order
the question is on the majority
committee report of ought to pass on
house bill
1667 this is a roll call vote if you're
in favor you'll press the green button
if you're opposed you press the red
button voting stations are open for 30
seconds
representative
representative welch
of all members president an opportunity
to vote
the house will attend to the state of
the vote
205 in the affirmative 127 and the
negative the committee report has
adopted
mr speaker
i'd like to make a motion
okay
i'd like to i'd like to take 1177
off the table
and i'd like to speak to my motion
not a debatable motion sorry
division vote and i'll do a pie
hey tom
now
removed
okay
the motion is to remove house bill 1177
from the table
are you ready for the question
okay there we go i knew there'd be one
of those
who was that
who requested the roll call
and it is sufficiently second this will
be a roll
the call
all right
members should be in their seats
representatives hill
maguire
all right
all right this is a roll call vote the
motion is removed house bill 1177 from
the table representative bullio is
recognized for a parliamentary inquiry
thank you mr speaker
if i know
that affordable housing is important
to the republicans for the republicans
in this room and the democrats and the
entire state if i know that i just spoke
with the public policy director of the
bia
and the bia
prior one of its priorities is
affordable housing
would i now
press
the green button to take this off the
table so that we could debate thank you
representative osborne is recognized for
parliamentary inquiry
thank you mr speaker
so if i do know
that the affordability of housing is
probably the most critical issue that we
face today
but i also know that i already voted
against putting this bill on the table
once i voted to take it off the table
once
would i now
give up on the losing battle and move on
press the red button
the motion is to remove house bill 1177
from the table
this is a roll call vote if you're in
favor you'll press the green button if
you're opposed you'll press the red
button voting stations are open for 30
seconds
members should be in their seats
[Music]
of all members president an opportunity
to vote
thou shall attend the state of the vote
159 on the affirmative 176 and the
negative the motion fails
the committee on public works and
highways which was referred house bill
prohibiting the use of state funds for
new passenger rail projects
representative graham moves ought to
pass
for what reason does a member rise
mr speaker i arise for a motion
okay state your motion my motion is the
table
representative o'brien moves that house
bill 1432 be laid on the table
thank you mr speaker m.a.i mr speaker
requests are rolled out
hang on a second
i told you all about
uh
alrighty representative o'brien moves
that house bill 1432 be laid on the
table
and requests a roll call vote is that
sufficiently seconded
it is sufficiently seconded this will be
a roll call vote members please take
your seats
so
all right members should be in their
seats so we can get this thing going
this is a roll call vote the motion of
delay house bill 1432 on the table
representative o'brien is recognized for
a parliamentary inquiry
i'm sorry representative query is
recognized for parliamentary inquiry
thank you mr speaker
mr speaker if i know that the committee
members who support and expedient to
legislate believe this bill is premature
and if i know that the new hampshire
d.o.t was authorized to conduct a
project development phase for the
proposed capital corridor under the
state's 10-year transportation plan
entirely paid for with federal
transportation funds no state money and
if this bill passes could potentially
leave us on the hook for an unknown sum
and if i know that when completed next
year the project development will give
the legislature a clearer picture of the
total costs and the legislatures
legislators in the next term can debate
those costs on and where the funding
should or should not come from
and if i further know that manchester is
the economic driver of the state and
that this project will come right
through my district of manchester's ward
9 bringing with it the opportunities of
private public partnerships and
boundless new business ventures for
residents of manchester nashua bedford
and countless other surrounding
communities then would i now press the
green button to table this premature
legislation
representative graham is recognized for
parliamentary inquiry thank you mr
speaker mr speaker if i've learned
anything of the two decades up here that
sometimes it's nice to listen to the
opposition before you vote against their
position
and
if i know that the debate on this bill
will be one-on-one and very short
and that you should listen to both sides
since it is without recommendation and
if i truly believe that the ought to
pass position will prevail in this body
when i now press the red button
and keep this off of the table thank you
mr speaker
the question is whether the lay house
bill 1432 on the table this is a roll
call vote if you're in favor you'll the
house will be in order if you're in
favor you'll press the green button if
you're opposed you'll press the red
button voting stations are open for 30
seconds
so
representative mann
of all members president an opportunity
to vote
the house will attend to the state of
the vote
152 in the affirmative 182 in the
negative the motion fails
we're back to the motion of ought to
pass
the member from nashua representative
jack is recognized to speak against the
motion
thank you mr speaker
i rise in opposition to the ought to
pass motion the federal transit
administration has an established
process that we are following
step one is the alternatives analysis
that was completed in 2014
it evaluated seven bus and rail
alternatives including doing nothing to
develop ridership estimates economic
benefit estimates and cost estimates the
best cost benefit was achieved by
extension of the mbta lowell line to
manchester on the existing freight line
step two is the project development
phase that was funded in 2019 by sb 241
an identical language in that year's
budget hb4
this phase does enough engineering to
determine a firm project cost
completes environmental permitting and
produces a financial plan
to suggest how capital and operating
costs could be covered
it is on track to be completed later
this year
the source of funds is federal transit
administration funds already in the
state's possession matched with toll
credits it is important to note this
pool of money can only be spent on
transit and only in the boston urbanized
area the state receives a new allocation
every year and using this funding is not
starving any other project
with these two steps complete a future
legislature could decide to apply for a
competitive construction grant under the
new starts program after what i am sure
would be a full and vigorous debate on
the financial plan
nothing in what we have done so far
obligates the state to proceed to
construction
or to repay any of the federal funds
that have been used
amtrak operates the downeaster from
boston into maine and the vermonter that
crosses into new hampshire to make a
stop in claremont these are not using
state funds at this time but they may
may wish to in the future
knowing all of this we can see that the
bill does nothing to advance the
intention to stop the capital corridor
project since no state funds are being
used
there is strong public support for
commuter rail i looked at a poll over
the weekend that was over 70 percent in
support
not having rail makes it more difficult
for employers to attract workers some of
those workers might be the
cryptocurrency developers that we heard
about on tuesday
passing this bill would send a terrible
message about how willing the
legislature is to listen to its citizens
and businesses
we avoid appropriating funds outside of
the budget cycle and it is equally wrong
to pass a bill that would restrict the
use of funds
outside of the budget cycle i encourage
members to join me in pressing the red
button it is
hang on
it's super noisy in here can somebody
close that door at the back
sorry about that please continue
i encourage members to join me in
pressing the red button to defeat the
ought to pass motion so another motion
may be made
hopefully they're not too comfy out
there this is going to go fast
the member from bedford representative
graham is recognized to speak in favor
of the motion
he's the last speaker i'd be shocked if
this was
they've already asked for division vote
on this so members should start
migrating back
quietly please um thank you mr speaker
i rise in support of the ought to pass
motion on hb 1432
let's talk about this for a little bit
it is not whether or not passenger rail
is going to come to new hampshire
that is a policy decision for another
day
it is not about
private public partnerships with the
political subdivisions of the state that
is their decision to make in the future
is also unfortunately
not about ancillary costs to
municipalities
in any rail corridor and there will be
some if this is ever built
it is not about stopping the ongoing
project development plan for the capital
rail corridor project
that is being done with federal monies
and is well underway with a report date
for that study in early 2023
we have some preliminary reports from it
but nothing that that really indicates
what it's going to cost
this
report
will cover cons what it costs for
construction
operating
maintenance
whatever else is needed
to include if we have to put down
new rail or anything else
and it will also address funding sources
to pay for all of this
which will in probability taking in
total be in the hundreds of millions of
dollars
what it is is a statement that the
state of new hampshire
will not
be used as the piggy bank
for passenger rail service
what this bill does is clearly tell
those making the recommendations on
funding
that the state of new hampshire
will not be providing the funds
it will also clearly
make clear
to the department of transportation
that when they come in within this
project that they're going to have to
have funding sources outside of state
monies
i ask for your support and not to pass
so that we have a position to lay down
in front of this
project development phase and in front
of the commissioner of d.o.t
that
if we are going to do passenger rail
service anywhere in the state
that it will not be done
with new hampshire funds and i ask that
you uh support the uh to pass motion i
was going to say the majority but it was
without recommendation
so please support ought to pass and i
thank you mr speaker
well only one of you can request the
roll call who is it
representative
request a roll call and it's already
well seconded this will be a roll call
vote
members please take your seats
here
all right the house will be in order
members please move to your seats
is
the motion is out to pass on house bill
1432 this is a roll call vote
representative clutier is recognized for
parliamentary inquiry
thank you mr speaker fellow house
members
if i
know according to a 2019
poll conducted by a new hampshire
business publication that 75 percent of
our state's residents support bringing
passenger rail to southern new hampshire
and if i believe this bill is premature
because now the project development
phase of the proposed capital corridor
railing is being done using federal
funds
and in in a phase that will be complete
should be completed in 2023
then the next term those of us who
return next term will have a chance to
debate how we pay for this project which
may or may not include state funds
and finally if i know
that if let's say this bill were to pass
and become law
a future legislature could easily
repeal it next term or later
because
no current legislature can ever bind
future legislatures in this or other
policy matters would i now press the red
button and oppose the ought to pass
recommendation thank you mr speaker
representative mcconkey is recognized
for parliamentary inquiry
thank you mr speaker
mr speaker if i know no passenger rail
service in the world operates without
extensive public subsidies
and
i know nothing in this bill prohibits
any political subdivision of the state
such as manchester or nashua from
entering into public private
partnerships
and further mr speaker
if i know there is an ongoing project
development phase for a rail service
project
funded entirely with federal funds
and this bill is providing clear notice
no state funds will be used would i now
press the green button and pass house
bill 1432
thank you
house will be in order this is a roll
call vote
if you are in favor of ought to pass
you'll press the green button if you're
opposed you'll press the red button
voting stations are open for 30 seconds
[Music]
representative woodcock
have all members president had an
opportunity to vote
the house will attend to the state of
the vote
187 and the affirmative 144 and the
negative the motion passes
ten year plan
the majority of the committee on public
works and highways to which was referred
house bill 2022
an act relative to the 10-year
transportation plan
having considered the same report the
same with the following amendment and
the recommendation that the bill ought
to pass with amendment
representative john graham for the
majority of the committee
the minority of the committee having
considered the same and being unable to
agree with the majority report with the
following amendment and the
recommendation that the bill ought to
pass with amendment representative bill
boyd from the minority of the committee
the majority amendment is zero seven
four five h printed in house record 10 a
on pages 91 to 93. the question is on
the amendment are you ready for the
question all those in favor say aye
all those opposed nay
the eyes have it
and the amendment is adopted the bill's
on second reading and open a further
amendment
representative boyd moves amendment zero
eight five nine h
also printed in house record santa a on
page 93
and is recognized to speak to his motion
thank you mr speaker and through you mr
speaker to my
esteemed colleagues of the general court
i rise in support of my minority
amendment to house bill 2022 the state
10-year plan the state of new hampshire
has 259 cities towns and unincorporated
places within its borders
the state department of transportation
maintains over 17 000 miles of roads
within its borders
house bill 2022 as presented wants to
give back 2.5 miles of state roadway
back to the town of merrimack currently
known as continental boulevard
we don't want it
this road came about in 1993 when the
d.o.t acquired lands through eminent
domain proceedings to build the road
the town of merrimack back then argued
against eminent domain proceedings for
continental boulevard but the d.o.t
prevailed arguing that public necessity
for the use of private property for this
stretch of road was needed by the public
in the region for the greater good
some 30 odd years later continental
boulevard continues to serve
as a primary arterial connection for
route 101a running west to east from
milford to nashua
to the fever turnpike at exits 10-11 and
daniel webster highway us-3
this connection carries more than 17 000
vehicles per day many of which are from
surrounding communities
more than 10 000 of those vehicles can
be found in traffic counts along
industrial drive and continental
boulevard
the traffic volumes on the state section
of continental boulevard exceed those of
any merrimack public road
including the urban compact section of
daniel webster highway that carries a
traffic volume of 14 550 cars daily
the demand for a high level of service
will be constant as this roadway remains
a critical part of the state's
infrastructure as a primary artery
between the major east-west and
north-south route in southern new
hampshire region
now the argument is being made that the
stretch of roadway is no longer
needed as a public necessity to the
state
d.o.t seeks to abdicate its ownership
from a roadway it richly wanted back in
1993.
the town's absorption of this roadway to
our town's budget is an additional 200
000 annually with potential long-term
capital costs exceeding 2.5 million
dollars over the next 20 years and
that's infrastructure not including
staffing equipment and other ancillary
components necessary to maintain the
roadway
furthermore the road
the town also gets the roadway in its
supporting infrastructure
as is
no caveat emptor
just the town being gifted a piece of
infrastructure that the town didn't want
in 1993 and still doesn't want today
as you deliberate this amendment please
consider that this application of
content at the boulevard by the d.o.t to
the town of merrimack could also happen
in your community
if you agree with me then please press
the green button
to ensure that the dot remains committed
and engaged to maintain the roads and
the highways it has been entrusted to
oversee mr speaker through you i thank
my colleagues for listening to me today
i sincerely ask for a division vote and
i do yield for questions thank you
representative nader you may inquire
thank you mr st speaker and thank you
representative for taking the question
would you believe that i agree with you
100 and i'll be voting green and i
really hope everyone else does too
i thank the gentlelady for agreeing with
me
representative blasic you may inquire
thank you mr speaker and thank you
representative for checking my question
um representative how much would this
cost the town of merrimack to repave the
road could you clarify that
i thank the gentlelady for the question
the maintenance cost
potentially for paving the search of
roadway is 200 000. what i can know that
was brought up in testimony in committee
was that the d.o.t in 2017 bonded the
stretcher road for seven hundred
thousand dollars
the member from hinsdale representative
abbott is recognized to speak
against the amendment
[Music]
thank you mr speaker
it's been asserted that this incident
with continental boulevard was an
attempt to downshift
to the merrimack community
the expense of this
area
uh this if it was i would be voting
for it
i'm not voting for it
i think that
first of all
the average cost according to the dot
for this roadway
that they plow and pave is 80 000
a year
initially merrimack
wanted to have continental boulevard it
is not a state highway
it is a municipal road
and
they wanted it because they wanted to
develop it they wanted to bring digital
in they wanted to bring other industries
into merrimack
in exchange for that
on the turnpike system
exit 10 11 and 12
in merrimack
were
created
eventually this became a problem for the
citizens of merrimack
they didn't want to pay the tolls
so it was eliminated
the toll booth at exit 12
and then with the exit 11 there was a
bill
presented to our committee
to have
the
tolls eliminated at exit 11. that did
not happen by vote 18 to 2 it was
defeated
and then
it went
what they did is they went to the
executive council
who sets the tolls
and got them to set the toll at exit 11
at zero
which eliminated
that from the scheme
and now
they've passed a bill to get rid of the
tolls at exit 10.
so in other words they're getting no
toll money
and what you have to understand
that all the total money
from the turnpikes
has to be spent on a turnpike
and at the time
when it first happened
the salt sheds in the storage areas
where the trucks
the state trucks were a long continental
boulevard
that has since gone away
so
what the expenses are now
were the elimination of the tolls at
exit 10
and 11 and 12
is 1.7
million dollars annually again
1.7 million dollars annually
the cost to remove the toll plazas
is 1.5 million dollars
the other point is
that
when the money that is collected from
the tolls
what it has to be used for and again
only on the turnpike
is for winter maintenance first that's
the priority
second is preservation
and the third is any new projects
so what this is mean that all these
projects
are going to be delayed
a lot of them are going to be delayed
because the money the revenue was not
there
i think that it would make more sense
for
and i question the fact
whether it's going to cost merrick mack
the sum that they said i will tell you
that it was
repaved
in 2017 and it's an average of five
years for it to go
and the cost to remove
the total booth
at exit 10
which is in the 10-year plan
is hundred thousand dollars
thank you
the member from merrimack representative
wrong is recognized to speak in support
of the amendment
thank you mr speaker
i come before you in support of this
minority amendment
it removes from the 10-year
transportation plan as we amended it
the transfer of continental boulevard a
state road to the town of merrimack
the reasoning for making this transfer
is that since merrimack no longer has
the three ramp tolls which supported the
everett turnpike we should take on the
more than two hundred thousand dollars
expense of maintaining this road
annually
it is outrageous and illogical as well
as unjust
here is why
first off let me tell you about
continental boulevard it is a connector
planned and built by the state to join
101a with the everett turnpikes exit 10
and 11
both state roads
it is considered part of the turnpike
system
this is not a road for townspeople to
navigate merrimack
there are no homes on continental
boulevard
it is primarily used to get travelers
from one state road to another
it exists for the benefit of state
transportation
to think that a town should take over
responsibility for this road is
ridiculous
second
to justify that this transfer
to justify this transfer because of the
closure of the merrimack ramp tools is
also ridiculous
for decades decades
merrimack residents paid for the cost
for the turnpike every time a merrimack
resident got on or off to go to work or
to go home
while tens of thousands of drivers south
of merrimack paid nothing
tolls are user fees
and all users of the road should pay
not
just some others who get shouldered with
the burden
we have a toll booth
at the northern boundary of the turnpike
in hooksett
but the state failed to put one in at
the southern boundary
even though that road the tunnel and
other infrastructure is already in place
for a toll booth in nashua
so the heaviest eight miles of the
turnpike from the state line through
nashua
have not paid
one penny for that use
nor for the new ramps
and bridge work
nada zilch zero
i would go as far to say that if the
state kept to their plan to have a toll
in nashua the turnpike system would be
flush with money and we wouldn't be
having this discussion today
the last point i want to make is this
plan
is to dump the cost of continental
boulevard on merrimack
comes without any discussion with our
town leaders or dpw department
it takes what should be a
state-supported cost
and turns it into a property tax
increase for the residents of merrimack
so for all the people of my community
who don't even travel to on continental
boulevard will have their property taxes
increased
so the state can make up
its turnpike revenue losses
that is not a user fee that is not a
toll it is an injustice of government
don't allow it to happen
please vote green in support of this
amendment enough is enough thank you
does the member yield for a question no
member does not yield
the member from bedford representative
graham is recognized to speak against
the amendment
thank you
mr speaker mr speaker i rise in
opposition to the minority amendment
let me tell you what it does first i
don't think anybody hit that
it modifies the majority amendment by
taking out one section
it takes out the the very first section
that says transfer of ownership of
continental boulevard it re leaves the
rest of the majority amendment in place
i just want everybody to make sure they
understand that
when they're voting
a little bit of background
you've heard it here i'll recap the
exits in merrimack were constructed by
the turnpike
some at the request of the town
for development especially for digital
corp now fidelity
the town acknowledged that they would be
told
but it led to the development of large
sections of merrimack
and it allowed both business and
industrial development
over the past several terms these sole
plazas have been removed
and bills that i deem must pass let me
give you a couple examples in 2020 a
democratic senator inserted the removal
of one of the toll plazas and one of
those infamous
omnibus bills that the speaker and
senate president agreed would not have a
committee a conference last year 2021 a
republican center added the removal of a
toll plaza in the house bill 2
while it was in the senate
so the last messages of the grand
agreement that opened up merrimack for
development is the turnpike's ownership
of a portion of continental boulevard
it's to find the time to finish the
breakup of this bargain
by transferring the road to the town
you've heard different costs
i'll accept what my good colleague from
merrimack said that it's two hundred
thousand dollars maintenance and 2.5 in
the in the longer term
if that is the cost of the town that is
the cost of the turnpike system
and so everybody who goes through
another toll plaza will be paying that
amount for the next however long we
maintain control of continental
boulevard that's not cost downshifting
per se to me that is cost shifting to
every other person who uses the turnpike
system
you've heard the talks about
what it will cost to finish up the
removal of the toll plazas but the other
thing that has happened within the
turnpike system
is that because
of this
expenditures and others we've had to
delay in this 10-year plan all of the
major turnpike projects by at least two
years
we can continue to do that
that's up to this body to
decide for me it is an equity
issue should those drivers on the
spaulding of the rest of the everett pay
for what is now in my opinion
essentially a town thoroughfare
the majority of the committee does not
think so and ask that you vote down this
amendment
um and i'm sure it's not going to be a
voice vote but by pressing the red
button thank you very much mr speaker
does the member yield for a question no
i do not the member does not yield
division
representative boyd requests a division
vote this will be a division vote
members please take your seats
the house will come to order
the question is whether to adopt
amendment
nine h
this is a division vote
members should be in their seats
representative moon is recognized for
parliamentary inquiry
thank you mr speaker
if i know that we just adopted an
amendment to carefully detail the
10-year transportation plan
and if i know that there is one section
one
in this plan
that downshifts a six
figure
annual road maintenance costs directly
to merrimack
and if i further know
that this one section
of the plan
received no public input from town
officials or town public works from
merrimack
despite it causing a sizable
unanticipated
unexpected
town expense
then
would i remove this one section
by adopting this minority amendment
and now press the green
button
thank you
yep that just happened okay
representative graham is recognized for
parliamentary inquiry
thank you mr speaker mr speaker if i
know that this should have come as no
surprise to the town of merrimack this
one's piece of the majority amendment it
has been in prior
10-year plans
and if i know that if we keep the cost
of continental boulevard accepting the
town of merrimack's cost that everybody
else who uses the turnpike system will
be paying for those 2.5 million
miles of road that are within the town
of merrimack
and if i know that the committee did
have work sessions
and there are
members of the merrimack delegation on
our committee would i now
vote no
by pressing the red button thank you mr
speaker
the question is whether to adopt
amendment zero eight five nine h this is
a division vote if you're in favor
you'll press the green button if you're
opposed you'll press the red button
voting stations are open for 30 seconds
[Music]
representative soti
representative ford
representative snow
have all members president had an
opportunity to vote
the house will attend to the state of
the vote
148 in the affirmative 181 and the
negative the amendment fails
we're back to the original motion of
ought to pass with the majority
amendment
representative graham is good
the question is on the majority
committee report about to pass with
amendment are you ready for the question
what
all right are you ready for the question
all those in favor say aye
all those opposed nay
the eyes have it and the committee
for what reason does it memorize for a
motion mr speaker state your motion
i uh move that hb 1097 be special order
to the next order of business
and i'd be happy to speak to my motion
all right representative osborne proves
that house bill 1097 be special ordered
to the next order of business and is
recognized to speak to his motion
thank you mr speaker so i i have to feel
really badly for our colleagues over in
ways and means
mostly because of my friend from salem
who i have to listen to
every time we meet about it
all their bills are at the end of the
day after everyone's tired and no one
wants to pay attention and so forth
but more importantly i have a chairman
who needs to leave
early and we're not going to get to his
bills before he has to leave so
we really need to hear from him
on this bill so if you could please vote
yes i would appreciate it thank you
the question is whether special order
house bill 1097 to the next order of
business are you ready for the question
all those in favor say aye
all those opposed nay
the eyes have it
and
1097 a special order to the next order
of business
the majority of the committee on ways
and means to which was referred house
bill 1097 an act relative to taxation of
income of new hampshire residents when
we're working remotely for an out of
state employer
having considered the same report the
same with the following amendment and
the recommendation that the bill ought
to pass with amendment representative
walter spillsby for the majority of the
committee
the minority of the committee having
considered the same and being unable to
agree with the majority report with the
recommendation that the bill be referred
for interim study representative mary
hack and phillips for the minority of
the committee
the majority amendment is
one zero three seven h printed in house
record 10 a on page 13.
the question is on the amendment are you
ready for the question all those in
favor say aye
all those opposed nay
okay the eyes have it and the amendment
is adopted
now on the recommendation of octopass
with amendment the member from hanover
representative hopkins phillips is
recognized to speak against the
committee report
thank you mr speaker
mr speaker i rise in opposition to hb
1097 as amended
i agree with my distinguished colleagues
on the ways and means committee
that the matter of remote employment and
multi-state income taxation is worthy of
protecting new hampshire residents in
fact i love the idea behind the bill
it's a marvelous talking point for our
campaigns after all who here among us
does not want to support new hampshire
workers
but
we must be sure that this legislation
actually protects new hampshire workers
and this cautious committee has
uncharacteristically rushed to legislate
in an area where fiscal prudence
patience and study should drive our
policy making mr speaker i oppose this
bill for two primary reasons first i
oppose the bill because it fails to
properly consider the legal complexities
involved in crafting a litigation
strategy
the majority lists several guesses why
the previous litigation of this very
matter was unsuccessful before the
united states supreme court
then selectively focuses the language
here on a limited issue rather
developing rather than developing a
broad litigation approach
after the amended language was offered
the committee did not gather substantive
testimony from constitutional
interpretation or legal experts
policy experts or independent tax
experts
the committee did not study the most
likely reasons for the previous denial
by the u.s supreme court nor did they
identify the most likely pathway forward
for future success
instead the committee heard an assertion
that the attorney general's office
approved of the language offered
and that a promise
that the amended bill encompassed the
strongest legal position for the state
to protect its citizens
no representative from the attorney
general's office was made available to
comment on that proposed language
no additional hearings were held to
verify those assertions to ask questions
or to confirm the soundness of that
legal strategy
no new facts were presented to suggest
that the timing of this legislation is
urgent right now
so
what does the state gain by rushing this
legislation through and the consequences
of being improperly prepared for future
litigation
is a huge greater risk
make no mistake this bill could leave
new hampshire in a worse position to
defend its remote workers in the future
and we should acknowledge that new
hampshire taxpayers will be responsible
for the tens if not thousands or
hundreds of thousands
of dollars to litigate
a sub-optimal position
the minority urges cautions and caution
in proceeding without further
investigation into the legal
complexities here
and second i oppose this bill
for its technical deficiencies and with
a little bit of irish luck you'll just
hear me for one more moment
the majority revised the mandatory
language of the original bill
and replaced it with a permissive
enforcement of the state's sovereign
power
see this is problematic because the
language change may undermine the
state's right to bring a lawsuit there
is if there's no mandate for new
hampshire to defend its student
sovereignty
we never heard from the attorney
general's office as to why the suggested
language change to permissive was so
important so we're left with answered
unanswered questions
you know does this undermine
the position that we're intending to to
build and to bring forth
so second the bill also creates this
problematic double taxation standard in
one paragraph it stands for the
principle that no other state may tax
new hampshire citizens who work remotely
in our state
but then in another paragraph reaffirms
new hampshire's right to tax another
state's citizens located outside of new
hampshire through our business profits
and enterprises taxes
the logical incongruency here of the
double tax
double standard and taxation cannot be
ignored
and we also have to remember the state's
shift to single sales factor taxation
and determining those big business taxes
you've got to wonder is this bill
intention unintentionally harming our
position by setting up our state to lose
significant portion of its revenue
stream
this body has a responsibility
to be prudent
to be patient and to properly study the
issue before us
there are simply too many unanswered
questions too many unknowns and too many
risks to support this legislation as
written for these reasons i urge my
colleagues to vote no on the motion for
ought to pass with amendment on hb 1097
so that another motion may be put forth
thank you mr speaker and happy st
patrick's day everyone
the member from charlestown
representative spillsberry is recognized
to speak in favor of the committee
report
thank you mr speaker
i make my maiden voyage to the well
to urge your support of hb 1097.
which has the
bipartisan support of a 17-6 majority
of the ways and means committee
i think everybody is generally familiar
with the background so i won't labor it
but we know that during the pandemic
massachusetts asserted a taxation power
we didn't expect
claiming that
new hampshire residents
while staying home and working
exclusively in new hampshire
would be subjected to massachusetts
personal income tax and withholding
i venture we all had a visceral reaction
that that was
illegitimate
our governor objected
massachusetts
did not yield
and the result was our attorney general
took a case to the united states supreme
court invoking original jurisdiction
in which the court can take a case to
resolve a conflict between two states
but the supreme court declined to take
the case
there are theories that it's mandatory
but when the supreme court chooses not
to take a case it's under no obligation
to explain why
so once left to wonder why
and new hampshire is left to wonder
exactly how will we repel
such an intrusion
on our sovereign interests if it arises
in the future
the pandemic came unexpectedly
the reactions to the pandemic including
this massachusetts taxation act
were sudden
and unanticipated
there is a possibility whether it's a
pandemic
or shifting
commuter
and work patterns
or high gas prices
helping to persuade employers to allow
their workers to work from home there is
a distinct possibility that this could
arise at any time and unfortunately
a power once invoked
without having been repelled
is all too likely to be revoked to be
invoked again
from any one of our neighbors who all
have income taxes
and a vested interest in collecting as
much as they can
so hb 1097 is originally introduced
essentially asserted that massachusetts
or any other state has no power
to tax in this way
but we don't have actually the ability
to tell another state what their power
is what we can do though
is we can
directly place into law
a clear statement of our taxation policy
and our sovereign interest
and thus arm the attorney general
in the case they have to litigate again
to establish the basis for standing
the likely
thinking of the supreme court was
it's the individual taxpayer who's
aggrieved
and that taxpayer would have to file a
lawsuit
imagine
you're just a guy trying to bring home
his income without massachusetts taking
a portion of it and you're going to have
to litigate to the united states supreme
court
so in short
this amendment
was co-drafted with attorneys from the
dra
who attended four or five sessions of
the ways and means committee
and attorneys from the
attorney general's office
and when the draft was
completed
it was placed directly under the eyes of
attorney general formella
who affirmed that he wants this in law
so what the minority has basically told
you
is that tax laws complex
they think there might be a way to
further perfect
and
develop a silver bullet
but they have yet to tell us what
changes they would make
so my suggestion
is that we
embrace hb 1097
with the blessing of the attorney
general
and if any of us comes up with an even
better idea later
i am sure the ways and means committee
will gladly look at it
thank you
does remember yield for a question
member does not yield
the questions on the majority committee
report of ought to pass with amendment
are you ready for the question
this will be a division vote members
take receipts
gentleman right here
representative you know keller requests
a roll call is that sufficiently
seconded
it is sufficiently seconded now this
will be a roll call vote
so
all right
i also come to order
this is a roll call vote
no really the house will come to order
you ultimately have control over how
long this vote takes
this is a roll call vote representative
ames is recognized for parliamentary
inquiry
thank you mr speaker
if i know that personal income
earned by new hampshire residents
working entirely within new hampshire
should be protected from unfair personal
income taxation
by other states
but
if i believe that the proposal contained
in hb 1097
that is intended to protect new
hampshire workers from such interstate
taxation
fails
to adequately address the complexities
of interstate commerce
and tax law
and related constitutional limitations
and therefore is not ready for prime
time
nor is there any reason for immediate
action
would i now vote against the otp a
motion
and press the red button thank you
representative major is recognized for
parliamentary inquiry
i need my classes
thank you mr speaker
if i know this bill addresses the issue
of personal income of new hampshire
resident that is earned entirely within
the state of new hampshire
and another state
is subjecting it to their income tax and
withholding
and if i know that the committee
believes that this bill addresses a very
important issue
that was offensive to new hampshire
independent sovereignty and that this
issue must be addressed
permanently
lest it
arise again without recourse
and if i know the committee concluded
that the bill needed to be reframed
so in connection with the attorney
general
and the department of revenue
administration
the committee's amendment seeks to
re-aim the bill
towards firmly and inequality
establishing an explicit claim of policy
and sovereign interest
that will put other states on notice
and clearly lay the foundation
for successful litigation if it should
ever become necessary
then would you join me in the bipartisan
vote of the committee and press the
green button thank you
the questions on the majority committee
report about to pass with amendment this
is a roll call vote if you're in favor
you'll press the red button if you're
opposed you'll press the green if you're
opposed you'll press the red button
that's why we ask voting stations are
open for 30 seconds
why did that happen
[Music]
represents 11.
this representative
representative langley
hello members president had an
opportunity to vote
i realize it's anticlimactic at this
point but 251 having voted in the
affirmative 72 and the negative the
committee report is adopted
representatives page and ward declared a
conflict and did not participate in the
vote
for what reason does a member rise
mr speaker i would like to make a motion
please state your motion
i would like to move that
tuesday's debate on house bill
1266 of the criminal justice committee
be placed in the permanent journal ten
six six
twelve six six
twelve
would like the debate from house bill
1266 printed in the permanent journal
without objection
shall be printed
i know i'm a daily dollar shot here but
thank you mr speaker
i would like to make a motion
please state your motion
yet tuesday's debate on house bill 1476
be placed in the permanent journal from
criminal justice
representatives moves that the debate
from house bill 1476 be placed in the
permanent journal without objection
so what
well this place is getting busy for what
reason does a member rise
for a motion mr speaker
state your motion move that house bill
one two two one fn be special order to
the next order of business and i will be
happy to speak to my motion
representative osborne moves at house
bill 1221 be special alerted to the next
order of business and is recognized to
speak to his motion
thank you mr speaker
for the same reasons as before
if you all vote yes then the chairman of
ways and means will owe you a favor and
if there is anyone you want to owe you a
favor as the chairman of ways and means
please vote yes
the question is on the special order of
house bill
one two two one
then the next order of business
are you ready for the question all those
in favor say aye
those opposed nay
you guys have it
majority committee on ways and means to
which was referred house bill 1221 fn
act relative to the rates of the
business profits tax in the business
enterprise tax considered the same
report the same the following amendment
recommendation that the bill ought to
pass with amendment
representative john genetian for the
majority of the committee
minority of the committee have been
considered the same and being unable to
agree with the majority report
with the following resolution resolved
that is inexpedient to legislators and
richard names for the minority of the
committee
okay
the amendment is
0471 h printed in house record 10a page
27.
the question is on the amendment
roll call has been requested is that
sufficiently seconded
it is sufficiently seconded so be a roll
call vote on the amendment
this
norm is going to do the pi for it
so
members take your seats it's a roll call
vote
the motion before us is the adoption of
the amendment 0471
h
this is a roll call vote chair
recognizer representative sylvia for
parliamentary inquiry
thank you mr speaker
mr speaker if i know that house bill
in its original form
provides tax relief for both the
business enterprise tax
and the business profits tax
but that the committee amendment
would only reduce the business profits
tax
and mr speaker
if i also know
that the business profits tax
is mostly paid by larger companies
while smaller businesses
are much more likely to pay just the
business enterprise tax
and mr speaker
if i further know
that the small businesses were much more
likely to be negatively impacted during
the pandemic
and they are at
they are at least as deserving if not
more deserving as larger businesses to
re
receive
tax relief
mr speaker if i know
that the new hampshire new hampshire has
had several other rounds of business
relief
in the past seven years
and despite assertions that these cuts
would undermine our business tax and
revenues
our business taxes for this fiscal year
are currently more than 88 percent
higher than they were
the final year at the highest rates
finally mr speaker
if i know that this fiscal year alone
through just eight months
our business taxes
are already more than 91 million dollars
ahead of plan
and overall revenues are more than 191
million dollars over plan
so we can clearly afford to give relief
for bet and b
pt
then
what i now press the red button
so that we can provide tax relief to all
businesses this this is a parliamentary
inquiry
then would i press the red button
so that we can provide
tax relief to all businesses so that we
can continue to grow the new hampshire
advantage and our economy thank you mr
speaker
chair recognized representative major
for parliamentary inquiry
thank you mr speaker
if i know
that
this bill originally
was to reduce the business profits tax
and the business enterprise tax
and it would reduce income by a total of
36 million dollars
also if i
know that
we have
instituted
through house bill 2 last year and
others
a reduction in the business and the
price tax business profits tax meals and
rooms tax
and they're going to glide down to zero
on the interest and dividend tax
and we also raise the threshold for
filing the business enterprise tax
raise the threshold for filing the
business tax
and if i know that yes our
business taxes are high
there's two major reasons for that if i
know
they're high because
we didn't change the
tax laws for ppp loans
and therefore
the businesses had to pay taxes on those
and that's going to be about 100 million
dollars is going to have to be refunded
and i also know
that there's been a
number of stimuluses over the last
couple of years
[Music]
everybody gets checks for fourteen
hundred dollars we get checks
for
our employment and all kinds of checks
now
that raises our profits and you we're
seeing that now
those are one-time things
if the member will suspend this is a
parliamentary inquiry
okay if i know that that raises our
profits and this is a one-time
event
and that this amendment
reduces
changes the
bill from just a tax
on
business profits tax and business
enterprise tax to just business profits
tax which will be eight million dollars
and if i know
that
over time
due to 100 million dollars of refunds
and not receiving stimulus tax in the
future years
that this bill is
very reasonable
then would you
vote no on the amendment
uh
i'm sorry yes on the amendment
sorry
the motion before us
is the amendment to house bill one two
two one
this is a roll call vote
if you're in favor you'll press the
green button if you're post you'll press
the red button voting stations are open
for 30 seconds
representative wells
representative edwards
representative tripp
if all members president had the
opportunity to vote house will attend
the state of the vote
227 voting yay 99 voting a the amendment
is adopted
we'll now move on
to the majority report of what to pass
as amendment the chair recognized
for what reason is a member rise
mr speaker i have a question and i'm not
sure
how to word it so i think it's a
question to the speaker
state your question
at the beginning of the discussion
something was said
that would indicate
that the chair of ways and means
would be more likely
to
give members a favor
if
we voted with him there is no one in
this body
who is more honorable than the chair of
wasteland if you were recognized for a
question and my question is how do we
correct that problem
once once again representative i'm going
to move on to the bill
the motion before us now is the majority
report of autopass as amended the chair
recognizes representative ames to speak
against the committee report
thank you mr speaker
so i rise to speak against the pending
otpa motion
on hb
the amended version of hb 1221
reduces the business profits tax from a
rate of 6 7.6
of net taxable
business profits to a rate of 7.5
percent
that is all it does
it makes no change in the business
enterprise tax
this this single decimal
bpt tax rate reduction is expected per
department of revenue administration
estimates
to lower the state's total business tax
revenues
by about 2 million dollars in fiscal
year 2023
and then the annual loss is expected to
build up
to about 8.5 million dollars per year
starting in fiscal year 2024
and this hb 2021
revenue loss
will be additional
to a probable 100 million dollars in
revenue losses attributable to prior
year cuts in the bbt
tax
rate the business profits tax is paid
mostly by big business as you have heard
of the 77
businesses that filed business property
tax returns
for fiscal year 2019
just
or about one percent of all filers
paid close to 80 percent
of the 515 million dollars in business
property tax revenue
received that year
eighty of these high-end filers
had taxable profits above one million
dollars per year
these high-end filers
mostly if not exclusively out-of-state
international
corporations
will be the primary beneficiaries of hp
1221's
single point
single decimal point
tax rate reduction
the average tax break for each of the
top 20 would be about thirty six
thousand seven hundred dollars
based on fiscal year 2019
in contrast
about
400 businesses
or 76 percent of all businesses filing
bpt tax returns in 2019
would get no benefit from the new
hb 1221 tax break
since their net profit after all credits
will remain too low to be taxable
in the middle of the 2019 business
profit taxpayer range
about 7 800 taxpayers
those with net business property tax
paid in fiscal year 2019
of between thousand dollars and ten
thousand dollars
will receive on average just a forty
nine dollar tax break from the hp 2021
single decimal point rate reduction
test excuse me
testimony on the bill
included no persuasive evidence
demonstrating that a single decimal
point rate reduction would have any
noticeable impact on business decisions
to move to
or depart from
new hampshire
state revenues have been high this year
most likely because new hampshire has
benefited from a huge temporary infusion
of covid related federal funds
and from soaring worldwide
corporate profits realized by our large
largest business profit taxpayers
but even so the state's revenues have
proved insufficient to meet local school
and essential human service funding
needs
property tax rates
have been forced up this year in many
property poor jurisdictions
where state aid
has failed to keep up with essential
needs
in jaffrey
where i live
state school aid is substantially down
from fiscal year 2021 levels and and
the school tax rate is expected to rise
this year by about three dollars per
thousand
of assessed property valuation
translating to a 300 property tax
increase
for each one thousand one hundred
thousand dollars of business property
valuation
this property tax increase will for most
business property taxpayers in jaffrey
dwarf any tax break received because of
hp 2021
and even with that three dollar per
thousand school tax rate increase
the public school system serving jeffrey
is being forced to reduce its staff by
about seven full-time teachers
testimony on this bill and at the ways
and means economic forum on march 4
provided no evidence-based support for
the bill's proposed rate reduction but
made clear instead
that equitable relief from high property
tax rates
is urgently needed to enhance the
profitability of many struggling new
hampshire businesses
as well as the quality and sufficiency
of local public schools
working housing and infrastructure on
which these businesses depend
since 2014
rapid national and global growth
and more recently enormous federal
stimulus funding for state businesses
and consumers alike
have masked
the state's revenue losses due to tax
cuts given mostly to our largest
businesses over the last six years
as the stimulus
fades
and as new recession threatens our
revenue situation could become dire
the hp 21
single decimal point business property
tax rate cut
is mindless and senseless i hope that
you will agree and join me in voting
against the pending otpa
motions so that another motion can be
brought thank you
a roll call has been requested is that
sufficiently seconded representative
major requests a roll call
it is sufficiently seconded
this will be a roll call vote members
will take your seats where you're on the
last speaker
chair recognizes representative genetian
take your seats quietly
thank you mr speaker
mr speaker as several speakers before me
have now
announced the original hb 1221 proposed
to cut the business enterprise tax and
the business profits tax we all know
that now it's been said more than once
the amendment that we just voted on and
approved is only going to lower the
business profits tax so the
so any revenue hit to the state
is very minimal it's it's estimated to
be eight million dollars but the thing
that we have seen is every time we have
cut taxes
we've seen an increase in tax revenue
so who knows the eight million may
it may actually be zero
um
in terms of tax revenue loss
the um
many taxes were lowered in previous
years
and so one of the that was one of the
reasons as representative major
mentioned that we focus just on the bpt
right now is because we want things to
settle down we want to see how the ppp
uh loans and the coveted relief funds
affect the tax in the end
now some will say and some have already
said
that big business is going to profit
from this i i disagree with that basic
assertion there are a lot of small
businesses that are paying the business
profits tax and not paying the business
enterprise tax
both those uh thresholds were increased
the business profits tax threshold and
the business enterprise tax threshold
have both both been raised and that's
helping small business
and i i beg to differ even a 0.1 percent
decrease helps business
furthermore
when we think about those who are
thinking about coming to new hampshire
and bringing their business to new
hampshire
and those who are in new hampshire that
want to we want them to stay here
every point one matters
now we compare very favorably to the
other states massachusetts is at eight
percent
so they'd compare with our 7.5 vermont
is at 8.5 percent as soon as you net
more than 25 dollars
i'm gonna venture to say there's a lot
of businesses that make more than twenty
five thousand
so
in the end
this tax reduction will be good for new
hampshire businesses
good for this state
please vote yes and push the green
button
it will send the message once again
that the freest
and safest state in new hampshire
is open for business thank you
the motion before us is the majority
report of auto passes amended on house
bill one two two one this is a roll call
vote
chair recognizes representative almi for
a parliamentary inquiry
just a minute representative
thank you mr speaker
if i know
as the chair
as our chair said
earlier
that there have been major changes to
our tax rates
law and structure in recent years not
just in this term
as well as unforeseeable blows
and
one-time federal supports to our economy
and if i know
that
property taxes
which businesses as well as residents
have to pay
rise even faster when the state deficits
cause shortfalls in municipal or school
aid
or both
and if i know that our committee finds
it exceedingly difficult to forecast
whether we will find ourselves next year
maybe even the end of this year
or in
several years to come in deficit or in
surplus
and finally if i believe that it is
foolhardy to make this further totally
symbolic
0.1
cut to our revenues
until things stabilize
shouldn't i push the red button
thank you
chair i recognize representative major
for a parliamentary inquiry
thank you mr speaker
if i know this bill originally proposed
lowering the business profits tax and
the business enterprise tax
resulting in about 36 million dollars in
reduction in revenues
and if i know the bill was amended to
only lower
the business profits tax from 7.6
percent to 7.5 percent
which will lower the business taxes
approximately eight million dollars
and if i know this reduction in the b
business profits tax rate will be good
for both the small and the large
businesses
and therefore resulting in the most
important thing is keeping our economy
growing then would you join with me and
the majority of the committee and push
the green button thank you mr speaker
the motion before us is the majority
committee report of ought to pass as
amended on house bill one two two one
this is a roll call vote
if you're in favor you'll press the
green button if you're opposed you'll
press the red button voting stations are
open for 30 seconds
[Music]
mr
if all members president had an
opportunity to vote
house will attend the state of the vote
177 voting 141 voting a committee report
is adopted for what reason does a member
rise i asked that the remarks of the
previous debate be placed in the
permanent journal
the motion is to place
the remarks of the previous debate in a
permanent journal without objection
without objection so be it
we got three quick ones and then looks
like we're going to break for dinner
if members
member house will be in order if members
will stay in their seats
we got three that are just going to be
pis and division votes
majority of the committee on resources
recreation development to which was
referred house bill 1071
act relative to wake surfing
having considered the same report the
same
with the following resolution resolved
that is inexpedient to legislate
sin of greg huff for the majority of the
committee
minority of the committee having
considered the same being unable to
agree with the majority report with the
recommendation that the
bill ought to pass representative susan
gartling for the minority of the
committee
this is a division vote members take
your seats
1070.
so
house will be in order
the motion before us is the majority
report of inexpedient to legislate on
house bill 1071. this is the division
vote chair recognizes representative
gottling for parliamentary inquiry
thank you mr speaker and thank you
members of the house for your patient
attention
uh if i know that hb 1071 asks boaters
to maintain a 250 clearance from shore
docks and other vessels vessels
only when wake surfing
in order to moderate the effects of
their powerful waves and wakes
on other boats boaters bathers and the
shoreline
and if i know the captain of marine
patrol
stated this 100 foot increase is
unlikely to preclude wake surfing on any
water body in new hampshire
and the department of environmental
services
agreed
250 feet is a distance that will protect
the environment while allowing a very
popular sport to continue
and if i know that lake and river
associations
advocate 300 and to 500 feet clearance
then would i agree
that hb 1071 is a modest proposal that
hits the sweet spot
250 feet
between what the wake surfing community
wants education enforcement and no
change
and what the concerned public wants the
opportunity for everyone to enjoy their
lake experiences
now and into the future and if i know
all this i would push the red button to
overturn the itl and allow another
motion to be made
chair recognized right from the um huff
for parliamentary inquiry
thank you mr speaker
if i know that new hampshire boating
laws and coast guard regulations
currently require boaters to be
responsible for their own wake
and violators can face enforcement and
fines
and if i know that new hampshire lakes
and ponds are held in public trust for
all to enjoy
and hb 1071 would hurt access for those
who enjoy wake surfing as the committee
heard from over eleven hundred people
who oppose the bill
and if i know mr speaker that new
hampshire marine patrol and new
hampshire's boating industry
were working together to better educate
voters through the new hampshire wake
responsibly campaign thus making
restrictions
in hb 1071 unfair and unnecessary
would i now push the green button to
uphold the committee recommendation
and vote hb 1071 inexpedient to
legislate thank you mr speaker
the motion before us is the majority
report of inexpedient to legislate on
health bill 107.1 this is a division
vote if you're in favor you'll press the
green button if you're opposed you'll
press the red button voting stations are
open for 30 seconds
[Music]
representative
if all members president had an
opportunity to vote house will tend to
stay to the vote
171 voting 149 voting a committee report
is adopted
majority of the committee on resource
recreation development to which was
referred house bill 1227
act relative to the definition of prime
wetland been considered the same report
the same with the following resolution
resolve that it is inexpedient to
legislate senator andrew minzulo for the
majority of the committee
minority of the committee having
considered the same
being unable to agree with the majority
report with a recommendation that the
bill ought to pass representative chuck
grassy for the minority of the committee
for what reason does the member rise
for a motion state your motion emotion
to table
it is a proper motion
the motion before us is the table house
bill 1227.
and there is no vote no uh waiver
okay
the motion before us is the majority
committed report of any expedient to
legislate no
the motion before us is a tabling motion
on house bill one two two seven are you
ready for the question all those in
favor say aye
those opposed nay
guys have it and the bill house bill
1227 is laid on the table
all right
everyone stay in your seats we have a
division vote ahead of us and all we
have is parliamentary inquiries
majority of the committee on resources
recreation development to which was
referred house bill 1317
an act requiring the director of the
state police in consultation with the
bureau of marine patrol to report
annually to the legislature regarding
new developments in electric and
gasoline-powered recreational watercraft
having considered the same report the
same with a resolution that is
inexpedient to legislate it's in a great
cuff for the majority of the committee
minority of the committee
have been considered the same and being
unable to agree with the majority report
with the recommendation that the bill
ought to pass incentive suzanne gottling
for the minority of the committee
the motion before us is
the
majority report have been expedient to
legislative health bill 1317
this is going to be a division vote
members take your seats
the chair recognizes representative
gotling for a parliamentary inquiry
thank you again mr speaker and thank you
again colleagues for your continuing
patient attention
if i know that hb 1317
requires the department of safety aka
marine patrol
to give a yearly written update to the
appropriate house and senate
committees alerting members to
developments in gasoline or electric
power watercraft that may make changes
in voting
regulations or rules advisable
and if i know that recently innovative
vessels such as battery-powered e-foils
and even jet propelled surfboards have
emerged to challenge present regulations
and rules
and that the relentless ingenuity of new
hampshire men and william will continue
to challenge the aqua quo
and if i know that although the captain
of marine patrol was most agreeable to
this update at a hearing
putting the agreement into the rsas is
advisable
since committee members
committee chairs and even captains
change over the years
if i know all these things would i not
then push the red button to overturn the
itl and allow another motion to be made
chair recognizes president huff for a
parliamentary inquiry
thank you mr speaker
if i know that new hampshire state
police along with the new hampshire
marine patrol are exceedingly competent
organizations that diligently work to
keep our highways byways and waterways
safe
for all who use them
and if i know
that as an exceedingly competent
organization
they are well informed and knowledgeable
in all aspects of their duties including
knowledge of any new developments in
watercraft that may be headed to our
waterways
and if i
know that both the new hampshire marine
patrol and the new hampshire state
police are always available and more
than happy to provide the legislature
with any and all information that would
assist us in understanding new
innovation and how they might impact new
hampshire
and already do so voluntarily willingly
make this bill unnecessary
would i now push the green button and
uphold the committee report of any
expedia to legislate thank you mr
speaker the motion before us is the
majority reported been expedient to
legislative and house bill
one
three
one seven this is a division vote if
you're in favor you'll press the green
button if you're opposed to press the
red button voting stations are open for
30 seconds
representative
push it
all members president an opportunity to
vote
house will attend the state of the vote
201 voting yay
110 voting a committee report is adopted
tonight we have pizza for you
it's not irish pizza but it's good pizza
the pizza is made possible again
by the generosity of sponsors of the new
hampshire home builders association and
legislative solutions
the kit the food will be served on the
kitchen side of the cafeteria area like
last night
in the basement level dining room and
members lounge in first full are
available for seating
please be back in your seats no later
than seven o'clock
and again thank the new hampshire home
builders association and legislative
solutions for tonight's dinner
members take your seats
the house will come to order
majority committee on science technology
and nad to which was referred house bill
an act relative to renewable energy
customer generator accounts and credits
having considered the same report the
same with the following resolution
resolved that is inexpedient to
legislate
janine nader from the majority of the
committee
minority of the committee having
considered the same being unable to
agree with the majority report with the
recommendation that the bill ought to
pass senate rebecca mcwilliams minority
of the committee
for what reason does a member rise
mr speaker i make a motion to table
house bill 1116.
the motion before us is the table house
bill 1116.
a division has been requested members
take your seats
so
don't tell me
the motion before us is a tabling motion
on house bill 1116.
the house will come to order
the motion before us is a tabling motion
in house bill 1116
the chair recognizes
representative
vos for parliamentary inquiry
he's first
thank you mr speaker mr speaker
if i know that the additional
administrative costs to implement this
bill
would increase electricity costs at a
time when we don't want to see
electricity costs go any go up any more
than they already have
and in addition mr speaker if i know
that very few people expressed an
interest in this bill during the public
hearing
would i now press the green button to
table house bill 1116.
the chair recognizes representative
christian for a parliamentary inquiry
thank you mr chair
if i know that this bill will help
individuals and small businesses with
multiple electricity meters who generate
their own energy to budget and avoid
taking on unnecessary debt by allowing
them to apply the credit generated on
one meter to the bill on another meter
and if i know that utilities already
administer these credits manually once a
year meaning that this should not
require substantial additional costs or
complexity
and further if i know that allowing a
utility to hold and collect interest
from funds for a period of up to 11
months that have already been earned by
and properly
sorry
and should be paid to granite staters is
an illegal taking of funds that properly
belong to the customer generators would
i now press the red button so that
another motion can be made
the motion before us is the tabling
motion on house bill 1116.
this is a division vote if you're in
favor you'll press the green button if
you're opposed you'll press the red
button voting stations are open for 30
seconds
all members president an opportunity to
vote house will tend to stay to the vote
168 voting and voting yay 127 voting a
house bill 1116 is laid on the table
majority committee on science technology
and energy to which was referred house
bill 1148
the noise is getting very loud again the
house will come to order
and act relative to prohibiting
government entities subordinate to the
state from restricting the types of fuel
sources that may be used for energy
considered the same report the same the
recommendation a bill ought to pass
representative fred plett for the
majority of the committee
minority of the committee having
considered the same being unable to
agree with the majority report with the
following resolution result that is
inexpedient to legislate
senator cat mcgee for the minority of
the committee
for what reason to member rise mr
speaker i'd like to make a motion
state your motion
like the table
it is a proper motion
there is a motion the motion is a table
house bill one one four
eight
are you ready for the question all those
in favor say aye
those opposed nay
cabling tabling motion fails
chair recognizes
representative mcgee
thank you mr speaker
and thank you all for your patience and
indulgence these three days and and
happy saint patty's day
[Music]
hb 1148
uh if you if you heard the description
relative to prohibiting governmental
entities
subordinate to the state blah blah blah
what it really boils down to
is saying that
local towns and cities
are unable to determine whether there
are certain fuel types that will not be
used within their borders
so the minority finds this to be an
extremely disruptive bill to new
hampshire energy planning
hb 1148 not only removes local control
for energy planning from those who are
doing the work on town energy committees
to help lower costs
and emissions
it voids decisions already made
by towns
who have adopted plans to eliminate
fossil fuels from their municipal energy
portfolios because the bill is also
retroactive
this bill is an about face
in direction setting that walks back
support for local clean energy efforts
to implement a mandate that says new
hampshire counties and towns have no
authority to exclude an energy source
can only be seen as paving the way for
continued fossil fuel dependence
this is not the desire of many towns who
have already invested in moving forward
with clean energy targets and i know
because i live in one of those towns in
my town hollis over eight years ago
we did a benchmarking study of all our
municipal buildings and then we began
investing in converting maybe some of
you have had the same experience some of
your town buildings to pellet burners
we put solar panels on top of the
elementary schools and all of these have
resulted in hundreds of thousands a year
of dollars going down in our energy
costs so
we believe the minority believes
we should have the right to do that we
should have the right to lower our costs
and invest in which sources we want and
if we want to set a target saying we
will be fossil fuel free by 2050 which
many towns in new hampshire already have
we should be free to do that this bill
would prohibit that
so um this
this is very much an issue of granite
staters having greater control over
their energy bills which we talk often
is something we want uh creating savings
through local generation hb 1148
disrupts orderly planning for many
municipalities and defies our
long-standing tradition for local
control please oppose the ought to pass
thank you
chair recognized representative platt
thank you mr speaker and i thank the
colleagues who came back
from dinner tonight and i know you did
it just to listen to my scintillating
speech
this bill
first of all has nothing to do with
heating systems it was a senate bill
last year which which uh
stopped municipalities from uh
prohibiting any kind of heating system
this is power production or conversion
and contrary to the minority speaker it
doesn't block a municipality from
investing their own money and solar what
it does do is keep them
from
prohibiting
generation of any sort or throwing
ordinances in the way of them changing
zoning
power production has to follow local
zoning unless accepted by the site
evaluation committee but
but the ordinance that the town or
municipality cannot change zoning to
throw roadblocks in the way of
production
so this is a state responsibility before
the site evaluation committee any kind
of
generation that's proposed
is an automatic opposition from a lot of
people no matter what it is it's not in
my backyard
uh or or it's uh
ideologically driven but it is an
automatic negative reaction some cases
is positive site evaluation committee
the municipality can go there and argue
for pro or con but it should be at the
site evaluation committee
thank you very much mr speaker
the motion before us on house bill 1148
is a majority report about to pass
a division has been requested members
will take their seats this will be a
division vote
while we're waiting for everybody to
take a seat
i would remind members
that
parliamentary inquiries
are supposed to be short
and to the point
not a novel
we actually we have a form up here
to tell everyone how to do a
parliamentary inquiry
they're getting way too long
and way too involved in what a
parliamentary inquiry is supposed to be
and i'm addressing it to both sides of
the aisle not one or the other
the question before us is a majority
report of ought to pass on house bill
1148 this is a division vote the chair
recognizes representative mcgee for a
parliamentary inquiry
thank you mr speaker
if i know
that prohibiting cities and towns from
saying no to any type of fuel means
pulling the rug out from under towns
with climate action plans who are doing
great work to lower the costs of their
taxpayers and if i know
that this kind of reversal of
long-standing state policy creates
economic uncertainty and hurts the clean
energy sector just as defunding new
hampshire saves hurt the weatherization
sector these are new hampshire jobs and
finally if i know that this type of
mandate runs counter to long-standing
efforts to
make new hampshire's energy economy
competitive in the region and sends poor
pricing signals to new companies looking
to do business in the area
then would i now press the red button to
reject the ought to pass motion so that
another motion can be made thank you
chair recognize representative thomas
for parliamentary inquiry
thank you mr speaker
if i know
that
this is not a home rule state and that
municipalities should not
be restricting types of fuels to use to
their
residents and if i know that it's the
job of the sec to decide matters like
this
would i now press the green button to
pass this bill
the motion before us is the majority
report of ought to pass in house bill
1148 this is a division vote
if you're in favor you'll press the
green button if you're opposed you press
the red button voting stations are open
for 30 seconds
represent macbeth
representative macbeth
representative president
representative
if all members president had an
opportunity to vote also attend the
state of the vote
167 voting 142 voting a to commit a
report is adopted
majority of the committee on science and
technology and energy to which was
referred house bill 1250
an act requiring a public utilities
commission to consider climate change
and making rate-setting decisions
considered the same report the same with
the following resolution resolved that
is inexpedient to legislate president
j.d bernardi from the majority of the
committee
minority of the committee have been
considered the same and being unable to
agree with the majority report with the
recommendation that the bill be referred
for interim study
representative lee oxenham for the
minority of the committee
for what reason is a member rise
to make a motion mr speaker
stage in motion
emotional table
hb 1250
that is a proper motion the motion
before us is the table house bill 1250.
i
division has been requested members will
take their seats
[Music]
are you doing
yes
the motion is to lay house bill 1250 on
the table
this is a division vote
the chair recognizes representative
thomas for a parliamentary inquiry
thank you mr speaker
mr speaker the
bill requires the puc to consider
climate change in its rulings
if i if i know the puc uh
is um
this if i know this bill requires a puc
to consider climate change climate
change in its rulings and if i know the
bill does not tell the puc
how to consider it
if i know that the bill does not tell a
puc why to consider it and if i know
that the bill does not require or tell
the puc what to consider
then would i press the green button to
table this bill
crx is representative oxenham for a
parliamentary inquiry
thank you mr speaker colleagues
if i know
that climate change could cut usgnp by
10 percent over the coming decades and
do billions of dollars of damage to new
hampshire
and if i know that increasingly
prevalent extreme weather events pose
major threats to our clean water
agricultural production and human health
even our lifespans
and if i know that wildfires droughts
and extreme heat events pose looming
financial risks that could cause major
economic losses to residents and
businesses here in new hampshire
then would i not want the puc to take
into account climate-related risks in
its decision-making on utility
investment decisions
please push the red button so that we
can have this debate
the motion before us is the table house
bill 1250
this is a division vote if you're in
favor you'll press the green button if
you're opposed you'll press the red
button voting stations are open for 30
seconds
representative terry
if all members president had an
opportunity to vote house will attend
the state of the vote
168 voting 843 voting a house bill 1250
is laid on the table
committee on science technology and
energy to which was referred house bill
1258 enact relative to the
implementation of the department of
energy
i'm still reading the bill
but we didn't take a vote on the bill
that was the tabling motion
it passed and it passed
having considered the same report the
same with the following amendment and
recommendation that the bill ought to
pass with amendment senator michael
harrigan harry harrington for the
committee
amendment the amendment is zero eight
five one h printed in house record 10a
pages 29-35
are you ready for the question on the
amendment all those in favor say aye
those opposed nay
the eyes have it and the amendment is
adopted
the motion before us now is the ought to
pass with amendment
are you ready for the question all those
in favor say aye
those opposed nay
the eyes have it and the committee
report is adopted
majority of the committee on science
technology and energy to which was
referred house bill 1270 in act
dissolving the legislative oversight
committee to monitor the transformation
of delivery of electric services
considered the same report the same with
the following amendment and the
recommendation that the bill ought to
pass with amendment senator doug thomas
for the majority of the committee
minority of the committee having
considered the same and being unable to
agree with the majority report with the
following resolution resolved that is
inexpedient to legislate senator
jacqueline kelly pitts for the minority
of the committee
the chair recognizes representative cali
pitts mr speaker
for what reason to the member rise for a
motion stage of motion
i moved we table hb 1270.
that is a proper motion the motion
before us is the table
house bill 1270
are you ready for the question all those
in favor say aye
those opposed nay
the nays have it
house will be in order
the amendment is 0880h
printed in house record 10a pages
to 40. are you ready for the co
a division has been
we already did oh we already i thought
we did yeah
i've been informed that we already did
the amendment
so
we're back to the majority report of
ought to pass as amended
and i'm recognizing representative kelly
pitts
no we're not we're in the debate i'm not
going to speak on it
okay that's not what i had in front of
me but if we're just going to do a
division vote and pis that's fine that's
great
this will this will be a division vote
members take your seats
hey
clear
for what reason does a member rise
point of order
state your point of water uh mr
mr speaker as far as i know we never
voted on the amendment when we were
getting ready to vote on the amendment
the tabling motion was made the clerk
the clerk informed me we did vote on the
amendment
the house will be in order
the record shows that we adopted the
amendment that's what i'm going with
so
nelson
house will come to order
the motion before us
is the majority report of ought to pass
as amended
on house bill 1270.
this is a division vote
with pis only
chair recognizes representative callie
pitts for parliamentary inquiry
mr speaker
house
may cooper may culpa i don't know what's
going on
um
[Music]
if i know this is a pi
if i
if i believe that we are currently in an
energy crisis and if i believe that we
you the way we use and obtain energy
is in transition and that transition is
not over
and the work of the oversight committee
is far from over
if i believe that
we need a comprehensive
study of all the reports that we get
and all the information that we get
and that we can't get that in committee
many times
i believe that we should continue with
this oversight committee which does not
hurt anything and if i know that this
committee has not met
i believe that it was due to coven
so
my information was that the
committee had come out with an itl
but i believe that this is an odd to
pass
it harms no one and it helps everyone
thank you
chair recognizes representative vols for
a parliamentary inquiry in case
everybody just doesn't know please press
the red button
thank you mr speaker mr speaker
if i know that i served on the
restructuring oversight committee myself
a couple of terms ago
and if i also know that the
restructuring process has been completed
that committee's purpose has been served
if i further know that a couple of years
ago
[Music]
a new bill was passed to repurpose the
committee but its language was vague
and didn't really do the job of defining
what the new committee's role would be
as a result the committee hasn't met for
two or three years
if i knew all that mr speaker would i
press the green button delayed to
to pass this bill ought to pass as
amended thank you
house will come to water
the clerk's office has reviewed the
video and
it is right
that the
amendment was not adopted
so
we're going to take up the amendment
right now
the house will be in order
the amendment is 0808
printed in house record 10a pages 39
through 40.
the question is on the amendment are you
ready for the question
all those in favor say aye
those opposed nay
the eyes have it and the amendment is
adopted
would
representative kelly pitts
waive off
another pi okay
so this is a division vote members will
be
so we're going to do this once again
this is going to be a division vote
on the majority report of ought to pass
as amended on house bill 1270.
if you're in favor you'll press the
green button if you're opposed you will
press the red button voting stations are
open for 30 seconds
looks like
[Music]
represent belanger
representative
nordgrid mr speaker
while members president had an
opportunity to vote house will attend
the state of the vote
173 voting a 138 voting nay and for the
second time tonight
committed report is adopted
majority of the committee on science
technology and energy to which was
referred house bill 1328 fn
an act authorizing a utility to petition
to be relieved of their carrier of last
resort obligations consider the same
report the same with the recommendation
that the bill ought to pass senator
michael harrington for the majority of
the committee
minority of the committee having
considered the same and being unable to
agree with the majority report with the
recommendation that the bill be referred
for interim study senator lee oxenham
for the minority of the committee
for what reason is a member rise
for a motion mr speaker stage a motion
i move that we lay this bill on the
table
the motion is to lay house bill 1328 on
the table and i asked for a division
vote
members will take your seats
this is a division vote
so
house will be in order
the motion before us is the table house
bill 1328.
this is going to be a division vote
the chair
the chair recognizes representative
oxenham for parliamentary inquiry
thank you mr speaker
colleagues
if i know
that despite new communication
technologies and increased competition
carrier of last resort requirements
still meet a vital need here in new
hampshire
and if i know that this requirement
means that incumbent telecommunications
service providers
must ensure the continuing availability
of life-saving communication services
to all
their customers not just 95 percent or
97 percent of them
and if i recognize that many areas of
our state still do not have either
reliable broadband service or cell phone
service
then would i not put the cart before the
horse by removing this vital safeguard
until we have other
sufficient technologies in place
please push the red button so another
motion can be made
i recognize representative host for
parliamentary inquiry
thank you mr speaker mr speaker if i
know that
the few small regional telephone
companies that still exist in new
hampshire
would experience financial relief from
the passage of this bill to relieve them
of that
carrier of last resort obligation
but if i further know that the public
utilities can commission continues to
collect an obsolete
assessment based on that carrier of last
resort obligation
which rate payers continue to pay
would i vote no on the tabling motion by
pressing the red button so that we can
listen to the debate on this bill and
pass this really good bill thank you mr
speaker
the motion before us is delay 1328 on
the table
this is a division vote if you're in
favor you'll press the green button if
you're opposed you press the red button
voting stations are open for 30 seconds
so
representative
representative edgar
representative tucker
representative woodcock
all members president had an opportunity
to vote also attend to the state of the
vote
142 voting yay 168 voting nay
the motion delay on the table fails
we're now back to the original
motion of the majority report ought to
pass
division has been requested members will
take their seats
is
the motion before us is the majority
report of ought to pass in house bill
we're going right to parliamentary
inquiries this is a division vote
chair recognizes representative oxingham
for a parliamentary inquiry
i know everyone wants to go home thank
you mr speaker so i'll be brief
we have a vital need for carrier of last
resort
excuse me
if i know that we still have a vital
need
for the protections that are offered by
carrier of last resort
would i vote
against the ought to pass by pushing the
red button
thank you
chair recognize the representative
thomas for parliamentary inquiry
thank you mr speaker
if i know it's time to read new
hampshire of an obsolete and costly
public utilities commission
assessment
and 38 other states have done likewise
for the past six years with no problems
and if i know that having rate payers
pay for a service no longer needed is
just wrong would i now press the green
button and pass this bill
the motion before us is the majority
report of ought to pass on house bill
1328. this is a division vote if you're
in favor you press the green button if
you're opposed you press the red button
voting stations are open for 30 seconds
[Music]
all members president an opportunity to
vote house will attend the state of the
vote
173 voting a 138 voting a committee
report is adopted
majority of the committee on science
acknowledge nature which was referred
house bill 1459 fn act relative to
recycling solar panels considered the
same report the same with the following
amendment a recommendation that the bill
ought to pass with amendment senator
fred plett for the majority of the
committee
of the committee having considered the
same being unable to agree with the
majority report with the following
resolution
resolve that is inexpedient to legislate
representative roderick pimentel for the
minority of the committee
for what reason does a member rise
to make a motion mr speaker stage
emotion
i move to
place this bill on the table
the most
the motion is to lay
1459 on the table
and i ask for a division vote
and it asks for a division vote
members take their seats
um
they all shouldn't even be sitting here
uh
so
chair recognize
representative pimentel for
parliamentary inquiry
thank you mr speaker
mr speaker if i know that we need to do
a better job of recycling all products
and if i know that this bill targets
only the solar industry
in new hampshire
in at its infancy
would i press the green button to table
this bill
chair recognizes representative votes
for parliamentary inquiry
thank you mr speaker mr speaker if i
know that we have a tendency to kick the
can down the road and it's time to stop
doing that
solar panels may last for
15 or 20 years but they're eventually
going to fail and have to be recycled
if i know that if we start a stewardship
plan now
the money will be in place when the time
comes to recycle those solar panels
knowing that would i press the
red button
not to table this bill
thank you
the motion before us is the table house
bill 1459
this is a division vote
if you're in favor you'll press the
green button if you're opposed to press
the red button voting stations are open
for 30 seconds
[Music]
representative page
representative maggiore
representative tucker
if all members president had an
opportunity to vote also attend this
state of the vote
141 voting 867 voting a the motion to
table fails
the question before us now is amendment
zero nine four o h printed in house
record 10 a pages 62 to 64.
are you ready for the question on the
amendment
all those in favor say aye
as opposed nay
the eyes have it and the amendment is
adopted
the question before us right now
is on the majority report of ought to
pass as amended
a division has been requested
members take your seats
[Music]
there is no debate just parliamentary
inquiries
the chair recognizes
representative partial for a
parliamentary inquiry
thank you mr speaker
mr speaker
if i know this restrictive bill that's
trying to kick a can that may possibly
exist 25 years down the road
and i recently and the recently passed
house bill 1149 provides a far superior
and less biased means of examining
extended producer responsibility
and further
i know that the unexamined economic
consequences
of this
anti-business and anti-environmental
legislation will impede new hampshire
energy independence at a time
when grid stability
should be our top priority
would i not now
press the red button
so that another motion may be brought
forward that removes the legislative
thumb
from the new hampshire homegrown
renewable energy and mr speaker i
request a division vote
thank you
the chair recognizes representative
plett for parliamentary inquiry thank
you mr speaker
if i know
that
this is a growing problem the solar
panels in in new hampshire that's 153
megawatts installed already and by 2025
there'll be 389 megawatts and if i know
every time i mention megawatts people
fall asleep
but so i'll turn it into other terms
380 my
megawatts rent rounding up to 400 that's
2 000 2 million panels and if i know
that that's 400 acres of panels
and if i know that other production
going to site evaluation committee has a
re has a plan at end of life but most
solar does not go to the recycle
site evaluation committee and if i know
that small electronics can handle by a
dpw for nominal fees but for the solar
panels it can run to thousands of
dollars then when i pass this important
bill i i also know that califor that
it's modeled after washington bill uh
law rather than work representatives
parliamentary inquiry yes if i know that
that has been done in in
in washington and several other states
are considering it
then which would i press green to pass
this bill
the motion before us is the majority
report of auto pass as amended on house
bill 1459 this is a division vote
for your house will be in order
if you're in favor you'll press the
green button if you're opposed you'll
press the red button voting stations are
open for 30 seconds
yes or no
representative allegra
representatives davis
murphy
while america's president had an
opportunity to vote the house will
attend to the state of the vote
167 voting a 145 voting a committee
report is adopted
majority of the committee on science
technology in any juju which was
referred house bill 1596 fn act relative
to net energy metering limits for
individual and business customers
considered the same report the same with
the following resolution resolved that
is inexpedient to legislate president
j.d bernardi for the majority of the
committee
minority of the committee having
considered the same being unable to
agree with the majority report the
recommendation that the bill ought to
pass presenter rebecca mcwilliams for
the minority of the committee
chair recognizes representative parasol
for
you're waving off
wait what reason does a memorize
mr speaker
mr speaker i make a motion to lay this
bill upon the table
the motion before us is the late house
bill 1596 on the table a division has
been required
this will be a division vote
members take your seats
motion before us
is to lay house bill 1596 on the table
this will be a division vote
the chair recognizes representative
parasol for a parliamentary inquiry
thank you mr speaker
speaker
if i know that our current
fall policy to cap net energy metering
at one megawatt for new hampshire
individuals and businesses not only has
the effect
of depressing the competitive energy
market but also unfairly penalizes a
nascent green power jobs market in new
hampshire and further
if i know my constituents are acutely
aware of our desperate need for the
removal of arbitrary caps that impede
new hampshire's energy independence and
like them
i'm reminded this the fact every with
every electric bill i open and every gas
pump i visit
would i not now push the red button so
that another motion may be brought
forward that once again would remove our
legislative thumb from new hampshire's
homegrown renewable energy
thank you when i believe the division
was called
thank you jerick and isis
representative votes for a parliamentary
inquiry
thank you mr speaker mr speaker if i
know that house bill 1596
is substantively the same bill
that our governor vetoed three times
over the course of the last two years
but i now press the green button
the motion before us is to lay
house bill 1596 on the table this is a
division vote if you're opposed you'll
press if you're in favor you'll press
the green button if you're opposed
you'll press the red button voting
stations are open for 30 seconds
so
representative
while members president had an
opportunity to vote also attend the
state of the vote
167 voting a 140 voting a committee of
the late house bill for
1596 is laid on the table
the committee on science technology and
entity to which was referred help the
house will be in order
to which was referred 1599 fn and act
relative to customer generators who sell
renewable energy certificates having
considered the same report the same with
the recommendations the bill ought to
pass senator fred platt for the
committee
the division has been recalled has been
called members take your seats
the motion before us is the committee
report of ought to pass
on house bill 1599 this is going to be a
division vote
chair recognizes representative pimentel
for a parliamentary inquiry
thank you mr speaker
mr speaker
if i know that hb 1599 only looks at one
side of the ledger and if i know that
the puc will be completing a four-year
study that addresses both sides of the
ledger
then would i let the puc do their job
before the legislature arbitrarily
changes the formula and press the green
button
thank you mr speaker
chair recognizes representative votes
for parliamentary inquiry
thank you mr speaker mr speaker if i
know that this bill
fixes a mistake that was made back in
2017 by the puppy public utilities
commission
when they determined what the tariff
would be
for
default service with regard to net
metering this created something called
the
missing money problem
the missing money problem essentially
allows
customer generators people who generate
electricity and put it back onto the
grid to avoid paying
the rps charges that they are
responsible for
and that requires
representatives i know that that
requires the public the
utilities to recover those costs
from ratepayers
and if i further know house will be in
order we heard
and i believe i corrected my mistake
and if i further know
that this bill fixes the missing money
problem and prevents cost shifting to
other rate payers would i now press the
green button
the motion before us is ought to pass on
house bill 1599.
this is a division vote if you're in
favor you'll press the green button if
you oppose you press the red button
voting stations are open for 30 seconds
if all members president had an
opportunity to vote the house will
attend the state of the vote
163 voting a 137 voting nay
the committee report is adopted
no debate mr speaker
committee on science technology and
energy to which was referred house bills
act relative to rules of the site
evaluation committee having considered
the same report the same with the
following resolution result that is in
expedient to legislate representative
michael herrington
for the committee
the motion before us is the
committee reporter been inexpediting to
legislate are you ready for the question
all those in favor say aye
those opposed nay
the eyes have it and the committee
report is adopted
committee on science technology and
energy to which was referred house bill
1628 fn enact directing the department
of energy to generate a report on the
microgrid project currently in progress
the university of new hampshire in
collaboration with the regional
utilities considered the same report the
same with the following resolution
resolved that is inexpedient to
legislate
representative tom project for the
committee
for what reason does the member rise
mr speaker
i make a motion that we lay this bill
upon the table
that is a proper motion
division has been requested members take
your seats
so
house will come to water
the motion is to lay house bill 1628 on
the table
chair recognizes of representative votes
for parliamentary inquiry
thank you mr speaker mr speaker if i
know that the department of energy
testified before our committee that the
micro grid project involving eversource
in the university of new hampshire had
been terminated
would i now press the green button to
lay this bill upon the table
chair recognize the representative
samsic for parliamentary inquiry
thank you mr speaker honorable members
if i know that this project with the unh
and the utilities is in fact on hold
right now because of several problems
but i also know that microgrids have a
great potential in the future for
community power and for rural
communities to unite to create energy
networks and i'd like to see more
information and furthermore i know also
now that there are several businesses in
this state that are doing that so i am i
was requesting the department energy to
put together a report of what we know
right now about microwaves so we can go
ahead and and and so i ask you to
vote against the tabling motion
the motion before us is lighthouse bill
1628 on the table
this is a division vote if you're in
favor you'll press the green button if
you oppose you press the red button
voting stations are open for 30 seconds
representative toole
you can't try now
representatives
all members president had an opportunity
to vote household in the state of the
vote
208 voting yay 99 voting nay house bill
1628 laid on the table
majority of the committee on science
acknowledge energy to which was referred
house bill 1629 fn
act relative to default service for net
metering having considered the same
report the same with the recommendation
that the bill ought to pass senator
michael harrington for the majority of
the committee
minority of the committee having
considered the same being unable to
agree with the majority report with the
following resolution resolved that is
inexpedient to legislate senator kat
mcgee for the minority of the committee
the motion before us is the majority
report of how to pass
the vision has been requested members
take your
pi seats
the motion before us is the ought to
pass motion on house bill 1629
this is a division vote
chair recognizes representative mcgee
for a parliamentary inquiry thank you mr
speaker colleagues
if i know that this bill seeks to adjust
net metering rates by removing all
current charges ex that make up the rate
except for the energy itself
basically this bill says the wholesale
rate of energy is what we should use for
net metering credit
but if i further know that this is not a
legitimate method of evaluating the
value of net metered energy
and that a long pending public utilities
commission study on this very topic is
due out any day to let us know what that
rate should be
and finally if i know that it is
fiscally irresponsible to knowingly
create an adverse effect on existing
renewable energy facilities and slow
planned adoption of new projects by
throwing this kind of wrench into the
mix when there is no evidence that this
arbitrary calculation is the right price
point for a complex market
then would i now press
the green the red button to stop this
bad bill becoming law thank you
geo recognized representative harrington
for parliamentary inquiry thank you mr
speaker mr speaker if i know that the
rate being paid to net metering involves
lots of costs that they don't see such
as risk premiums and on the go i could
list a whole mess of them there's a lot
of them it raises your electric rates
but you know what nothing more i say is
going to change a single vote so just
please press the green button
the motion before us is the
majority report about a pass on house
bill 1629
this is a division vote if you're in
favor you'll press the green button if
you're opposed you press the red button
voting stations are open for 30 seconds
so
[Music]
represent clutter
represent camarlo
all members president had an opportunity
to vote house will attend the state of
the vote
163 voting yeah 140 voting a committee
report is adopted
committee on science technology and
energy to which was referred house bill
1635 fn
act relative to the purchase of output
of limited electrical energy producers
including qualifying storage system
having considered the same report the
same with the recommendation that the
bill be referred for interim study
senator nick white for the committee
the motion before us is
the motion of re referred for interim
study are you ready for the question all
those in favor say aye
those opposed nay
you guys have it and the committee
report is adopted
majority of the committee on science
technology and energy to which was
referred house bill 1645 fn
an act requiring notification to
renewable energy customer generators of
issues related to renewable energy
credits considered the same report the
same with the following resolution
resolve that is inexpedient to the
legislate representative lex
presents to
brzezinski
minority of the committee have been
considered the same being unable to
agree with the majority report with the
recommendation of bill auto pass
president of lee oxenham for the
minority of the committee
the motion before us is the majority
report of in expedient to legislate on
house bill 1645
this is going to be a division vote
members take your seats this is just
going to be a division vote
with parliamentary inquiries
the motion before us is the majority
report of index being to legislator on
house bill 1645.
this is a division vote the chair
recognizes representative oxenham for
parliamentary inquiry
thank you mr speaker colleagues
with your indulgence i know we're all
tired
one minute and we can be done with the
bills for ste
please
if i know
that there have been bills aimed at
eliminating wreck sweeping for years and
in the last session we passed the bill
the other body passed the bill
but the governor vetoed it
thereby violating the new hampshire
constitution's guarantees of property
rights protection due process and equal
protection under the law
and if i know that via rex sweeping the
state of new hampshire is seizing the
property rights of new hampshire
citizens and businesses
without their knowledge
and without any
compensation and if i know that this
practice has transferred millions of
dollars from new hampshire residents and
businesses to private corporations
with roughly half yes going to the
utilities and
pennies on your rate going down but with
the other half
going to out-of-state private
corporations like constellation energy
and direct energy
thereby placing the state of new
hampshire in legal jeopardy
and lastly if i know that this bill
simply
informs those customer generators who
are being harmed and have been harmed by
this practice
of the fact of the taking and the means
they can take to protect their property
from further seizure
would i now push the red button
thank you
chair recognizes representative thomas
for parliamentary inquiry
thank you mr speaker
mr speaker if i know that the state
created these wrecks
and the state can also take them away
but if i also know that these wrecks
these unclaimed wrecks are used by the
electric utilities to reduce your
electric bill
and if i know that if we stop letting
them use these unclaimed rates it will
be raising your electric bill and if i
believe that's wrong let's press
the
red button on the green button and get
this over with
members need to be in their seats
the motion before us is the majority
report of an expedient to legislate this
is a division vote you're in favor
you'll press the green button if your
poster press the red button voting
stations are open for 30 seconds
so
representative gallagher
if all members president had an
opportunity to vote house will tend to
stay to the vote
165 voting a 139 voting a committee
reports adopted
mr speaker
for what reason does a member rise um i
will call it a parliamentary inquiry
state your inquiry if i think that all
of my colleagues would acknowledge that
the clerk's staff is probably getting as
tired and bleary-eyed as we all are
and i think that they would like to join
me
in saying how much we appreciate them
getting the record correct a few minutes
ago before we proceeded
wouldn't they all join me now in
thanking them for sticking with us at
these late hours
[Applause]
hmm
house will be in order
majority committee on state federal
relations and veterans affairs to which
was referred house bill 1284
an act
establishing a committee to study the
effects of deportation of primary
earners on family members who are united
states citizens consider the same report
the same with the following resolution
resolve that is inexpedient to legislate
senator albel disarro from the majority
of the committee
minority of the committee having
considered the same and being unable to
agree with the majority report with the
following amendment and the
recommendation that bill ought to pass
with amendment
representative amanda elizabeth told for
the minority of the committee
for what reason is a member rise
uh to make a motion mr speaker stage
motion i'd like to make a motion to
table this bill
the motion before us is the table
house bill 1284 it is a proper
motion a division has been requested
members take your seats
roll call has been requested is that
sufficiently seconded
it is not sufficiently seconded
the motion before us is to table house
bill 1284
this is going to be a division vote the
chair recognizes representative bell
desauro for a parliamentary inquiry
thank you mr speaker mr speaker if i've
known i've seen this bill about three
four times
and and if i also believe in many of us
here all of us here have taken the oath
of the constitution knowing that the
federal government
take is deals with immigration so mr
speaker if i believe
that
there's no way that we'd be able to get
the information requested in this bill
due to privacy and we do not have
subpoena then would i press that
green button thank you
geo recognizes representative toll for
parliamentary inquiry
thank you mr speaker
if i know that deportation has
devastating economic and humanitarian
impacts
if i know
that it is clear that we have much
anecdotal evidence about the impacts of
deportation of primary earners but no
statewide data collection
if i know that we have data elements in
very local places like school districts
municipal welfare offices and state and
human services offices but these haven't
been woven together into a state
narrative
if i know we need this study to collect
reputable data on a statewide level to
inform public policy that leads to the
best economic and humanitarian outcomes
for new hampshire residents would i go
ahead and vote no on the motion to table
the motion before us is to table house
bill 1284 this is a division vote if
you're in favor you'll press the green
button of your polls you'll press the
red button
voting stations are open for 30 seconds
so
thank
representative mullen
representative gallagher
representative mann
representative ford representative ford
all members president had an opportunity
to vote also attend the state of the
vote
172 voting yeah 135 voting a the tabling
motion passes for house bill 1284
so
majority of committee on state and
federal relations and veterans affairs
to which is referred to hcr 7.
enact reaffirming support for the nation
of israel and the location of the
embassy of the united states therein
having considered the same report the
same with the recommendation of bill
otter pass
representative michael moffatt for the
majority of the committee
minority of the committee
having considered
considered the same in being unable to
agree with the majority report with the
following resolution resolved that is
inexpedient to legislate senator israel
p deidre deidra for the minority of the
committee
representative le branch offers floor
amendment
l
it's in your seat pockets
the chair recognizes representative le
branch
thank you mr speaker
mr speaker
honorable colleagues
i rise today to offer an amendment
located in your seat pockets if you'd
like to read along
to house concurrent resolution 7
reaffirming our support for the nation
of israel and the location of the
embassy therein
what my amendment seeks to do is make
this resolution less controversial by
removing the section relating to the
moving of the embassy to jerusalem and
by adding a section about supporting the
israel israeli-palestinian peace process
the moving of the embassy to jerusalem
was a very controversial one
as jerusalem is claimed by both israel
and palestine
the united states should not be picking
aside in this decades-long conflict and
should serve instead as a neutral
arbiter
the united states cannot be considered a
neutral arbiter if it is picking a side
on who owns jerusalem
secondly it adds after the section about
reaffirming our support for israel and i
quote
that the new hampshire general court
recognizes the right of the palestinian
people to exist and that the new
hampshire general court supports the
israeli-palestinian
peace process
now i believe that every member in this
house can agree that we support peace in
the middle east and for a peaceful
resolution to this conflict
this is why i ask for a roll call so
that we can see who stands for peace and
who does not
i believe that if this amendment were to
pass that we would pass this underlying
resolution unanimously
that is why i ask for your support on
this important amendment and to please
press the green button thank you
house will be in order
some of the branches requested a roll
calls that sufficiently seconded
is sufficiently seconded this will be a
roll call vote we're on our final
speaker members take your seats
chair recognizes representative silber
thank you mr speaker
one of my arab american
friends and colleagues representative
abbas was waiting to to call for
a roll call vote anyhow
this amendment and the underlying
resolution
is both
substantive
and highly symbolic
if you read the underlying resolution
chcr7
merely a
clear restatement
of american foreign policy
american foreign policy that has existed
now
for decades essentially since shortly
after the founding of the state of
israel in the mid-40s
the move to the embassy
was voted by the congress of the united
states
many years ago
under several administrations and
finally was implemented under the trump
administration
before the embassy and before israel
took back control of jerusalem
in the 67 war when it was under the
control of jordan
the three religions that called
jerusalem a holy site were not all
allowed
access
but now they are
if you look at this amendment
it basically guts the underlying
resolution completely
for a peace process to work
the parties involved in the conflict
all the parties involved in the conflict
must want peace
must advocate peace
that is not the case with the so-called
palestinian people
they
their principal spokesman
are from a designated terrorist
organization called hamas
hamas has in its charter
its goal of the destruction of the state
of israel
fails to recognize the right of the
state of israel to exist
controls the gaza strip from which it
builds underground tunnels to infiltrate
terrorists into the state of israel
reigns rockets down
on civilians in the state of israel
the member will suspend stage
appointment
stage a point of order i believe uh the
member uh unfairly generalized a whole
group of people
into a one terrorist organization
and i don't think that's fair there's
there are separate individuals here
mr chairman it's a matter of fact that
the hamas is the principal spokesman of
the palestinian people
the
hamas hamas
hamas's
hamas statement
which has been repeated
which has been repeated publicly
in the last couple of months by a member
of this very house
from the river to the sea palestine will
be free
and that means that they want to push
all the jews out of israel into the
mediterranean kill the jews that's what
they want so that's what this amendment
will stand for
so i urge you
to vote no on this amendment thank you
the
house will be in order
for what reason does a member rise i'd
like to make a motion mr speaker
state your motion
i would like to move to table this bill
i think it's all gotten out of order
it's not debatable excuse me i apologize
i just moved to table it then
the motion before us is the table
hcr7
are you ready for the question
a division has been requested members
take their seats
roll call has been requested is that
sufficiently seconded it is sufficiently
seconded this will be a roll call vote
what's up
oh
members need to be in your seats
the chair recognizes the representative
accident for a parliamentary inquiry
thank you mr speaker
mr speaker if i know
that
for reasons that are far larger than
this room
that the conflict between
israel and palestine
that has gone on for nearly a century
now
is so
not going to be solved by the new
hampshire house at 9 00 pm at night
would i then
agree with the wise decision from my
colleague from newbury to table this hcr
thank you
geo recognized representative val
disarro for parliamentary inquiry thank
you mr speaker fellow representatives
under uh rule 30 my committee is
required
this is a parliamentary inquiry
let me try to listen to the word i use
fellow representatives if you know that
my committee is required
mr speaker i got people shaking their
head here and if you read here if i know
i know you know okay read the damn sheet
i have the sheet mr speaker
okay i'm going to try it again thank you
the house will be in order
mr speaker
let me make it simple so if you know out
there
that my committee
understands we are required to rule 30
which is we have to listen to
resolutions
and if i know
that i give the respect to every state
representative that comes in with a
resolution for the last 16 years or the
two times i've been the chair in that
committee
to give you and listen and vote properly
as a committee and mr speaker if my
committee and i know
that this should have never gone to that
resolute that amendment in the speech
that we had and if i know here i try to
stop that amendment earlier working with
my ranking member and if you know the
whole story of what's going on here this
is a resolution about a building being
moved
nothing about palestine or jurism and if
you know all that will you support me in
go against this table motion thank you
[Music]
house will be in order
the motion before us is the table cacr7
hcr7
this is a roll call vote
if you're in favor you'll press the
green button if you're impulse you'll
press the red button voting stations are
open for 30 seconds
representative
so
if all members president had an
opportunity to vote
house will attend to the state of the
vote
150 yays
155 knees the tabling motion fails
let me quickly explain what's going to
happen here
we're going to go right into
we've already had the debate on the
amendment so we're going to go right
into the vote presidential branch has
requested a roll call is that
sufficiently seconded
it is sufficiently seconded this is
going to be a roll call vote with just
parliamentary inquiries
the chair recognizes representatives
yes
oh
the motion before us is a blanche floor
amendment
this is a roll call vote the chair
recognizes representative branch for
parliamentary inquiry
is this a roll call on the bill itself
for the amendment roll call on the
amendment
mr speaker
if i stand for peace and if i know that
not
[Music]
mr speaker if i stand for peace and if i
know
not all
palestinians are part of hamas
and if i know that this if this
amendment passes we will pass this
resolution unanimously would i now press
the green button
jay reckon has ripped in a belt of
sorrow for parliamentary inquiry
thank you mr speaker mr speaker if i
know that this amendment's not going to
go anywhere and it wasted a little bit
of time god bless them mr speaker
and if you know as i do that
let's just vote this thing down and move
on thank you
the motion before us is a branch floor
amendment this is a roll call vote if
you're in favor you'll press the green
button if you're opposed you'll press
the red button voting stations are open
for 30 seconds
is
representative mann
representative